Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Äh, heute leider kein Schnitzel?
Ja, sehr sehr schade.
Warum kein Schnitzel? Das Kind ist wieder in der Schule, aber es wurde erst heute Morgen freigetestet. Und es ist tatsächlich so bis Samstag Mittag oder so war völlig unklar, ob Deutschland überhaupt die Infrastruktur bereithält, um ein aus der Isolierung befreites Kind an einem Schultag vor neun Uhr noch freitesten zu können oder ob alle Teststationen sagen, nee, leider, geht nicht.
Ja, also das war Spannung und das bedeutet aber, dass es dem Kind gut geht und euch auch gut geht. Also ihr habt keine Symptome in irgendeiner Weise jetzt.
Niemand hat irgendwas. Am Montag rief mich meine große Tochter aus der Schule an. Papa, mein Test war gerade positiv, hat mich nicht allzu sehr gewundert, weil sie war ja am Freitag zu Hause. Wir haben sie zu Hause gelassen. Wir haben ihr einen Fernsehtag gegönnt, da sie sonst nie krank ist, aber sagte, oh irgendwie, keine Ahnung, mir geht es nicht so gut. Ich bin dann hin zum Kind und habe Fieber gemessen und habe festgestellt, 39, 1. Das ist aber viel. Wie geht es dir denn? Mir ist ein bisschen warm. Also es war ganz komisch. Das war so, als wäre Fieber gar nicht symptomatisch für irgendwas, sondern als wäre es einfach nur mal Fieber. Das war jetzt nicht mit Unruhe sein oder so.
Und dann auch sofort wieder weg, also dass man eigentlich dachte, ist doch nichts.
Es war, dass sie am Dienstag geimpft wurde, das zweite Mal.
Ach so.
Haben wir gedacht, es ist eine verzögerte Impfreaktion. Weil bei Jontek, auch in der Kinderdosis, ein Drittel ist das ja nur, hieß es ja trotzdem, ja ja, kann durchaus mal und so weiter, aber so drei Tage zu spät halt. Wahrscheinlich ist einfach Virus und Impfung um die Wette gelaufen und beide Dienstag irgendwie und dann drei Tage Inkubation und Impfung hat aber schon soweit und so, keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls war sie dann Freitag so ein bisschen kränklich. Samstag haben wir Captain Marvel geguckt, nee Captain America haben wir geguckt. Wir wollten jetzt mal die Marvel-Reihe so chronologisch, wie das halt so die Cool Kids machen. Und da taucht ja der deutsche Sondern-Hydra-Nazi mit rotem Gesicht und so weiter auf. Hat sie ein bisschen gruselig, deswegen hat sie dann die Nacht noch bei uns im Bett gelegen. Also ich habe jetzt original 8 Stunden Infektiosität direkt neben mir gehabt, aber es hat sich nirgendwo niedergeschlagen. Und Montag war dann dieser positive Test, was ja bedeutet, Papa, ich stehe schon auf der Straße. Die haben mich ja schon aus der Schule rausgeschickt. Ich komme jetzt nach Hause. Zum Glück hast du nur einen Fußweg, weil was ist sonst die Botschaft an die Kinder? Geh nach Hause, weil du darfst ja keinen Nahverkehr mehr benutzen oder was? Also es ist ganz merkwürdig.
Es ist bisweilen dramatisch. Mir hat ein Vater erzählt, der zwei kleine Kinder hat, dass in Grundschulen dann geweint wird in den Klassen. Zum Teil sind da Eltern, die den Kindern enorme Angst vor Corona gemacht haben. Das heißt, wenn die positiv getestet werden, denken die weiß Gott, was dann passiert. Lehrer zum Teil reagieren nicht unbedingt der Lage entsprechend oder verbreiten dann noch mit Panik. Die Freundinnen und Freunde solidarisieren sich mit vielen Tränen. Das sind sehr unschöne Szenen, sagt er, die da stattfinden. Das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was hoffentlich sehr bald endet. Was sich ja hier in dem Fall zeigt, bei dir ist, dass es ja offenbar eine gute Impfwirkung gibt und dass das bei euch jetzt gar kein Problem war. Insofern hoffe ich ja auch, wenn ich dann mal eine Begegnung mit Omikron habe, dass das dann auch so sein wird, dass ich dann nur ein bisschen vielleicht mal Fieber habe oder gar nichts habe.
Wer weiß. Ja, es gibt ja diese neue Studie zur Superimmunität durch die Kombination Biontech, Moderna, wie auch immer, plus Omikron oder Delta. Am besten natürlich Omikron, weil es weniger Krankheit bedeutet. Jetzt bin ich leider drum rumgekommen. Das ist natürlich auch schade.
Ja, wer weiß? Vielleicht hast du es ja.
Oder so.
Aber du hast es nicht als Symptom. Das kann ja auch noch sein, aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Es gibt so ganz viele Sachen, die weiß man jetzt einfach nicht. Wie zum Beispiel, wenn dein Körper Kontakt mit dem Virus macht, es aber abwehrt, sodass es zu dieser Schleimhautreplikation und so weiter nicht kommt. Also der Antigentest auch nicht anspringt entsprechend, weil ich lasse mich ja dann abends, bevor ich außer Haus gehe, testen. Also Mittwoch, also jetzt die Woche Mittwoch, letzte Woche Mittwoch, Freitag und dann gestern nochmal. Und die waren immer also richtig krass negativ. Wir mussten auch dadurch, dass der PCR-Test am Ende, den wir am Montag beim Kind gemacht haben, bei CT29 war, also eine Stufe vor dem Freitesten, haben wir auch zu Hause dann nochmal einen Schnelltest gemacht gehabt. Und da musste man recht mit der Lupe hinschauen und alle Lichter anmachen, um das überhaupt zu sehen, dass da noch ein Streifen war. Jetzt haben wir die Woche über natürlich genau hingeschaut, die auch richtig durchtrocknen lassen, aber es war nichts zu sehen. Hat mein Körper jetzt trotzdem Omikron? Also mein Körper hat ja auf jeden Fall ein Omikronvirus mal gesehen. Aber wurde das jetzt wieder zu früh abgewehrt? Also habe ich jetzt eine breitere Immunisierung als nur die Impfung gibt, dadurch, dass das ganze Virus jetzt mal Hallo gesagt hat oder nicht? Weiß man alles nicht, ist ein bisschen unklar, ist natürlich auch ein bisschen schade. Aber ich denke mir dann irgendwie, naja, wenn ich acht Stunden neben dem infektiösen Kind liege, wann sonst soll ich mich dann infizieren? Also dann kann ja wohl jede andere Lebenslage, in die man so kommt, ist ja, ich bin ja nicht daran an und in der Ansicht hatten wir jetzt letzte Woche eine Corona-Ferien. Das hat ja Kikule immer empfohlen. Also meine Frau hat dann auch die anderen beiden Kinder vorsorglich nicht in die Kita und in die Schule geschickt, sodass wir einfach zu Hause so eine Art Winterferien gemacht haben. Es war auch für alle Beteiligten ganz nett. Umso trauriger, dass natürlich heute Morgen das Kind wieder freigetestet wurde, denn Drive-in-mäßig hat es dann doch noch geklappt, sie vor der Schule freizutesten. Was auch wieder bedeutet, es standen ja heute... Also freitesten heißt ja eigentlich, du bist mehrere Tage, nämlich zwei mindestens symptomfrei und dann laufen auch sieben Tage nach PCR-Ergebnis und so weiter. Dann kannst du dich ja freitesten. Und auch da muss man wieder sagen, es ist so irre, weil es ist ja Montag. Die werden ja ohnehin in der Schule getestet, statt also einfach den Test für das Kind in Frage, im Zweifel, noch schnell vor der Schule oder in so einem Container oder so machen zu können. Nein, du musst sieben Uhr nochmal vorstellig werden bei irgendeinem zertifizierten Antigen-Tester, der auch nichts anderes macht, als das, was die Kinder geübt haben die letzten Monate, nämlich sich mehrfach die Woche zu testen. Also es geht runter und drüber. Wir machen es uns so schwer, so kompliziert. Die Schule hat über 1000 Kinder und die Inzidenz ist über 2000. Lohnt es sich dann nicht, innerhalb der Schule eine PCR-Abnahmestation einzurichten? Eine freie Teststation müssen die Kinder und sie dürfen in dem Moment nicht den Nahverkehr benutzen, nochmal durch die halbe Stadt. Also es ist auch amüsant dadurch, dass eigentlich keine Krankheit dahinter steckt. Wir mussten jetzt nicht mit einem hustenfiebernden, schüttelfrostenden Kind irgendwie da noch zur PCR-Station. Diese Dramen sieht man dann aber auch, wenn man an der offiziellen Teststation des Uniklinik Frankfurt, der große Uniklinik Frankfurt ist, und man verschickt Bilder, man darf natürlich dort keine Bilder machen, aber ich habe trotzdem eins gemacht, verschickt das so an seine typischen Chatgruppen und kriegt nur die Antwort, oh, das sieht aber echt aus wie beim UNHCR in Pakistan, wenn es Essen ausgegeben wird. Und so ist es auch, das ist wirklich keine schöne Lage. Und wenn man dann immer liest, was in Dänemark los ist, wie es in Österreich funktioniert, ist man auch ein bisschen traurig über diesen deutschen Zustand.
Ja, und es hätte alles anders sein können. Interessant ist, dass ja das mit den Tests etwas war, was wir hier früh aufgegriffen haben, also nicht nur PCR-Tests, sondern die Schnelltests und wie lange das alles gedauert hat. Warum Deutschland sich da so versperrt hat, ist mir immer noch nicht nachvollziehbar. Auch nicht nachvollziehbar, dass es jetzt nicht dann endlich mal vernünftig funktioniert. Woran liegt es dann? Ich meine, es sind ja jetzt schon Leute unendlich reich durch diese Tests geworden, aber man hätte ja vielleicht dann, wenn man da einige so begünstigt, doch wenigstens trotzdem eine gute Infrastruktur hinbekommen können. Das würde mich ja gar nicht stören, wenn da manche Leute sagen, ich kann mir jetzt jeden Monat noch einen Ferrari kaufen, weil ich so viel teste. Aber es sollte dann auch funktionieren und dass das alles so irre ist und man dann auch gar nicht mehr irgendwann nachvollziehen kann, wie dann noch sinnvoll getestet werden kann. Also da ist man ja kurz davor zu kapitulieren und zu sagen, dann lassen wir das jetzt halt einfach mit den Tests sein. Und dann guckt man, wenn man sich krank fühlt, dann bleibt man daheim und sonst geht man wieder. Also das ist ja eine Konsequenz, die da ausfolgt. Es ist sehr absurd und man kann nur hoffen, dass das dann doch jetzt schnell vorübergeht. Und ich hoffe dann auch, dass wir Ende des Monats, also Ende Februar, uns wieder treffen, dass wir dann uns wieder wahrhaft gegenüber sitzen und dann auch Schnitzel essen gehen können. Denn das ist ja schon etwas, was zum Leben dazugehört. Zum Leben dazugehört auch die Ethik zu fragen, was geht, was soll, was darf, was kann. Und es gab ja in diesem Monat eine große Debatte im Bundestag zur Impfpflicht. Ich habe mir die Debatte nicht angesehen. Ich habe nur ein bisschen was mir dann in der Tagesschau oder so dazu angesehen. Es hat mir auch eigentlich genügt. Ich habe aber unsere ja unseren Expertenrat natürlich hin und wieder verfolgt. Wir wissen ja, wir haben nicht nur eine recht langsame Stiko, sondern wir haben auch eine noch viel langsame und auch sonst nicht besonders geistreiche Ethikratskommission. Einen Ethikrat, der entscheiden soll, brauchen wir eigentlich eine Impfpflicht oder nicht und wenn ja, für wen und wann usw. usf. Das ist ja etwas, was den Ethikrat schon länger beschäftigt hat. Mich stört an dieser Ethikrat, am Ethikrat wie an der Impfpflichtdebatte, dass das so unglaublich nivellos ist, was da an Wortbeiträgen kommt. Also wenn man nicht in der Lage ist, ein bisschen intelligenter darüber zu diskutieren, dann sind wir wirklich arm dran und ich will jetzt einfach mal symptomatisch einen Ausschnitt vorspielen, nicht vom Ethikrat, sondern von einer Virologin von Melanie Brinkmann, die sagte Folgendes im November bei Markus Lanz.
Und haben wir uns nicht eigentlich schon für eine Impfpflicht oder haben wir uns da nicht demokratisch schon für entschieden? Ich meine, 77 Prozent in Deutschland, die sich impfen lassen können, haben sich schon geimpft. Das ist doch eigentlich schon eine demokratische Abstimmung, oder?
Ja, ist es nicht. Das ist doch keine demokratische Abstimmung. Und da widerspricht auch dann niemand im Saal. Und man fragt sich, wie kann denn das sein? Also da kann ich auch sagen, die meisten Menschen sind verheiratet, aber das ist keine demokratische Abstimmung dafür, dass alle heiraten müssen. Also was soll denn das? Also das kann doch nicht sein. Man kann sagen, ja, offenbar sind die meisten Leute für die Impfung und erachten die als gut. Und deswegen könnte auch für eine Impfpflicht ein großes Verständnis in der breiten Bevölkerung sein. Aber zu unterstellen, dass jeder, der sich impfen ließ, zugleich auch für eine Impfpflicht ist, das ist ja was anderes. Also das kann man nicht miteinander vermischen.
Genau. Und das allerdings ist auch der eine große Kritikpunkt, der sich über, also wirklich über drei, also mehr als dreieinhalb Stunden Impfpflichtdebatte im Bundestag gespannt, dass da wirklich, wir hören es auch nachher nochmal, jeder junge Neue im Bundestag nochmal ans Rednerpool tritt, um nochmal zu sagen, was die 20 Redner vorher und auch die zehn folgenden noch sagen werden, nämlich, dass die Impfung eine wichtige Sache ist, dass aber eine Impfpflicht zur Diskussion stand. Das hat man kaum gemerkt an dieser Debatte. Es war ganz merkwürdig, so richtig am Thema vorbei. Viele meinten ja irgendwie, das sind diese Debatten, die Sternstunden-Debatten, wenn es um den Körper geht, um Leben und Tod und so weiter. Man hat das dann immer verglichen mit, ja, so war das auch bei der Organspende, bei der Sterbehilfe wie auch so. Robin Alexander hat dazu in seinem Podcast einfach Machtwechsleister. Der hat das sehr gut gesagt. Das ist alles Unsinn. Die ganze Debatte ist Unsinn. Es geht nur um eine Impfung. Und das ist der beste Kommentar überhaupt dazu. Insbesondere auch, weil er einfach in zehn Sekunden abgehandelt ist. Also es ist ein unglaubliches Gelaber völlig am Thema vorbei in Deutschland. Auf allen Ebenen.
Ja, bleiben wir mal bei der Impfpflicht, um das nochmal zu betonen. Ich habe überhaupt gar kein Problem mit einer Impfpflicht. Ich habe das von Anfang an nie ein Problem damit gehabt. Hab gedacht, das ist nicht nötig, überhaupt darüber nachzudenken, weil ich dachte, alle Leute rennen wie ich möglichst schnell irgendwo hin, wo man sich impfen lassen kann. Aber offenbar war es dann doch ein bisschen anders. Jedenfalls habe ich gar kein Problem damit und würde auch zunächst einmal in Frage stellen, ob man nicht da eine merkwürdige Fokussierung auf körperliche Unversehrtheit vornimmt, wo man also die ganze Zeit sagt, oh ja, das ist noch mal ein ganz besonderer Eingriff. Das kann es natürlich sein. Aber ich würde jetzt dem auch mal einen anderen Wert entgegensetzen, zum Beispiel den Wert der Diskretion. Also dir drei Spritzen geben zu lassen, finde ich erstmal nicht so schwierig. Ich gehe entweder zum Arzt oder gehe in ein Impfzentrum. Und da bin ich sehr anonym. Da muss ich zwar meine Daten hinterlegen, aber da ist eine Ärzteschaft, die mit Patienten umzugehen weiß und die sich vollkommen korrekt verhält und so weiter und so fort. Aber für mich ist es ein viel größerer Eingriff. Und das ist jetzt nur mein persönliches Empfinden. Wenn ich überall, wo ich hingehe, meine Adresse, meine Handynummer liegen lassen soll, wo ich auch nochmal abgeglichen werde, meinen Impfausweis mit meinem Personalausweis und und und. Also nicht, dass ich mich jetzt nur in der Halbwelt aufhalte, aber ich möchte doch eigentlich eine Unbeschwertheit im Leben haben und nicht die ganze Zeit Personalausweis und sonst was zücken müssen. Für mich ist das ein viel größerer Eingriff, dass ich die ganze Zeit dem so ausgesetzt bin und immer zeigen muss, ja, hier, ich bin es und ich bin auch schon dreimal geimpft und ich bin so und so alt. Das ist für mich wirklich etwas, was mich viel mehr stört. Also ich fand diese drei Spritzen mir abzuholen viel unproblematischer. Insofern würde ich auch einfach mal sagen, diese körperliche Unversehrtheit, wo da immer drauf abgezieht wird, das ist auch ein gewisser Fetisch. Man kann das im Übrigen auch bei Agamben ganz gut nachvollziehen, der ja inzwischen auf einer ganz merkwürdigen Seite angelangt ist, der ja eigentlich schon Corona-Leugner ist.
So würde ich schon sagen, immer schon. Mir kamen im Studium schon immer die Leute mit ihrem Agamben, Agamben. Ich habe das dann immer gelesen, Ausnahmezustand. Ich habe gesagt, Leute, das ist irgendwie total verdreht. Jetzt stellen es irgendwie alle fest.
Agamben hat sich ja zum Beispiel dann irgendwann geweigert, zu fliegen, weil er da einen Fingerabdruck lassen musste. Und dann hat Slawe Scherzkek immer zurecht gesagt, ja, aber was soll jetzt der Fingerabdruck irgendwie intimes von mir sein? Intimeres sein als das, was ich sonst die ganze Zeit von mir preisgeben muss. Aber dann hat Agamben auch immer so eine Fokussierung davor genommen und so eine Fetischisierung. Das ist jetzt der Fingerabdruck. Das ist die Identität. Und Scherzkek hat dann gesagt, wieso ist das die Identität? Und ich würde auch hier sagen, warum müssen wir jetzt die ganze Zeit über diese drei Spritzen diskutieren? Aber nun ist es nun mal so, und ich will ja auch diese Debatte ernst nehmen und gerade deshalb ärgert mich dann es so kolossal, wenn der Ethikrat eigentlich nur Nonsens von sich gibt. Und ich möchte jetzt erstmal einen Clip vorspielen. März, Phoenix 2021, Alena Bücks ist zu Gast.
Wir haben für die Corona-Impfungen eine allgemeine Impfpflicht ausgeschlossen.
So, hat man ausgeschlossen? Damals wusste man, die Impfung wirkt sehr gut. Wir hatten da, ist ja noch mit einer anderen Variante zu tun. Inzwischen wirkt die Impfung auch sehr gut, aber Infektion kann durchaus möglich sein. Das war damals noch viel besser, die Zahlen. Da hat man gedacht, Mensch, das ist ja schon fast bombensicher, wenn man da mit mRNA oder so geimpft ist. Aber trotzdem, man hat es ausgeschlossen. Jetzt die Begründung.
Da gibt es verschiedene Gründe. Einmal haben wir gesagt, das sollte, wenn möglich, immer auf der informierten Einwilligung beruhen. Aber zweitens haben wir ja auch eine ganz, ganz unterschiedliche Risikoverteilung in der Bevölkerung. Und wir haben gesagt, nur dann, wenn es wirklich sicher wäre, dass Geimpfte nicht mehr ansteckend sind, das ist die erste Voraussetzung, da bewegen wir uns ja so langsam hin. Und wenn es keine andere Möglichkeit gäbe, bestimmte, ganz verletzliche Gruppen zu schützen, könnte man für bestimmte Berufe über eine Impfpflicht nachdenken.
So, ja, ganz vorsichtig formuliert und gesagt, na ja, vielleicht für bestimmte Berufe. Also natürlich Pflege im Altenheim könnte geimpft, könnte das Geimpft sein zur Pflicht werden. Aber wichtig ist auch, dass die Geimpften nicht noch das Virus weitergeben können. Jetzt wissen wir ja, das kann aber alles passieren. Also haben wir eigentlich jetzt noch schlechtere Voraussetzungen für eine Impfpflicht bei Omikron, als wir sie damals hatten. Der Ethikrat aber jetzt ändert ja seine Meinung. Dazu kommen wir gleich. Aber ich will das einfach mal festhalten, denn es gehört auch dazu, dass wir mal dokumentieren, was vor paar Monaten noch ganz klar ausgeschlossen wurde.
Es gibt aber andere Möglichkeiten, diese sehr vulnerablen Menschen zu schützen. Und deswegen glaube ich, also von der allgemeinen Impfpflicht sowieso, das halte ich ganz klar für etwas, was wir hoffentlich nicht brauchen werden, aber was wir auch aus ethischer Perspektive tatsächlich klar ausgeschlossen haben. Ich glaube aber auch, dass selbst diese eingeschränkte berufsbezogene Impfpflicht nicht notwendig sein wird.
Ja, Alena Büchs zeichnet sich ja dadurch aus, dass sie in vielen Talkshows zu Gast ist und auch so ein bisschen getrieben ist, dort aber dann immer besonders geruhsam redet. Angestrengt geruhsam, würde ich mal sagen. Und März 2021, da wissen wir alle noch, was wir diskutiert haben. Wir haben im Salon zum Beispiel Texte gelesen, auch so unter Belustigung, wie irgendwelche britischen Landclubs reisen nach Dubai oder so für 45.000 Pfund anbieten und dann holt man sich da schnell seine Impfung ab, sozusagen drei Monate, bevor man sie regulär bekommen hätte. Also man drängelt einfach vor, was man sich leisten kann. Oder werden in Deutschland Bürgermeister, die nicht ganz begründen konnten, warum sie schon im Dezember geimpft wurden. Ah, die haben sich also auch vorgedrängelt. Große, große Skandale, dass es nur drei, vier Monate später plötzlich die Impfverweiger so wichtig sind, konnte man da gar nicht antizipieren. Also drehte sich auch die Debatte, und das haben wir ja bei der Impfpflicht jetzt auch, dass alle noch mal dazu sagen, da habe ich meine Meinung geändert. Und wir sehen, wir fühlen ja gerade, wenn wir auch schon wieder Söder im Fernsehen sehen, wie er sagt, Omikron ist gar keine Wand, sondern eine Tür, durch die wir schreiten müssen, und das hat ja der Drosten auch gesagt und so. Wir fühlen eigentlich, dass wir schon im nächsten Monat ganz anders wieder darüber reden. Und dass auch die Impfpflicht, ich habe meine Meinung geändert, auch nur so ein Piek war. Und man dann doch wieder anschließt anders zuvor. Also diese Argumente von März, die du hier nochmal dokumentierst, sind ja nicht aus der Welt. Die sind ja auch nicht aufgehoben, sondern die werden ganz schnell wieder reaktualisiert. Im März 2022 wahrscheinlich.
Genau, und nur weil sich die Lagen verändern, kann man ja trotzdem kategorische Aussagen treffen. Also es ist ja keineswegs so, nur weil jetzt das Virus sich verändert hat, oder der Wirkstoff so oder so gut ist, dass man damit grundsätzlich in Frage stellt, ob es sinnvoll ist, eine Impfpflicht einzuführen oder nicht. Und tatsächlich aktualisieren sich dann hier gewisse Aussagen wieder. Umso verwunderter ist man, dass der Ethikrat jetzt aber tatsächlich eher Richtung Fürimpflicht geht, wo jetzt eigentlich weniger dagegen spricht. Und meine These ist, der Ethikrat ist eigentlich nur dazu eingesetzt, um ein bisschen zu legitimieren, was die Politik macht. Damals war es so, dass Spahn auf keinen Fall eine Impfpflicht wollte. Also hat der Ethikrat gesagt, wir wollen auf keinen Fall eine Impfpflicht, das können wir ausschließen ethisch. Und nun möchte man eine Impfpflicht, jetzt wird der Ethikrat wieder in diese Richtung gehen. Also man fragt sich eigentlich, wofür sind die da? Also das ist eigentlich nur so ein bisschen Diskurs bespielen, Talkshows munter machen und ein bisschen das stützen, was politisch entschieden wird. Das geht dann bis zu Aussagen wie im Spiegel, da war Alena Büx im Interview und sagte, es gab auch große Aufregungen und Kontroverse, bevor die Gurtpflicht oder das Rauchverbot eingeführt wurde. Aber sobald beides Gesetz war, ebte die Empörung rasch ab. Das meint sie zum Thema Impfpflicht. Und dann muss ich sagen, ja, Leute gewöhnen sich an alles. Aber das kann doch kein ethisches Argument sein. Also wo sind wir denn jetzt da wirklich gelandet? Wenn ich dann sage, ja, die gewöhnen sich wohl an alles. Das ist einfach keine ethische Debatte. Und es ist dann folgendes. Sie ist im Morgenmagazin oder Mittagmagazin zu Gast. Jetzt also aktuell vor ein paar Tagen, ein paar Wochen. Und da wird sie natürlich darauf angesprochen, warum jetzt eigentlich die Ethikkommission ihre Haltung so verändert hat. Und wir müssen jetzt wirklich mal auf die Sprache achten, die hier gewählt wird.
Wir haben ja auch eine klare Strategie oder eine Sicherheit. Also von wem muss sich die Politik da leiten lassen?
Also da hätte ich mir wirklich eine ehrlichere, transparentere Kommunikation gewünscht. Denn man muss anpassen, wenn sich die Situation verändert. Es wäre völlig unverantwortlich, bei dem zu bleiben, was man vor einem Jahr gesagt hat, wenn die Situation anders ist. Da sollte man ganz proaktiv sagen, wir lernen dazu. Und dann passen wir an. Und ich glaube, das muss man so deutlich und transparent und ehrlich sagen. Ich bin mir sicher, die Bürgerinnen und Bürger verstehen das und wissen das auch. Das macht man ja im eigenen Leben auch die ganze Zeit. Aber das sollte man noch deutlich besser erklären.
Besser erklären, wir lernen proaktiv und, und, und. Ja, wir sind alle kleine Kinder. Und was ist das überhaupt für ein Demokratieverständnis, was dahintersteckt dann eigentlich noch? Also das ist dann, so kann ich mit einem Siebenjährigen vielleicht noch sprechen. Du weißt ja, du wolltest ja hören. Und deswegen höre jetzt mal bitte gut zu. Aber ich möchte so nicht angesprochen werden. Also wie gesagt, da ist bei mir sofort die Trotzhaltung da.
Das hat Merkel mitgebracht. Oder? Das ist auch so ein Erbe Merkels, dass wir immer wie Kindergartenkinder angesprochen werden. Und was mir hier immer wieder auffällt, du hast noch einen Clip, der heißt Revisionsoffen. Vielleicht warte ich den noch ab, bevor ich noch mal ein kleines...
Du hast jetzt schon verraten. Das ist nämlich das neue Wort, das wir nun lernen. Revisionsoffen. Ich habe dieses Wort da zum ersten Mal gehört. Man kann sich relativ leicht vorstellen, was es bedeutet. Revision kombiniert mit offen. Also wir ändern immer mal wieder unsere Meinung. Bei Adenauer war das eigentlich in einer schönen Ehrlichkeit noch formuliert, wenn er sagte, was stört mich, mein Geschwätz von gestern. Inzwischen nennt man sowas Revisionsoffen. Und ich habe diesen Begriff dann einfach mal gegoogelt. Ich dachte, wo gibt es eigentlich diesen Begriff? Taucht der irgendwo auf? Ich habe dann so ein merkwürdiges Manager-Ratgeberbuch gefunden. Da tauchte das auf. Dann habe ich eine Homepage gefunden für Klimaanlagen, die wohl zum Teil auch revisionsoffen sind, was immer das meinen mag. Und dann fand ich auch noch drei oder vier Tweets dazu, in denen der Begriff vorkam. Und diese Tweets aber, also die aktuelleren aus den letzten zwei Jahren, kamen alle von einer Person, die auch im Ethikrat ist. Dann dachte ich, aha, das ist also so eine Schöpfung des Ethikrats vor allem, dass man sich überlegt hat, gut, wir sagen ja eh ständig wieder irgendwas anderes. Wie können wir das in einen wunderbaren Mantel kleiden? Nennen wir das Ganze doch revisionsoffen.
Wenn sich Omikron ganz anders entwickelt, wenn sich alle anstecken, brauchen wir dann vielleicht gar keine Impfpflicht mehr?
Wir haben in unserer Empfehlung ja gesagt, weil wir die auch geschrieben haben, unter diesen ganz unsicheren dynamischen Umständen, das muss revisionsoffen bleiben. Man muss ganz genau hinschauen, wie entwickelt sich die Situation, was ist wann noch gerechtfertigt, welche Voraussetzungen muss man haben. Also man muss da einfach immer offen bleiben. Das ist anstrengend und schwierig. Und das macht die politische Gestaltung auch weiß Gott nicht einfacher. Aber so ist das.
So, wir sind ja hier angetreten, um auch so ein bisschen spontan zu historisieren. Das machen wir nachher auf extreme Weise, aber wir können es hier schon mal wieder üben. Revisionsoffenheit. Ich habe ja mit Dirk Becker für Redaktionsschluss vor fünf Jahren oder so auch mal über dieses Handyzeitalter gesprochen. Und da er so als, wie soll man sagen, Boomer, aber nicht auf die negative Art und Weise, sondern einfach aus dieser Boomer-Generation, der sich anschaut, wie auch seine Studenten und so weiter mit Smartphones umgehen. Und Revisionsoffenheit oder wie man auch immer diesen Begriff nutzt oder ausgestaltet, das ist heute Gang und Gebe. Das ist in Fleisch und Blut jedes Einzelnen. Während früher unsere Eltern noch, jetzt habe ich den Brief geschrieben, das ist die Sachlage und das gilt auch nächste Woche noch. Sitzen die Kinder da, ich habe doch gerade gesimst, ge-WhatsApp, was auch immer. Klar war das nur vorübergehend, weil ich habe jetzt meine Meinung geändert und dann schicke ich einfach an die nächste Nachricht hinterher und so weiter.
So wie Snapchat, einfach dann ist es weg nach 24 Stunden oder so.
Ganz genau, die letzte Nachricht kann sogar ganz verschwinden, aber sie kann auf jeden Fall immer revidiert werden. Die Eltern noch machen das Familienfoto und das ist dann das Foto für das ganze Jahr. Die Kinder machen halt alle fünf Minuten Neues mit dem Smartphone. Das gilt dann auch gar nicht als das ist fürs Archiv, sondern das ist halt die schnelle Kommunikation. Man macht halt einfach mal so ein Bild, man hält so einen Moment fest, aber der verfliegt auch das digitale Duplikat des Moments so schnell wie der Moment selbst. Und eigentlich ist ja die Aufgabe jetzt nicht revisionsoffen zu sein, sondern sich der Realität wieder zu stellen. Und jetzt kann man dem Ethikrat den gleichen Fehler unterstellen, den auch die deutsche Politik und die deutschen Wissenschaftsallgemeinen in der Beratung gemacht haben. Warum können die Dänen jede positive Probe sequenzieren, selbst bei einer Inzidenz von 2000? Und warum erwarte ich in Deutschland drei Tage auf das PCR-Ergebnis meiner Tochter oder auf das des Kindergartenfreundes? Dann darf nämlich erst der Kindergarten wieder aufmachen. Und warum steht nach drei Tagen, wenn das Ergebnis endlich da ist, immer noch drauf, die genaue Variante ist pending, dauert noch. Analyse dauert noch und wir alle wissen, diese Analyse kommt nie. Dem positiven PCR-Test wird nicht hinterhergeschrieben, eine Woche später, welche Variante das jetzt war. Warum schaffen das aber die Dänen? Warum können die Wiener alleine doppelt so viele PCR-Tests machen wie die Deutschen allgemein? Nur aus einem Grund, weil man sich dann irgendwann mal hingesetzt hat, als es hieß, Inzidenz ist gerade 5, niemand ist in Aufruhr, die meisten erwarten eigentlich gar keine nächste große Welle, sich die Daten anschaut und trotzdem antizipiert, was in drei Monaten, wenn die Temperaturen um den Nullpunkt zurückfallen, passiert. Wenn man das antizipiert, die Wissenschaft ernst nimmt, sich Omikron anschaut, auch im frühen Stadium und sagt, Infektiosität haben wir gesehen, die Impfung hilft auch nicht, wir müssen damit rechnen, dass hier eine mega Welle auf uns zukommt, dann muss man vorbereitend und dann, mit der entsprechenden Vorbereitung, ist man dann aber auch fertig im Oktober, November und kann das dann einsetzen. In Deutschland nie, in Deutschland ist man ja immer völlig überrascht und das ist auch Erbe Merkels. Man zieht so ein Inzidenzgrenzer ein von 50. Und erst wenn der überschritten ist, setzt man sich zusammen und überlegt, was man dann jetzt tut. Und dann legt man den neuen fest, 150. Und erst wenn der überschritten ist und dann wartet man noch eine Woche und dann kommt die politische Beratung dazu.
Und dann kann man nur noch irgendwann den Hammer auspacken und sagen, jetzt bleiben wir alle wieder zu Hause. Reden wir mal wieder ein schönes Buch zu Hause. Es ist doch eigentlich ganz toll, auch mal wieder bei der Familie zu sein. Und deswegen machen wir mal wieder einen kleinen Lockdown, nur vorübergehend, also für die nächsten vier Monate. So war das ja dann immer.
Und das ist nämlich dann die Einsicht, wir müssen schon wieder machen, was wir letztes Jahr gemacht haben, als wir aber noch sagen konnten, das muss jetzt sein, das ist ad hoc. Das ist im Grunde gar keine Politik, das ist Diktat durch das Virus. Und wir sind ja genau in diese Falle wieder reingetappt. Wir wurden ja wieder vom Virus, wurde ja die politische Entscheidung diktiert. Man konnte ja gar nicht anders entscheiden als so, wie es halt war.
Ja, ich bin sehr froh, dass jetzt wieder Politik gemacht wird, denn das war ja unsere Kritik, auch dass das keine Politik ist, wenn man einfach den Hahn aufdreht und den wieder komplett zutreht, sondern jetzt findet ja tatsächlich Politik statt. Auch wenn das mit den Testungen nicht vernünftig läuft, hat ja doch auch vieles geklappt. Und du hast ja recht behalten, sogar Scream 5 konnte ich im Kino sehen. Aber was ich jetzt Alena Bücks vorwerfe, ist, dass sie eben nichts antizipiert und auch gar nicht dazu bereit ist, sondern dann einfach sagt, ja, wir sind offen und proaktiv und sonst irgendwas. Sondern man muss ja auch im März 2021, wenn man im Ethikrat sitzt, eine Position dazu einnehmen, was ist, wenn sich nicht genügend Leute impfen lassen wollen. Und das ist ja nicht so, dass Ethik so funktioniert, dass man sagt, ja, wir hätten es ja toll gefunden, wenn alle sich freiwillig impfen lassen würden. Aber jetzt haben die das nicht. Deswegen ändern wir jetzt mal das Programm. Ethisch ändert sich an der Frage, darf der Staat eine Impfpflicht einführen oder nicht? Daran erst mal gar nichts. Also man kann ja nicht einfach sagen, naja, es wurden doch alle freundlich gebeten, jetzt wollen sie nicht, dann müssen wir sie freundlich zwingen. Das geht nicht. Also man kann entweder sagen, grundsätzlich darf der Staat sowas. Warum denn nicht? Ist doch kein Problem, solange die Impfung wirkt oder was. Aber man kann nicht sagen, wir hätten uns ja gerne das anders vorgestellt. Alle machen es freiwillig und wir müssten gar nicht entscheiden. Aber das ist ja keine ethische Haltung, die dazu eingenommen wird. Und ich finde wirklich diese entsetzliche Sprache, die jetzt überall auftaucht. Also das ist ja hier nur ein Paradebeispiel, dass sich das nicht mehr aushattet. Und ich bin sehr froh, dass ich den neuen Roman von Michel Houellebecq schon gelesen habe. Und da gibt es den Protagonisten Paul, der für den Finanzminister, Wirtschaftsminister arbeitet und der dann so eine Fahrt mit dem ICE macht. Und alles ist so, ja, wie miteinander gesprochen wird. Also da fehlen auch eigentlich nur noch die Worte proaktiv und revisionsoffen und und und. Und er schildert mal, was er davon eigentlich hält, dass jetzt in dieser Weise mit mir kommuniziert wird. Denn man erfährt das ja überall. Also gerade immer die schlimmen E-Mails, die man bekommt, wo man zu irgendwas genötigt wird oder so, die sind ja inzwischen nicht mehr als Befehl formuliert, sondern die sind ja in genau einer solchen Weise formuliert, wie das Büchs auch getan hat. War er für diese Welt mitverantwortlich? In gewisse Maße ja, er war Teil des Staatsapparats. Aber dennoch mochte er diese Welt nicht. Und Bruno, das wusste er, hätte sich auch nicht wohlgefühlt in diesen Bürgerkreationen, diesen Zen-Bereichen, in denen man sich während der Fahrt den Nacken massieren lassen und dabei Vogelgesang hören konnte, dieser merkwürdigen Gepäcketikettierung aus Sicherheitsgründen, kurzum der allgemeinen Wendung, die die Dinge genommen hatten, mit diesem Pseudoverspielten, in Wahrheit aber auf eine quasi faschistische Weise normativen Ambiente, das Stück für Stück die letzten Winkel des alltäglichen Lebens infiziert hatte. Ja, infiziert kommt da nochmal vor. Ganz furchtbar diese Sprache. Ich reagiere da zunehmend allergisch drauf und möchte dann lieber klare Ansagen haben. Und vor allem möchte ich auch darauf hinweisen, die Impfpflichtdebatte ist jetzt, wie du schon zu Recht sagst, nicht die große Sternstunde. Und hier entscheidet sich jetzt nicht wohl und weh der modernen liberalen Demokratie, sondern ich glaube, es kommen da ganz andere ethische Herausforderungen auf uns zu. Das Deutschlandradio hatte einen Beitrag zum Thema Reproduktionsmedizin und wie der Koalitionsvertrag da aufgesetzt ist. Und das hat mich doch in gewisser Weise irritiert, auch schockiert. Und ich glaube, ich habe aber schon jemand gefunden für den Vorsitz des Ethikrats. Also ich würde sagen, da müsste man mal neu besetzen. Und ich habe da glaube ich schon eine Person gefunden, die ich ganz gut finde. Aber wir hören erstmal in den Beitrag rein.
Schwangerschaftsabbruch, Eizellspende und Leihmutterschaft. Im Koalitionsvertrag klingt das nach einer Art Dreiklang der reproduktiven Selbstbestimmung, so die Überschrift des Kapitels.
Ja, Leihmutterschaft. Wir haben schon darüber gesprochen, dass wir sehr froh sind, dass man jetzt Familie anders einmal noch versteht, als das bislang getan wurde. Einfach, weil man es an die Wirklichkeit auch anpasst und weil auch Wahlverwandtschaft all das eine wichtige Rolle spielen muss. Wir müssen da modern werden. Ich würde aber sagen, dass es auch Felder gibt, bei denen es nicht jetzt einfach darum geht, sich an einen Zeitgeist anzupassen. Und wir hören jetzt Thaleo Stübe vom genetischen Netzwerk, die sich in diesem Netzwerk kritisch mit dem auseinandersetzen, was da vielleicht auf uns zukommt.
Thaleo Stübe vom genetischen Netzwerk sagt.
Ich war tatsächlich überrascht, wie der Satz formuliert ist. Es ist so in einem Atemzug benannt. Ich verstehe die reproduktive Selbstbestimmung da eher im Bezug auf den Schwangerschaftsabbruch. Ich sehe da aber eben eine Gefahr, das so zusammenzulegen, weil es lässt sich aus einer reproduktiven Selbstbestimmung meines Erachtens kein Recht auf Eizelspende oder auch kein Recht auf Leihmutterschaft ableiten.
Das ist aber ein großes Fass, das du aufmachst.
Naja, ich glaube, man muss da schon mal drüber reden. Also gerade bei Leihmutterschaft haben wir es ja schon mit einer Realität zu tun. Also ob jetzt in der Ukraine oder auch in anderen Ländern gibt es Leihmütter und die werden auch frequentiert. Und jetzt versucht dieser Koalitionsvertrag auch zu prüfen. Und wer weiß, ob da der Ethikrat dann auch wieder eine gewisse Rolle spielt, ob man diese Leihmutterschaft in Deutschland genehmigen soll. Ich kann ganz klar sagen, ich bin strikt dagegen. Und würde auch da ganz klar die Haltung von Stüve teilen. Wir könnten da mal reinhören, was sie da sagt. Es ist nämlich ein Paradigmenwechsel, der da stattfindet.
Das mögliche Vorhaben der Ampelkoalition bezeichnet Thalio Stüve als Paradigmenwechsel.
Weil das ein Zugriff auf Körper Dritter ist, die keinen eigenen Zweck von dem Eingriff haben. Fremdnützige Eingriffe bedeuten eine Grenzüberschreitung. Und im deutschen Recht sind die bisher nur dann zulässig, wenn die einen medizinischen Nutzen haben. Bei der Organspende z.B. oder auch Knochenmarkspende, Blutspende. Das wäre eben eine noch stärkere Verschiebung hin zu einer Wunscherfüllung.
Also wir können das ja...
Diese Wunscherfüllung finde ich hoch problematisch. Ich kann diesen Wunsch in gewisser Weise dann gedanklich nachvollziehen und sagen, das mag auch eine große Not sein, wenn man jetzt Kinder haben möchte. Und das geht aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht. Entweder aus gesundheitlichen Gründen oder aufgrund der Parkkonstellation geht das nicht. Aber auch da, würde ich sagen, sind klare Grenzen gesetzt. Beziehungsweise gibt es ja auch Mittel und Wege, wenn man jetzt Kinder haben will, also eine Familie haben will. Zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit der Adoption.
Ja, genau. Adoption. Also es gibt ganz viele Modelle. Man darf das immer nicht so verengen. Und es lohnt sich auch hier wieder, das so im großen historischen Bogen zu spannen. Lin hat mir mal, die Biologin Lin, unsere Biologin, die hat mir mal einen Hinweis geschickt für die Rentnerpublik, auch aus Japan, mit so einem Hinweis, das könnte man sich jetzt auch in Deutschland und Italien mal anschauen. In den Ländern, wo die Demografie als erstes in Schrumpfung kippt, was ja in Deutschland auf jeden Fall der Fall ist, in Japan auch, da werden die Anerkennung von Früchen fällt dann immer früher. Also, während man in Europa so eine gewisse Wochenanzahl im Mutterleib verbracht haben muss, bevor man dann als Früchen gilt, also auch an die Maximalmedizin angeschlossen wird und so weiter, und es versucht wird, das Leben zu retten. Das ist in Japan irgendwie noch mal einen Monat weniger als in Deutschland bislang. Und da könnte man auch schon mal antizipieren, dass das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen geändert wird, weil es so einen demografischen Druck gibt. Das sieht man jetzt auch schon wieder. Also die Bundesagentur für Arbeit kriegt jetzt eine neue Spitze, und damit kriegt dieses Haus auch ein bisschen Fokus. Und damit auch Detlef Schäle, der ja in der Süddeutschen dieses Interview gab. Ja, uns fehlen ja 400.000 Leute im Jahr und so. Und wenn man das so ein bisschen planerisch aufzieht, je nachdem, ob die Politik dazu kommt, so langfristig zu denken, könnte man da an durchaus Paradigmenwechsel denken, die einfach kommen. Und das betrifft natürlich auch jetzt dieses neue Familienmodell, was die Anne Spiegel, also die neue Familienministerin, fährt, dass man nämlich sagt, ja, es gibt jetzt Verantwortungsgemeinschaften, auch wenn keine Liebe im Spiel ist. Hauptsache, es geht den Kindern gut. Also dass man so einen Fokus auf da, wo Nachwuchs gewünscht wird, sollte man es auf jeden Fall garantieren, selbst wenn es biologisch eigentlich ausgeschlossen ist, also männliche, homosexuelle Paare und so weiter. Dann kann man natürlich über adoptierte Kinder und so weiter sprechen. Die Frage ist halt, wie sehr drückt jetzt noch die CDU nach, also wie sehr hat man sich an so einem Status quo gewöhnt und hält dann auch Sachen für nicht diskutierbar oder dann eben doch? Und wie wird so ein politischer Prozess gestaltet? Da fehlen zum Beispiel auch noch so ein paar Orientierungstebatten im Bundestag, wo es da wirklich mal ins Eingemachte geht und nicht alle nur noch mal dasselbe sagen. In deren Sicht sind das schon krasse Diskussionen, die jetzt hier plötzlich aufgeworfen werden.
Und ich glaube, man sollte sich da auch nicht scheuen, zum Beispiel als Linke auch, sich gegen so etwas wie Leihmutterschaft zu stellen. Das heißt dann nicht unbedingt, dass man konservativ ist und eigentlich in die CDU gehört, sondern was ja hier stattfindet, ist, dass eine andere Frau ein Kind neun Monate lang austrägt, dann nachher kein Recht über dieses Kind hat, dieses Kind abgeben muss, auch die gewissen Risiken, die bei einer Schwangerschaft ja immer vorhanden sind, tragen muss und dafür Geld bekommt. Allerdings will man natürlich dann, und das sagen dann auch Leute, die einen Koalitionsvertrag mitgeschrieben haben, möchte man auf keinen Fall, dass es hier so in Richtung Designerbaby geht oder dass man in gewisser Weise Leihmutterschaft als Geschäft macht. Aber natürlich ist es ein Geschäft und deswegen finde ich es fast pervers, von einer altruistischen Leihmutterschaft zu sprechen. Hier hören wir mal da rein.
Befürworter sehen darin kein Hindernis. Schließlich könnten die Spenderinnen frei entscheiden, ob sie ihre Eizellen zur Verfügung stellen bzw. als Leihmutter bereitstehen. Im Koalitionsvertrag ist von einer altruistischen Leihmutterschaft die Rede.
So, Stüve widerspricht hier sehr schön.
Thalio Stüve vom genetischen Netzwerk indes glaubt nicht an ausschließlich Heereabsichten. Die meisten Spenderinnen lebten in prekären finanziellen Verhältnissen.
Es deutet eben eigentlich alles darauf hin, also die Erfahrungsberichte, die es gibt, die Studien, die es gibt, dass der Hauptgrund, sich dafür zu entscheiden, das Geld ist. Dementsprechend lohnt sich, denke ich, da die Frage zu stellen, wenn es diese Notsituation nicht gäbe, würden sich die Leute dann dafür entscheiden, ihren Körper zur Verfügung zu stellen und sich auch diesem Risiko auszusetzen. Deswegen würde ich sagen, da sind die Entscheidungen eben einfach nicht frei, weil die Bedingungen dafür gar nicht herstellbar sind.
Und wenn man dann versucht, das zu deckeln durch einen gewissen Preis, dann sieht das zum Beispiel so aus, wie in Griechenland.
Leihmütter in Griechenland dürfen mit maximal 10.000 Euro entschädigt werden.
Was macht man damit? Man hält die Preise niedrig, also jetzt mal ganz ökonomisch gesprochen. Man sagt einfach, gut, das wird sich natürlich für jemanden, der 2.000, 3.000 Euro im Monat regulär verdient, nicht lohnen, Leihmutterschaft zu machen. Aber Leute in prekären Verhältnissen, für die ist 10.000 Euro natürlich immens viel. Für die lohnt sich das dann. Durch diese Deckelung, die man da vornimmt, entkommerzialisiert man nicht das Geschäft, sondern man sorgt eigentlich für einen Niedriglohnsektor im Bereich Leihmutterschaft.
Also Christian Linden hat ja jetzt die Tage auch getwittert und hat sich dafür dann sehr feiern lassen, dass jetzt, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, beim Hartz IV irgendwie die Bedarfsgrenzen so ein bisschen reguliert werden. Also der Parathetische Wohlfahrtsverband will ja eigentlich so, dass die Hälfte aufgelegt wird. Ganz so wird es dann nicht. Aber 10.000 Euro ist auch viel Geld, wenn man an der unteren Einkommensgrenze in Deutschland liegt, weil da kann man durchaus mit einem Profit aus der Sache gehen, wenn man zehn Monate Schwangerschaft gegen zehn Monate normale Erwerbsarbeit, die man sonst leistet, austauscht. Also in deren Sicht ist dieser Anreiz immer noch geschaffen.
Und das manifestiert auch wieder wirkliche Ungleichheit zwischen den Geschlechtern, denn natürlich kann eine Leihmutter immer nur eine Frau sein. Und Leihmutterschaft würde dann bedeuten, gerade in prekären Verhältnissen, wir haben es da mit Frauen zu tun, die vielleicht selbst zwei, drei Kinder haben, kaum eine berufliche Perspektive bekommen, aufgrund von Gender Pay Gap, aufgrund von verschiedenen Dingen, Schwierigkeiten bei der Betreuung. Und diese Frau sagt sich dann, naja, aber 10.000 Euro, ich bin ja jetzt eh daheim und passe ja auf die Kinder auf, dann könnte ich ja nebenher noch schwanger sein, entbinde dann das Kind schnell, da sind dann halt die zwei Wochen, fall ich mal aus oder so. Aber eigentlich könnte ich das doch nebenher noch zu meinen Mutter- und Hausfrauen-Daten da sein machen. Und das wird dann als neues Geschäftsmodell für vor allem Leute sehr attraktiv, die sagen, naja, ich will eigentlich jetzt beruflich Karriere machen und hab zwar diesen Kinderwunsch, aber es ist ja doch auch belastend so unter Schwangerschaft und möchte das machen. Oder ich muss da auch sagen, dass ich da auch kein Verständnis habe für wie das hier Elton John oder so gemacht hat. Also ich oute mich ja richtig als Konservativ, Elton John mit seinem Lebenspartner, der ja auch auf Leihmutterschaft gesetzt hat. Und da bin ich ganz bei Deutsche und Gabaner, die auch mal gefragt wurden, ob das nicht für sie auch eine Möglichkeit gewesen wäre. Und dann sagten die, nee, nee, also man muss dann auch irgendwo die Grenzen kennen, was geht und was nicht. Also man kann nicht alles haben. Ich glaube, sich von diesem Konsumanspruch zu verabschieden, ist schon mal ein erster guter Schritt. Und dann war ich sehr entsetzt. Also hier, das ist übrigens jetzt für den Vorsitz, Tadeo Stüwe, schlage ich hiermit vor, und war dann sehr entsetzt, als ich einen Theologen hörte, einen evangelischen Theologen, der auch in diesem Bericht vorkommt, Professor Anselm, der eigentlich so Büchse-Argumente vorbringt.
Dass die Ampelkoalition der Reproduktionsmedizin offen gegenüber steht, entspreche der gesellschaftlichen Wirklichkeit, sagt Medizinetiker Rainer Anselm. Er lehrt als evangelischer Professor für systematische Theologie und Ethik an der Ludwig-Maximilians-Universität München.
Es sprach vieles für ein Verbot, mehr so aus kulturellen Gründen, dass wir eine Praxis der Nichtidentität von biologischer, genetischer und sozialer Mutter, dass wir das erst lernen mussten. Das sind so allmähliche Verschiebungen des Common Sense. Da würde ich sagen, sind wir jetzt so weit?
Ja, wir sind jetzt so weit, das mussten wir erst lernen. Das eine heißt ja nicht, nur weil man Familie jetzt anders auffasst, dass man zugleich eine Ausbeutung ermöglicht, nämlich durch Leihmutterschaft. Also das zusammenzutun und einfach sagen, ja, das ist jetzt unser modernes Verständnis von Familie, da würde ich sagen, nein. Also theoretisch würde ich sagen, ja, klar ist das Kind, das nicht das Eigenfleisch und Blut ist, genauso das Kind. Und kann genauso Familie sein und eine Familie kann auch sein, wir sind drei Frauen und zwei Kinder oder so. Denn wir haben es bei der Familie natürlich mit einem sozialen Konstrukt zu tun. Aber was ja gerade bei der Leihmutterschaft wieder so besonders durchkommt, ist ja eigentlich dieses Fleisch- und Blutdenken. Das ist ja das Interessante, dass hier Leute davon überzeugt sind, dass sie unbedingt ihre Gene auch noch irgendwo hinschleppen müssen. Und davon sollte man sich dann eher mal verabschieden. Und das wäre in der Moderne ankommen. Das wird hier alles auf sehr merkwürdige Weise vermischt. Und dann ärgert es mich wirklich, wenn da auch noch der Begriff Eigenverantwortung fällt.
Wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass wir Familienkonsolationen als Gesellschaft grundsätzlich akzeptieren, die auf Leihmutterschaft zurückgehen, dann glaube ich, müssen wir auch sagen, lasst uns das dann in unserer Eigenverantwortung regeln.
Wichtig sein, ein Kommerzialisierungsverbot.
Ja, aber dieses Kommerzialisierungsverbot, wie will man das einhegen? Da gibt es natürlich noch das Argument, ja, aber Paare, die das wollen, die gehen sowieso ins Ausland, lassen sich das machen. Ja gut, das ist immer irgendwie möglich, aber ich kann im Ausland auch viele andere Dinge machen. Aber ich kann nicht sagen, ja, ich gehe jetzt nach Amerika, um da zu schießen. Da kann ich viel besser mit Waffen rumrennen. Deswegen legalisieren wir das hier auch mal. Ich weiß, es ist ja ein sehr hinkender Vergleich, aber ich finde diese Bezugnahme aufs Ausland wirklich nicht sehr dienlich. Und was mich, ich bin ja noch Mitglied in der Kirche und bin ja evangelisch, was mich dann sehr schockiert hat, war das Ende dieses Berichts, da heißt es nämlich.
Der Theologieprofessor ist auch Vorsitzender der Kammer für öffentliche Verantwortung der Evangelischen Kirche in Deutschland. Sollte die Ampelkoalition in der Fortpflanzungsmedizin mehr zulassen, werde die evangelische Kirche nicht protestieren, sagt Rainer Anselm voraus.
Und sollte das so sein, das kann ich hier schon mal ankündigen, dann trete ich aus.
Also mal gucken, was passiert. Diese Diskussionen laufen immer sehr langsam und auch sehr orientiert am Ausland. Wie schon bei Corona ist es ja so, dass wir hier in Dänemark wieder den Vorreiter haben in Europa. Also in Dänemark liegt, glaube ich, weltweit auf Platz eins. Mehr als zehn Prozent der Kinder kommen dort über, wie es heißt, assistierte Reproduktionstechnologien auf die Welt. Allerdings ist es in Dänemark wahnsinnig schwer, eine Leihmutter zu finden. Das ist nämlich dort ausgeschlossen. Was es aber gibt, ist das…
Ich finde, dass da auch grundsätzlich diese modernen Methoden, wie Reproduktion ermöglicht werden kann, die schließlich, das will ich nur nochmal deutlich sagen, also ich bin nicht grundsätzlich dagegen und sage, also es soll nur alles im Ehebett vollzogen werden, und was darüber hinaus nicht klappt, ist verboten. Das möchte ich ja nicht sagen, aber ich finde, Leihmutterschaft ist doch ein erheblicher Unterschied.
Genau, und wenn wir das so demografisch, historisch einhegen, Dänemark gilt unter den Demografieforschern weltweit als das Musterland. Es sind 1, 8 Geburten pro Frau. Was bedeutet, es ist ein Schrumpfungsprozess, der quasi idealtypisch verläuft. Denn dort kann man alt werden, ohne arm werden zu müssen. Das ist in Deutschland ganz anders, denn hier liegen die Reproduktionswerte so bei 1, 2, 1, 3 Kindern pro Frau. Das ist aus dieser ökonomischen Sicht viel zu wenig. Also das bringt die Volkswirtschaftler einfach, macht ihnen wirklich Horror, weil sie einfach sehen, was da passiert. Deutschland hatte so einen Peak 2004 oder irgendwann von 1, 6 Kindern. Jetzt haben wir also dieses idealtypische Modell, wo man so richtig mit dem Willen auch weniger CO2 und so weiter zu produzieren, plus technologischem Wandel bei 1, 8 Kindern pro Frau eine Gesellschaft hat, bei der man wirklich sicher sagen kann, also diesen 2045 klimaneutral unglücklich. Dänemark gilt eh schon als das glückliche Land. Wir wissen auch, womit das zusammenhängt, dass man beispielsweise die Ausländer, die nach Dänemark kommen werden, schon in Afrika oder auf dem Balkan vorsortiert. Das sind sozialdemokratische Ideen in Dänemark.
Also die externalisieren ihre Probleme und dichten sich nach innen ab und sagen, ja wieso, uns geht es doch gut.
Genau. Und den Dänen Frauen werden Kinder nicht verwehrt. Sie können einfach zu so einer Samenbank gehen. Das wird dort nicht vom Staat organisiert. Das sind nicht ganz private Organisationen, aber da gibt es auch kein Profitgedanken. Also da geht man nicht hin und das kostet wahnsinnig viel, sondern man stellt so einen Antrag und dann wird er genehmigt und dann läuft das halt einfach. Während in Deutschland es ja immer noch so ist, dass man quasi im Internet so eine Kontaktanzeige macht. Hallo, wir sind ein lesbisches Paar, wir suchen einen Samenspender. Dann erklärt sich irgendwer bereit. Der muss dann gucken, wie er das in seinen Alltag integriert, weil er hat ja noch einen normalen Arbeitstag. Kommt also dann, was weiß ich, Mittwoch abends, weil es dann passt, von Hamburg nach Stuttgart gefahren, gibt dann da seinen Samen ab. Das läuft auch sehr häufig nicht über sexuellen Kontakt, sondern einfach er ist dann halt da, geht dann dort auf Toilette, holt sich einen runter, dann ist das Sperma da, dann gibt man das den beiden Frauen und die haben dann einfach einen schönen Abend und verteilen das dann so, dass da möglichst ein Kind draus ist. Also es ist so im Vergleich zu Dänemark, wie wir in Deutschland Tests machen. Das Kind wurde positiv mit angegangen getestet. Dann geh mal auf die Straße und kümmere dich selber. Ruf deinen Vater an und sag, du brauchst einen PCR-Test, so ungefähr. Du willst ein Kind, aber seit ein lesbisches Paar. Ja, geh mal auf die Straße und mach eine Anzeige mit der Netze. Das kann man alles mal ein bisschen organisieren und strukturieren. Man muss aber dann wieder sagen, dadurch, dass wir dann doch so einen großen Geschlechterunterschied haben zwischen Männern und Frauen, fällt es Frauen, wenn sie eine Paarbeziehung haben, sehr einfach an Kinder, eigene Kinder zu kommen, während sich homosexuelle Männer mehr Gedanken da machen müssen, so wie sich schon immer Männer in der Reproduktion, beispielsweise, wenn sie unehelich Kinder gezeugt haben. In Deutschland gilt ja, glaube ich, immer noch, dass automatisch der verheiratete Mann der Frau der juristische Vater ist. Selbst wenn alle wissen, dass der biologische Vater ein anderer ist. Das muss dann erst wieder alles aufgelöst und geklärt werden, sonst bleibt dieser Mann rechtlos. Und auch die Männer, die in Deutschland Samen spenden, auf diese freiwillige und auch sehr freie Art und Weise, wie ich es gerade beschrieben habe, die wissen auch nicht genau, woran sie sind. Und da höre ich aber bei Anne Spiegel raus, dass sie eben dadurch, das hat sie bei Lanz sehr schön beschrieben, Lanz fragt dann so, also zwei Frauen, ja, wollen ein Kind bekommen, ja. Und sie hört sich das einfach an, auch sehr zurückhaltenden Fragen. Wer weiß ja auch, wie sein Publikum so drauf ist. Aber sie sagt dann ganz offen, ja, das muss nicht Liebe sein. Die Verantwortung für ein Kind muss nicht mit Liebe begründet sein und so. Da sieht man schon, das geht alles in eine gute Richtung. Ich kann mir aber nicht vorstellen, dass es für dich jetzt Gründe gibt, die nächsten zehn Jahre aus der Kirche auszutreten, weil es zu irgendwelchen Entscheidungen unter zur Hilfenahme ethischer Beratung durch die Kirche kommt, dass wir plötzlich eine Leihmutterschaftsregelung haben, die selbst dänische Verhältnisse übertrifft. Denn die Dänen regeln das sehr freimüdig und Leihmutterschaften finden da so trotzdem nicht statt. Was allerdings wieder bedeutet, der Ausweg ist die Globalisierung. Also man geht dann in die Region. Die Dänen fahren sehr oft nach Amerika und holen sich da ihre Leihmütter. Denn das hat man ja auch bei Desperate-Hausgang schon vor zehn Jahren.
Ukraine ist sehr wichtig dafür. Die Ukraine ist sehr, sehr wichtig.
Oder da, genau. Und regelt das dann halt irgendwie.
Ich halte natürlich hier dich unter anderem auf dem Laufenden. Wenn es zum Kirchenaustritt kommen muss, dann werde ich das natürlich hier verkünden. Aber wir hoffen mal das Beste, dass die Neuen Zwanziger mit mir und der evangelischen Kirche noch zusammengehen. Mal schauen.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut. So, kommen wir trotzdem noch mal zu Corona. Denn ich möchte die drei Stunden 37, die ich natürlich auf eine Stunde im Walte zusammengeschnurzelt habe, dank Technologie, kann man sich alles schneller hören, nicht umsonst gehört habe. Denn es ist ja durchaus interessant, wie wir über Corona diskutieren. Nämlich immer noch nicht angemessen, insbesondere in Deutschland. Wir reflektieren es einfach nicht so richtig durch. Wir wollen auch dieses Studienwissen nicht so richtig anerkennen, wenn es nicht unserer Meinung entspricht. Was hat es damit eigentlich auf sich? Und ich finde das immer wieder beeindruckend, wie wir in Deutschland, nachdem wir dem Brexit, dem Trump, dem Duterte oder wie er heißt, alles Mögliche immer woanders, also die sind wirklich irre, die anderen, haben wir so eine komische Corona-Diskussion. Denn in Deutschland gilt, was auch in Amerika gilt, und was in The Daily am 26. also vor wenigen Tagen mal, wir gucken es uns in drei Clips an, was so richtig runtergebrochen wurde.
Und wie wir schon gesprochen haben, ist das nicht wissenschaftlich rational.
So, also Junge, es entscheidet sich gar nicht nach Alter so sehr, sondern egal ob jung oder alt, die Republikaner haben keine große Angst vor Corona-Infektionen, die Demokraten aber schon, auch die Jungen. Und das spiegelt schon mal nicht den wissenschaftlichen Stand wieder, denn auch wir in Deutschland haben die 100.000 tote Marke überschritten und davon sind 5% U60 und eben 95% über 60 gewesen. Bei der Frage, wie gefährdet sind wir also eigentlich wirklich, können wir unseren Pass gucken, gucken wir unser Geburtsjahr und dann können wir daraus ablesen. Allein aus dieser Zahl sind wir wirklich gefährdet von Corona, ja oder nein. Und Long-Covid ist nicht chronisch Covid. Also wir können auch bei Corona Long-Covid einfach mit einschließen. Corona infiziert zu sein kann bedeuten, ein Tag Schüttelfrost. Und manche schreiben dann, also die dritte Impfung war irgendwie härter als die Corona-Infektion. Manche sagen, nach drei Monaten hatte ich immer noch Puls 180, als ich vom Tisch aufgestanden bin. Ein Jahr später ist das aber in den meisten Fällen dann wirklich vergessen. Also wir haben es hier mit einer sehr irrationalen Betrachtung der Gefährlichkeit einer Corona-Infektion schon mal zu tun.
Lass mich da ganz kurz einhaken, denn das ist ja, wir müssen einmal ganz kurz über Twitter reden, wirklich verrückt, wie jetzt da, weil wir jetzt so hohe Infektionen haben, haben wir natürlich auch viele Fälle, die berichten, wie es dann genau ist. Und dann bin ich dann doch erstaunt über viele Medienleute, die ausführlich Bericht davon geben und aber immer nur eine Krippe haben. Also oder sagen wir Krippesymptome haben, dass sie sagen, auch nach dem vierten Tag bin ich noch total müde und habe gar keine Lust, mich anzuziehen. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das kennt man auch als Kind, hatte man mal eine Krippe oder vielleicht auch nochmal später und liegt dann einfach mal flach. Und dann ist man eigentlich auch noch zu erschöpft, um auch nur eine dumme Serie zu gucken. Man will eigentlich nur schlafen, mal einen Tee trinken, mal eine Suppe essen und dann ist wieder gut. Da würde ich auch sagen, da muss man nicht die gesamte Öffentlichkeit, wenn man da 40, 50, 60.000 Follower hat, mitbehelligen, wie es einem gerade geht. Wenn es wirklich was Ernsthaftes ist, dann kann man auch nochmal darauf hinweisen. Und kann auch nochmal sagen, unterschätz bitte das Risiko nicht. Oder manchmal ist die Statistik das eine, aber der individuelle Fall was anderes. Und natürlich ist das auch eine Sorge, die ich immer habe, weil ich denke, ja, die Statistik ist gut und schön. Aber es kann natürlich auch mich dann nochmal in spezieller Weise treffen. Es gibt in Homo Faba ja auch so einen Satz, wo es darum geht, wie die Statistik ist, dass man stirbt oder nicht. Aber dann heißt es ja, wenn es mein eigenes Kind betrifft, dann nutzt mich die Statistik nichts. Ich kann das auch alles so nachvollziehen, dass man da nicht sagt, naja, ist aber nur 0, 02 Prozent oder so. Aber dennoch finde ich es unglaublich, dass man die Öffentlichkeit in dieser Weise malträtiert mit seinen körperlichen Melesten, die man sich dann da eingefangen hat, dass ich es auch gar nicht mehr nachvollziehen kann und auch frage, wart ihr denn nie sonst auch mal irgendwie krank oder hattet ihr vielleicht auch mal einen Hexenschuss, wo man drei Tage nicht aufstehen konnte oder so. Das gehört doch auch alles zum Leben dazu. Und was ist eigentlich, wenn man in dieser Weise schon auf eine Krankheit überreagiert, wie ist es denn, wenn man wirklich mal ernsthaft krank ist? Und wir alle kennen in unserem Umfeld oder sind vielleicht auch selbst betroffen, Leute, die wirklich schlimme Krankheiten haben, über Jahre oder die acht Wochen, drei Monate im Krankenhaus verbringen. Und das ist doch auch in gewisser Weise ein bisschen vermessen, da, wenn man fünf Tage mal im Bett flach liegt, ein solches Drama aufzuführen, wenn man bedenkt, was Menschen für schlimme Krankheiten haben. Und damit in irgendeiner Weise versuchen zu leben.
Ja, also ich finde es hier in Frankfurt ganz speziell gerade wirklich erstaunlich. Wir hatten hier ja ein Jahr richtig Angst, also dieses typische Corona. Ja, ja, jeder hat so zwei, drei Kinder zu Hause. Man kennt sich über die Schulen, die Sportvereine, Kindergarten, Pipapo. Und jetzt, da die Inzidenz bei 2200 ist und bei unserer Klein in der Klasse neun Kinder gleichzeitig wegen Corona-Infektionen nicht da sind und so was. Also, wo wir einfach glauben, also unser Stadtteil hier, der hat so, keine Ahnung, 5000, 10.000 Inzidenz, hier sind wirklich 10.000, also 10 Prozent der Leute einfach gleichzeitig infiziert, ist doch eine ganz große Geruhsamkeit, weil einfach alle feststellen, hm, war gut. Man ist sich nicht so ganz sicher, ob es sich gelohnt hat, ein Jahr lang alles zuzumachen und ein weiteres Jahr so alles halb zuzumachen und die Kinder bis heute, bis 15 Uhr, selbst wenn sie draußen spielen, mit Maske rumzulernen zu lassen, um diese drei Schüttelfrosttage zu vermeiden. Also diese Gewichtung macht man doch jetzt. Und klar, das ist dann immer so anekdotisch, ja, ich rede hier nur von meinem Stadtteil und so weiter, aber hier ist niemand ernsthaft krank. Hier sind viele infiziert, aber hier ist niemand ernsthaft krank. Und man schreibt auch nicht mehr unter hier Pipapo. Also man gibt sich ja untereinander Bescheid, wurde gestern positiv getestet, weil wir haben vorgestern noch zusammen den Tag verbracht, dann kommen auch nicht mehr die großen Oh krass, ich bin so betrübt, ich hoffe euch geht's gut, kann ich euch was helfen oder so, sondern man sagt dann halt, ah ja, gut, okay, irgendwie, ja. Also man weiß gar nicht, was soll man jetzt sagen, danke, dass du mich informiert hast, weil das gehört ja irgendwie zur Bürgerpflicht dazu, dass wir uns jetzt alle informieren, aber es wäre jetzt auch albern irgendwie, da so, wie du es beschrieben hast, in Tränen auszubrechen und gleich allen Bescheid zu sagen, dass man wieder jemanden kennt, der Corona hat. Also Corona hat jetzt doch so eine ganz große Geruhsamkeit mitgebracht. Und wir hören mal diesen Clip hier zu Ende, denn es ist fast so, als wäre dieser anekdotische Alltag, der die Krankheit nun wirklich bei sich hat, die Seuche ist da sehr viel näher dran, als diese politische Diskussion darüber, wenn man mit Leuten spricht, wenn man Twitter liest und so weiter. Und dieses, was wir hier aus Amerika hören, gilt so auch in Deutschland. Ja, politische Beliefe, also politisch und Glaube, mal so grob übersetzt. Wenn wir feststellen, die alten Republikaner sind irgendwie bescheuert, die wählen Trump und haben keine Angst vor Corona, dann müssen wir zumindest bei diesem Corona-Aspekt einsehen, dass wir Jungen, nicht Republikaner, auch genauso weit von der Realität entfernt sind. Denn Corona ist für uns kein nennenswertes Problem und trotzdem drehen alle durch. Jetzt hat die New York Times hier eine eigene Erhebung gemacht und mal groß rumgefragt, weil sie eben über Literatur darauf gestoßen sind, dass das eine Fragestellung ist und haben, dass es jetzt ihr eigenes Ergebnis gewesen, alte Republikaner, sie haben noch weniger Sorgen und die jungen Demokraten sind überschwemmt von Sorge vor eigenen Corona-Infektionen.
Was ja zu ganz verrückten Dingen dann führt, also bei Twitter, dass es dann wirklich unsägliche Vergleiche gibt, dass dann noch zum Teil gesagt wird, ja, wenn man vom Ende der Pandemie spricht, dann schwinge da schon das Wort Endlösung mit und so Sachen, wo ich denke, jetzt ist aber auch wirklich mal gut, jetzt reißt euch mal zusammen und ja, es wäre toll, wenn sich einfach dieses Virus in Luft auflösen würde oder wenn es hieße, noch vier Monate warten, dann kann niemand mehr angesteckt werden, aber das wissen wir, das ist alles nicht so. Und jetzt müssen wir da einfach auch mal auf die Zahlen blicken, müssen auch mal unsere Nachbarländer schauen, wie damit Corona umgegangen wurde und wird. Und ich finde, diese Dramatisierung, die da stattfindet, ist dann etwas, was einen psychisch, glaube ich, mehr belastet, als dann das, was tatsächlich da eintritt. Und es ist so eine merkwürdige Verschiebung. Man findet das auch dann im eigenen Alltag wieder, wenn man bei Twitter ist und das alles mit nachvollzieht. Und dann unterhält man sich zum Beispiel mit den Eltern oder deren Freunden oder sonst was und erfährt dann, ja, wir waren ja gestern noch in der Kneipe, da war es aber dann auch relativ voll, wird dann gesagt. Und bei Twitter ist schon irgendwie der Weg zum Müll einmal die größte Gefahrensituation, der man sich nur einmal die Woche aussetzen möchte. Und das ist schon etwas, wo ich mich auch frage, wie will man denn von diesem Trip noch mal runterkommen? Denn fest steht auch, auch andere Krankheiten werden und so ein. Und ich frage mich auch, habt ihr denn sonst auch immer so besorgt, um eure Gesundheit gelebt? Also du bist ja nun jemand, du trinkst so gut wie keinen Alkohol, du machst viel für Herz-Kreislauf, du joggst und so weiter. Aber ich kann ja für mich sagen, ich ernähre mich nicht besonders gesund. Ich will nur nicht dick werden, damit die Anzüge weiterhin passen. Ich rauche meine drei Zigaretten am Tag und trinke auch gerne mal ein Wein oder ein Champagner und hab jetzt auch nie irgendwie die große Sorge gemacht, oh wei, wie wird das denn sein? Habe ich mit 50 ein Herzinfarkt oder so? Und dann kann ich ja nicht plötzlich jetzt fokussiert nur auf dieses eine Problem, Corona, so tun, als wäre mir nie etwas wichtiger gewesen als meine eigene Gesundheit. Dann müsste ich wirklich mein Leben ändern.
Genau, was ja auch jeder machen soll. Die Frage ist nur, ist das der richtige Antrieb?
Du empfiehlst es uns hier ja immer wieder, ja.
Ist das denn der richtige Antrieb? Die bei der New York Times fragen sich auch, also wenn wir jetzt durch unsere eigene Erhebung herausgefunden haben, die Einstellung zu Corona, insbesondere in Bezug auf das eigene Schicksal, ist vielmehr vom politischen Glaube beeinflusst, als von wissenschaftlichem Wissen. Haben wir durch Zufall jetzt einfach nur so, verzerrt unsere Studie irgendwas? Und sie stellen fest, dass unsere Studie bettet sich auch nur ein in diese große Studienlage.
Ich sage immer, Leute, verweigere nicht zu viel Geld in einen Poll. Aber es ist nicht nur unser Poll, das das findet.
Ja, also egal wer die Umfragen macht, Gallup, Gallup wie sie sagen, dann ist Pew Research Center, die New York Times selbst mit einer Fragestellung, die sie selbst kontrollieren, es ist immer wieder dasselbe. Und es ist verrückt, inwieweit der Booster diese Sachlage dann sogar nochmal dramatisiert.
Okay, so David, sag uns mal etwas über das zweite große, überraschende Erkrankung von den Amerikanern, das Thema Pandemie.
Was hat der Erkrankung gemacht?
verbreitet werden.
Ich denke, es ist wichtig, ein Sekunde zu fokussieren, wie klein der Risiko für die größten Erkrankungen ist, im Falle von Omicron. Also für mich war völlig klar, geboostert ist für mich persönlich die Pandemie vorbei. Ich trag da noch meine Maske und geh nicht zu irgendwelchen Konzerten, weil es keine Konzerte gibt und ich keine Lust auf Diskussionen hab zur Maske. Aber ich sehe es nicht mehr durch Überzeugung ein, sondern nur noch durch normative Kontrolle. Einfach sind halt die Regeln und ich halte mich an die Regeln. Und ja, es gibt natürlich das Argument man könnte ja infektiös sein und jemandem begegnen, der sich mit 80 Jahren hat noch nicht überzeugen lassen, sich impfen zu lassen, den schütze ich jetzt einfach mal. Ich frage mich dann, warum eigentlich der sich auch impfen lassen können. Also mein Verständnis schwindet da auch so langsam. Aber dass hier gesagt wird, Geboosterte nehmen dadurch, dass sie ja ihre Boosterung, ihren Aufwand, der ja gar nicht so groß ist, durch die Impfung nochmal, der soll kognitiv nochmal richtig gerechtfertigt werden, durch eine entsprechende Angst oder Infektion, das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Hier stelle ich vielleicht auch fest, dass ich einfach einen echten kognitiven Disconnect zu Twitter habe. Ich kann das einfach nicht nachvollziehen, was ich auf Twitter an Aufregungen die ganze Zeit lese. Und offenbar gibt es auch keine rationale Brücke, die ich bauen kann, sondern es sind einfach jetzt zwei Denkwelten, die aufeinandertreffen.
Du hast dich ja in deiner letzten Fernsehpodcast-Ausgabe bei den Fernsehmomenten schon gefragt, wieso wird das denn eigentlich nicht mal so kommuniziert, ein bisschen stärker, wie jetzt Covid als Omikron-Variante einzuschätzen ist. Du schlägst dir sogar vor, wir sollten jetzt nicht mehr Covid-19, sondern Covid-21 sagen, also das ist jetzt die neue Variante. Und die ist dann tatsächlich für geboosterte und vor allem dann auch noch jungen Leute sehr, sehr ungefährlich, sehr, sehr milde Verlauf. Und mild kann aber auch bedeuten, dass man mal drei Tage mit Fieber und Grippe im Bett liegt und trockene Husten hat und so weiter. Aber es ist kein Grund, sich noch weiter wegzusperren. Und da habe ich drüber nachgedacht, weil du präsentierst uns ja dann einige Ausschnitte und sagst dann ja, wieso wird denn dann nicht mehr auch in anderer Weise drüber berichtet? Und ich habe mich das in den letzten Wochen und Monaten immer mehr gefragt. Wir haben ja oft diskutiert, wie problematisch das ist, zum Beispiel bei Facebook mit der Timeline. Man gerät in die Bubble, in eine Blase hinein, vielleicht fällt man sogar in den Kaninchenbau und dann bekommt man nur noch die Bestätigung der eigenen Meinung angezeigt oder nur noch Dinge, die einen in irgendeiner Weise interessieren, affizieren und man setzt sich also dadurch Scheuklappen auf. Das Problem ist ja jetzt, wenn ich eine Nachrichtensendung wie die Tagesschau oder das heute schon mal mir ansehe, dann ist das zwar auch eine Timeline, aber die richtet sich an alle, an jeden, der den Fernseher anmacht und sich die Sendung ansieht. Und ich habe mich gefragt, für wen sind manche Nachrichten eigentlich produziert? Also beim Wetter ist es ja so, das ist für alle da. Wenn es heißt, heute wird es im Westen regnen, dann gilt das für dich, für mich, ob ich 90 bin oder eine Frau oder sonst was, ganz egal. Es wird regnen, wenn ich rausgehe, also Schirm mitnehmen. Aber die Nachrichten zum Virus sind ja etwas anders geartet. Wenn ich jetzt jung und geboostert bin, dann könnte für mich eine Omikron-Nachricht lauten, Experten von Kekulé bis Trosten sind sich einig für junge Menschen, die geboostert sind, werden allenfalls leichte Verläufe sein. Sinnvoll ist es noch, die Maske zu tragen, aber wir gehen in eine endemische Phase in den nächsten Wochen, Monaten. Aber diese Nachrichten sind ja auch für Leute zum Beispiel gemacht, die sich den Booster noch nicht abgeholt haben oder noch ungeimpft sind völlig. Und für die habe ich den Eindruck, wird primär inzwischen Journalismus gemacht, dass man sagt, sobald wir irgendwas mit Entwarnung bringen, wir haben es ja bei Trosten mehrmals gesehen, es werden ja immer nur die Sachen aus den 90 Minuten Gespräche rausgesucht, die noch mal waren, Trosten befürchtet das und so weiter. Aber wenn er sagt, für Kinder ist es auch dann nicht so wichtig, ob sie geimpft sind oder nicht zunächst einmal, weil wir sehen müssen, die ungeimpften Älteren sind unser Hauptproblem. Es wird immer das rausgezogen, was als Gefahr da ist, nicht das, wo er sagt, naja, ihr könnt auch ein bisschen entspannt sein, wenn die Kinder noch nicht die dritte Impfung haben, dann wird es wahrscheinlich für die auch nicht so schlimm sein. Das wird nicht signalisiert. Insofern, im Prinzip bräuchten wir eine Timeline auch für die Tagesschau. Und die Timeline für dich und mich sähe dann anders aus, wie für den ungeimpften 70-Jährigen, der sonst vielleicht auf die Idee kommen könnte, ah ja, mit Omikron ist ja alles halb so wild richtig, ich brauch mich ja gar nicht impfen lassen.
Also die Tagesthemen, und das hat ja Klaus Kleber bei seiner Tübinger Andrittsvorlesung als Honorarprofessor wie auch immer vor fünf Jahren, also ich konnte ja in Redaktionsschluss schon darüber schreiben, hat er ja festgestellt, an dem Tag Charlie Hebdo, einem großen Nachrichtentag, waren fünf Prozent der Zuschauer der AD, ZDF und RTL-Nachrichten U40. Und dann sagt er nochmal, U40, das sind nicht die Jugendlichen, sondern das sind Menschen, die mitten im Leben stehen. Und wir wissen, für wen heute schon die Tagesthemen produzieren und in deren Sicht, ja sie gaukeln uns immer noch vor und behaupten, sie machen Nachrichten für alle, aber sie machen Nachrichten für das Publikum, dass sie tatsächlich haben. Und das fällt nun mal in die Corona-Risikogruppe. Entsprechend alarmiert ist Marietta Slomka auch im Gespräch mit jedem und holt sich dann nochmal die Dramatik ab, die aber nicht für jeden gegeben ist. Es ist eben doch anders. Und damit fällt auch ein ganz großes Problem unter den Tisch, sowohl in den Tagesthemen, eben heute schon als auch im Bundestag. Und wir können aber alle mal ganz dankbar sein, dass Gregor Gysi es angesprochen hat. Denn was machen wir jetzt mit der Erkenntnis, die ja auch aus dieser Cosmo-Studie aus Erfurt kommt und so weiter, dass diejenigen, die sich nicht impfen lassen, und wie New York Times eben auch beschrieben hat, dass diejenigen, die sich bis heute nicht impfen lassen, das gar nicht so sehr aus medizinischen Gründen machen, sondern als politisches Statement verstehen, dass sie jetzt mal aktiv machen können. Denn nichts tun, also diese Untätigkeit, ist ja jetzt die große schlimme Tat, sich nicht impfen zu lassen. Das ist ja auch verrückt, dass man durch die Vermeidung einer Aktion den anderen sozusagen Aktionen vorgaukelt, ein Handeln vorgaukelt. Bisher konnten wir die immer ignorieren. Die nehmen nicht an der Gesellschaft teil, die reisen nicht in die Welt, die machen nicht, die sitzen einfach da in der Sächsischen Schweiz und machen Kampfspiele. Ja gut, wen interessiert, dass sie nicht geimpft sind, interessiert aber plötzlich alle, weil wir uns alle irgendwie davon betroffen fühlen. Obwohl der Booster und so weiter ja eigentlich auch ganz toll gegen Omikron hilft. Gregor Gysi hat das mal aufgeschlüsselt, hier im kurzen, in einer Minute im Bundestag, wo eigentlich die Fragestellung ist, die man auch mal diskutieren könnte, auch ganz explizit beim Thema Impfpflicht.
Statt einer Impfpflicht benötigen wir deutlich mehr Vertrauen. Sonst wird die Demokratie immer mehr Schaden nehmen. 23, 4 Prozent Nichtwählende, 10, 3 Prozent AfD-Wählende, 8, 7 Prozent wählten bewusst Parteien, die nicht in den Bundestag einziehen, weil sie alle, alle diese Gruppen mit der etablierten Politik fertig sind. Und zwar von der CSU bis einschließlich der Linken. Darüber müssen wir uns sehr viel mehr Gedanken machen. 37, 5 Prozent der Bevölkerung vertraut der etablierten Politik nicht mehr. Und 5 bis 10 Prozent werden vielleicht normal, aber 37, 5 Prozent sind viel zu viele. Und wir müssen uns wesentlich mehr Gedanken machen, wie man Vertrauen herstellen kann, durch eine allgemeinverständliche Sprache, durch die Angabe der wahren Beweggründe für Entscheidungen, durch die Überwindung des gesamten Lobbyismus und vor allem durch deutlich mehr Ehrlichkeit.
Mehr Ehrlichkeit, Überwindung des Lobbyismus. All das kann die Impfquote steigern in Deutschland. Es ist wirklich verrückt und genau richtig. Und es gibt dazu viel Forschung. Ich bin ja neuerdings Fan des Oxytocins, das wir viel zu wenig beobachten. Diese Forschung, diese klinische Forschung zu diesem Hormon oder auch Neurotransmitter, das ist ja nicht nur ein Hormon, wird vor allem in der ökonomischen Verhaltensökonomie gemacht, von Ernst Fehr und so weiter. Das ist der Typ, der mit 500 Wissenschaftspunkten immer Ranking Platz 1 im FAZ-Ökonomen-Ranking einnimmt. Erst danach kommen die ganzen Bekannte aus Funk und Fernsehen, Institutsleiter und so weiter, weil sich da einfach jemand akademisch wirklich bemüht hat, um zu verstehen, warum Menschen einander vertrauen, wenn es um alles geht, nämlich um ihr Geld. Dann bläst man ihnen so ein bisschen Oxytocin in die Nase und zack, sind sie nicht einfach nur auf Droge, sondern sind sich wirklich mehr zugewandt, achten mehr aufeinander.
Man kann es ja in den osteuropäischen Ländern, die zum Teil eine Impfquote von 30 Prozent haben, sehen, dass da natürlich das Vertrauen in die Regierung noch viel schlechter ist als hier. Und dann, wenn die Regierenden sagen, lasst euch impfen, dann sagen die, ich bin ja nicht bescheuert, ihr habt mich ja schon immer belogen.
Ja, gerade in den osteuropäischen Ländern, also Bulgarien, schrumpft gerade auf, sagen, es ist unglaublich, dass ein Land überhaupt so schnell schrumpfen kann und damit auch so schnell alt wird. Diese osteuropäischen Länder, die so viele junge Leute verloren haben nach Westdeutschland, nach England, nach Frankreich, die sind natürlich jetzt auch in diesen demografischen Echo-Kammern. Das sind einfach sehr viele alte Republikaner, die sich da gerade gegenseitig in ihren Timelines davon überzeugen, dass Corona für sie gar kein Problem ist. Und der Staat, der soll sich mal ganz hinten anstellen, wenn er irgendwas hat, in deren Sicht hören wir hier eine Stimme, die Gott sei Dank mal zu Wort kam, in den Tagesthemen. Katrin Schmelz, einer dieser Verhaltensökonominnen der Uni Konstanz.
Die Entscheidung gegen das Impfen ist für viele ein politisches Statement und keine Gesundheitsentscheidung mehr. Und es sollte mehr in den Gesundheitsbereich wieder rücken. Denn ein Großteil der Ungeimpften hat fehlendes und angeschlagenes Vertrauen in die Regierung. Und dann fragt man sich gut, wenn die Regierung aufklärt, glaubt man das eigentlich?
Und das kann man alles ignorieren, wenn man neu im Bundestag ist, zum Beispiel Jessica Rosenthal, die neue Juso-Vorsitzende, die sich im Bundestag wie folgt äußert.
Wir müssen uns eingestehen. Und davon bin ich überzeugt, dass es nicht nur auf freiwilliger Ebene machbar sein wird, eine endemische Situation zu erreichen. Im Sinne der Mehrheit der Gesellschaft, im Sinne des Schutzes des Gesundheitswesens und im Sinne möglichst vieler Freiheiten, übrigens gerade auch für junge Menschen, brauchen wir daher eine allgemeine Impfpflicht ab 18 Jahren.
Sie fordert jetzt die Impfpflicht ab 18 Jahren. Freiwilligkeit schließt sie komplett aus. Das muss normativ, und normativ heißt hier durchzwangen, also gegen eine kognitive Überzeugung muss es normativ, mit Hilfe des Rechts usw. durchgesetzt werden. Da fragt man sich natürlich, kann man weiter weg sein vom gegenwärtigen Stand der Wissenschaft zum Thema, Verhalten, politische Einstellung, Überzeugung, Anerkennung wissenschaftlichen Wissens zum Thema?
Da würde man ja schon fast den Ethikrat wieder in Schutz nehmen, weil die ja erst mal sagten, na gut, der einen Schritt müsste vielleicht dann doch ein Vorschritt sein, zu sagen, die über 60-Jährigen, die bekommen eine Impfpflicht, aber warum jetzt bei über 18-Jährigen? Und ich finde das aber ganz symptomatisch, wie nach wie vor da extrem Panik geschürt wird, auch von irgendwelchen Comedians und sonst was, die ja die ganze Zeit nur auf diesem Trip sind. Wir haben es ja schon vor vielen, vielen Monaten festgestellt, die Leute hören den Drosten-Podcast nicht und inzwischen ignorieren sie wohl alles. Und Drosten hat es ja auch bei der BPK und so nochmal ganz deutlich gesagt, dass wir jetzt auch nicht alle drei, vier Monate uns impfen lassen werden können und glauben, dass wir damit immer uns von dem Virus befreien, sondern anders ist eine endemische Phase auch gar nicht einleitbar. Und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, was da in den Köpfen vorschreibt. Ich glaube, es ist, und das ist ja doch so von links, also das kann man ja doch ganz klar mal hier festhalten, es kommt von links, links, liberal. Also ich und man hat sich ja an so ein Narrativ oder ein Erklärungsmodell gewöhnt, von dem man jetzt auch nicht mehr abrücken will, das aber noch so ziemlich 2020 ist. Und da würde ich sagen, da muss man noch mal revisionsoffen sein, um diesen Schock nochmal zu bringen. Nämlich man sagte, ja, wir müssen alle in den Lockdown, das ist ganz wichtig, denn wir wollen ja nicht für die Wirtschaft sterben. Das ist ja etwas, wo man immer noch glaubte, wir machen auch so ein bisschen Antikapitalismus jetzt hier gerade, wenn wir im Lockdown sind. Dazu ist aber zu sagen, die Wirtschaft, das sind auch wir alle, die Industrieproduktion ging fast ohne Probleme weiter. Das Einzige, was die Industrieproduktion in Deutschland behindert hat, sind Lieferketten, die kaputtgegangen sind oder irgendwelche Chips, die nicht rechtzeitig produziert wurden. Das war ein Problem, sonst wurde produziert, wir wissen, den DAX-Konzernen ging es gut, es wurden tolle Dividenden ausgeschüttet. Das No-Covid-Lager hat nie die Produktion im Blick gehabt. Diese Zero-Covid-No-Covid-Leute sind meist Leute, die jetzt sich aufregen, dass sie nicht genügend PCR-Tests haben und andere Tests haben. Da kann man ja erst mal feststellen, die fallen ja nicht vom Himmel. Die müssen ja auch in irgendeiner Weise produziert werden. Du sagst es ja immer gern, Wolfgang, du bist ja Marxist. Als Marxist kann ich dann mal ein Geheimnis verraten, auch im Sozialismus muss etwas produziert werden. Da müssen auch die Leute arbeiten gehen. Und man kann nicht so tun, als würden jetzt alle immer nur für die Wirtschaft verheizt werden, jetzt gerade während der Omikronwelle, sondern man mag es selbst ausbeutung, man darf es Verblendung nennen, wie auch immer, vielleicht ist es aber auch einfach die Lust am Beruf, dass Leute gerne ihr Restaurant oder ihr Kino öffnen möchten, dass Menschen gerne auch ihre Arbeit nachgehen. Und es sind nicht alle Leute nur in der Einstellung, dass sie jetzt gerade hier für die Wirtschaft sterben. Das ist nicht die Wirklichkeit. Und wenn eine Volkswirtschaft zusammenbrechen würde, dann ginge uns es allen sehr schlecht. Und dann hätten wir nicht nur Corona als Problem, sondern hätten wir auch ganz andere Versorgungsprobleme. Und immer nur so zu tun, als würden wir jetzt gerade von der Ampel-Koalition an die Wirtschaft verfeuert werden. Das ist einfach nicht wahr. Und es gibt, wie gesagt, diese gute Schutzmöglichkeit, Impfung. Einfach, zweifach und dann sogar dreifach. Und dann ist das auch etwas, was zum Teil zum Leben dazugehört.
Also wir können dieses Phänomen, das du gerade beschrieben hast, die Sarrazin-Falle nennen. Benannt nach Thilo Sarrazin, dem ehemaligen Berliner Finanzsenator, der in dieser Rolle den Leuten das Hartz-IV-Essen auf 1, 30 Euro pro Tag gekürzt hat. Und danach Deutschland schafft sich ab, geschrieben hat, dieses Buch. Denn Thilo Sarrazin war ja auch immer ganz wichtig, dass der Unternehmer und der Markt gut funktioniert und die ganzen Ausländer, das kann ja alles gar nicht sein. Und dann hat Kaube mal in so einem kleinen Text darauf hingewiesen, Jürgen Kaube. Ja, Thilo Sarrazin will immer über den Unternehmer und den Markt reden, aber wenn dann jemand kommt und sagt, na dann reden wir mal über den türkischen Obsthändler an der Ecke, dann ist das plötzlich nicht die Wirtschaft, die man meint. Aber es ist eben die Wirtschaft, von der wir abhängen und in der wir leben und die wir auch brauchen. Und diese Verwechslung findet da immer wieder statt, dass man da einfach so eine große Ausgrenzung macht. Wir hören aber nochmal ihr ersten Punkt, denn was, wie sie es wortwörtlich sagt, finde ich einfach, das ist der ganzen Sachlage der Dramatik und auch des Politikerseins, finde ich, nicht angemessen.
Wir müssen uns eingestehen und davon bin ich überzeugt, dass es nicht nur auf freiwilliger Ebene machbar sein wird, eine endemische Situation zu erreichen.
Die endemische Situation heißt Immunität in der Gesellschaft. U50er sterben nicht an Corona, sondern die können auch mit der Krankheit immunisiert werden. Denn anders als, und das muss man echt sagen, Karl Lauterbach bei Marit das Lomka einfach gelogen hat, indem er meinte, wer sich natürlich infiziert, gewinnt damit keine Immunisierung, sondern hat mit Zitat Zitronen gehandelt, was auch immer das bedeuten soll. Das ist völlig banal, so was zu sagen. Wir wissen aus diesen Studien erstens ja, die Impfung bereitet dich auf die Infektion vor. Aber erst die Infektion bringt dir wirklich breite Antwort. Und das haben wir ja bei Drosten letztes Dezember gehört. Wie Drosten schon damals über Delta sagte, also nach zwei Impfungen ist Schluss. Die dritte Impfung ist für Afrika. Ich erwarte jetzt meine erste, zweite und dritte Infektion. Und ja, durch Omikron hat sich die Lage verändert. Dann sind es nämlich drei Impfungen und ein etwas weniger gefährliches Virus. Aber trotzdem wartet man dann auf seine natürliche Infektion. Und wir haben jetzt dieses Schlagwort der Superimmunität aus diesen amerikanischen Studien. Infektion plus Impfung. Und zwar egal in welcher Reihenfolge. Das kann doch erst die Infektion sein und dann hinterher nochmal geimpft. Weil die Impfung bedeutet ja, dann kriegt man wirklich mal die richtige Last. Die Infektion kann ja auch so im Vorbeilaufen gewesen sein, dass das Virus schon anfängt zu replizieren, als es noch eigentlich noch gar nicht da ist. Statt dieser tiefe Art im Zug bei einer Karnevalssitzung, die die Leute dann K.o. geschlagen hat. Also in der Ansicht geht es hier drunter und drüber. Und nur weil es auch ein bisschen lustig war, Lauterbach saß, wie der Kanzler auch, die ganze Zeit in dieser Debatte drin. Drei, eineinhalb und noch ein paar mehr Minuten, Stunden. Das ist unglaublich lang. Er twitterte sogar zwischendurch, die CDU missbraucht die Debatte schon wieder wie Parteienpolitik und tritt dann als vorletzter Redner, glaube ich, nach über dreieinhalb Stunden, wie folgt, ans Rednerpult.
Frau Präsidentin, meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren, meine liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, ich möchte mich zunächst einmal für die hervorragende Debatte bedanken, von der ich sehr profitiert habe, viel mitgenommen habe.
Ich dachte, ich falle immer weit.
Als hätte er da etwas Neues gehört. Das kann doch gar nicht wahr sein. Aber es ist irgendwie schön, es wird so ein bisschen Demokratie gespielt. Das wäre so eine Szene, die hätte Wellback nicht besser beschreiben können. Der Protagonist sitzt zu Hause mit zwei Flaschen Rotwein vor dem Fernseher und schaut sich diese Debatte an und beschreibt dann, wie er schon eigentlich alles mitsprechen kann, was gesagt wird. Und dann zum Schluss kommt auch noch der Gesundheitsminister und tut noch mal so, als hätte er was Neues gelernt. Es gibt so eine ähnliche Stelle in Serotonin, da ist der Protagonist, der ja hochdepressiv ist, irgendwann nur noch vor dem Fernseher und guckt sich diese Debatten an, wo sich einer mit dem anderen abwechseln und man aber alles schon antizipieren kann, was gesagt wird. Es ist sehr schön, ja.
Also man kann das, also für alle, die sich fragen, was ist noch meine cognitive Dissonanz, habe ich doch im Studium gelernt, das hier von Lauterbach. Kau Lauterbach weiß, er und seine Koalition haben die FDP nicht im Boot, denn die hat legitime Argumente, zum Beispiel, dass Omikron ja gar nicht so schwer ist und eine allgemeine Impfpflicht ab 18 damit eigentlich nicht zu rechtfertigen ist, hat ja auch Buschmann jetzt als Justizminister noch mal bei Anne Will gesagt. Die unter 50-Jährigen belasten das Krankheitssystem nicht, weil sie einfach nicht auf die Inzidivstation eingeliefert werden. Wir können also hier mit einer Impfung keine Überlastung vorbeugen, nicht mal über das Überbande-Argument, dass die ja dann die Alten infizieren, die dann auf der Inzidivstation landen, weil auch für die gilt ja das Impfargument. Sie können sich ja impfen lassen. Also die Große Koalition, ist es eine Große Koalition, also die neue Ampel hat die FDP nicht gebot, kann deswegen keinen eigenen Antrag stellen, weil sie dafür keine Mehrheit hätte, was ziemlich peinlich wäre, wenn man gleich das als erstes Thema in der Koalition hat. Also musste die Ampel, und das war dann der Auftrag von Karl-Lotterbach, sagen, wir nehmen hier Gruppenanträge entgegen, es ist demokratische Leadership, das war das Zitat von Olaf Scholz, dass es nicht der Kanzler macht, sondern das Parlament. Also musste, egal was inhaltlich stattfand, musste diese Debatte eine Sternstunden-Debatte für Karl-Lotterbach sein, ansonsten ginge das ja gar nicht. Das Argument aufrechtzuerhalten, dass das eine genuine Aufgabe des Parlaments ist und nicht der Regierung, weil wenn man dem Parlament so eine tolle Aufgabe gibt und dann kommt aber nur dreieinhalb Stunden Müll in der Debatte geliefert oder Unsinn, wie Robin Alexander sagt, dann wäre das ja blöd. Also in der Ansicht war das natürlich eine ganz tolle Debatte aus Sicht Karl Lauterbaß. Und ich finde, er hat so ein bisschen rhetorischen Humor gezeigt, indem er nochmal wie folgt, hört euch das genau an, wie er das macht, wenn er wie folgt argumentiert.
Die Omikron-Variante befällt auch Geimpfte und verläuft leichter. Vielleicht ist das die Alternative zur Impfung. Vielleicht brauchen wir die Impfpflicht gar nicht mehr. Vielleicht ist die Omikron-Variante der Weg aus der Pandemie heraus in die Endemie, ohne dass wir die Impfpflicht nötig hätten. Das ist leider nicht so. Zum einen ist es jetzt bereits so, dass die Modelle des Robert-Koch-Instituts zeigen, dass diejenigen, die nicht geimpft sind, von der Omikron-Variante bedroht sind und wir wahrscheinlich mit Belegungen der Intensivstationen von bis zu 5.000 Menschen rechnen müssen.
So, wir haben bis heute und Omikron, davon haben wir als erstes am 9. November gehört über die Medien und schon eine Woche später war das hier in Frankfurt. Nachgewiesener erster Omikron-Fall in Deutschland. Wir haben bis heute keinen Omikron-Fall auf der Intensivstation und die Intensivstation in Frankfurt ist ziemlich groß. Das Einzugsgebiet ist riesig.
Keinen Omikron-Fall?
Keinen Omikron-Fall.
Das sind also alles noch Delta-Leute?
Das sind alles noch die alten Delta-Felder. Da liegen recht viele Junge, die seit Wochen sich da nicht erholen. Es ist ganz dramatisch, weil jeder einzelne Infektionsfall absolut unterschiedlich verläuft. Die Ärzte wissen nicht, wenn es heißt, braucht jetzt mehr Sauerstoff, als wir so geben können. Sie wissen nicht, was dann kommt. Es gibt noch keine Standardtherapie. Man hat nur dieses riesige Arsenal in irgendwelchen Medizin. Und da muss man auch sagen, da ist immer eine Medizin gegen die Krankheit und dann sind fünf andere Medizin um die eine Medizin gegen die Krankheit im Körper nicht ganz so einen schweren Schaden anrichten zu lassen. Also das total verketterte Infusionieren von irgendwelchen Mitteln, bei denen man immer genau auf die Geräte schauen muss, um zu gucken, wie die miteinander zusammenspielt. Also es ist eine ganz komplizierte Lage, ganz schrecklich auch für die Ärzte, weil die einfach nicht wissen, wie sie auch diesen Fall dann wieder absolvieren müssen. Aber es sind keine Omikronfälle dabei. Und Lauterbach kündigt uns jetzt hier im Bundestag 5.000 Intensivmedizinische Omikroninfektionen an. Und das gucken wir mal in einem halben Jahr, weil das ist einfach unwahrscheinlich. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Deutschland ist ein altes Land. Die Alten haben auch mit Omikron Probleme, aber 5.000, das ist viel. Mal gucken, er hat sich jetzt hier auf 5.000 festgelegt. Und diesen kleinen Wortwitz, die Argumente der Gegenseite aufzugreifen und sagen, das ist leider nicht so, doch das wird so sein. Omikron wird diese Tür sein. Naja, ich habe diese Debatte eigentlich nur geguckt, um auf ein Argument zu warten, nämlich was ist denn die Folge einer Impfpflicht? Die Impfung, das haben wir ja schon ausführlich besprochen, ist eine medizinische Intervention. Und wir haben jetzt viele nicht pharmazeutische Interventionen, also Lockdown, Schulschließung und der ganze Kram. Wenn man jetzt die pharmazeutische, die medizinische Intervention zur Pflicht macht, müsste die doch eigentlich alle anderen Maßnahmen aufheben. Das ist jedenfalls die Logik, die ich erwarte. Und ich habe dreieinhalb Stunden darauf gewartet, dass irgendwer im Bundestag sagt, wir müssen aus allen Corona-Maßnahmen raus, das geht nur mit Impfung. Und wenn die Impfung nicht angenommen wird, müssen wir sie verpflichtend machen, denn nur so können wir alle Maßnahmen beenden.
Was ja nur aufgreifen würde, was Trosten und auch Wieler und andere sagen, die Ungeimpften sind das Problem. Und daraus ist ja zu Schlussfolgern, die Geimpften sind also nicht das Problem, wären alle geimpft, verpflichtet worden, sich impfen zu lassen, hätten wir kein Problem mehr.
Ganz genau. Das hat aber niemand in diesen dreieinhalb Stunden gesagt. Und der, der es gesagt hat, ist Boris Palmer und zwar bei Markus Lanz. Und wie er es gesagt hat, fand ich dann auch sehr deutlich, denn wir wissen, er ist der Mann des deutlichen Wortes. Dann kann man sich es ja auch mal anhören.
Boris Palmer ist da noch radikaler und sagt, wir sollten einfach alle Regeln abschaffen, alle Maßnahmen aufheben.
Es gibt nur eine einzige Maßnahme, die heißt Impfpflicht.
Was heißt das?
Ja, ich will das noch mal begründen. Wir haben ja jetzt nicht nur den Rationierungsbeschluss für die PCR-Tests, sondern wir haben auch die völlige Überlastung Gesundheitsunterfaktisch wird die Kontaktverfolgung nicht mehr wirklich durchgeführt. Waren früher zentrale Elemente der Pandemie-Kontrolle. Heute hat der Verwaltungsgerichtshof in Baden-Württemberg die 2G-Regel für den Einzelhandel verworfen. Die ist jetzt weg, gilt seit heute nicht mehr. Bayern? Haben andere Verwaltungsgerichtshöfe auch gemacht. Nach meiner Wahrnehmung sind es Anzeichen für das Ende der bisherigen Pandemie-Strategie. Die funktioniert so nicht mehr, mit diesen immensen Fallzahlen sowieso nicht. Wir brauchen jetzt eine andere Lösung. Und ich bin der Meinung, dass wir die haben. Die Impfpflicht, Herr Streeck kann das besser erklären als ich, aber die Impfpflicht würde ja eine Grundimmunisierung der Bevölkerung sicherstellen. Alle sind zumindest mal zweimal geimpft. Und dann sind nach allem, was wir jetzt sehen, die Krankenhäuser sicher. Dann gibt es keine Überlastung mehr der kritischen Infrastruktur. Und dann gibt es auch keinen Grund mehr für diese ganzen Grundrechtseingriffe. Und deswegen finde ich es absolut logisch und schlüssig zu sagen, wir tauschen alle alten Regeln ein, vergessen die, sind eh viel zu kompliziert und unverständlich und ineffektiv und werden von Gerichten verworfen und ersetzen sie durch eine einzige neue Regel, alle müssen geimpft sein.
In diesem, aber nur in diesem Punkt, ich lege darauf Wert, stimme ich Boris Palmer zu?
Ja, mir fehlt dieses Argument in der breiten Diskussion, denn das, sagen wir mal so.
Irgendwie aber auch traurig, dass dann Boris Palmer so ein Argument machen muss, dass dann nicht noch sich jemand anders, der jetzt vielleicht, sagen wir so ein bisschen mehr, in der Mitte sich aufhält oder so, wie auch immer ich es formulieren soll, dass das nicht auch mal auf so einen ganz geistreichen Punkt kommt.
Also für mich ist es zwingend, es so zu diskutieren, denn wir wissen, die Impfung bringt nur einen individuellen Schutz. Denen zu verpflichten, also wenn es dieses soziale Argument nicht gibt, wie vorher, dass man um die Alten zu schützen, gehen die Jungen jetzt, machen Schulschließungen und so weiter. So wurde das ja kommuniziert. Ich verstehe nicht, warum dieser Bogenschlag nicht gemacht wird, denn ich würde zum Beispiel keine Impfpflicht, die einfach mit so einem Rosenthal-Argument daherkommt. Das ist der einzige Weg zur Endemie. Wir müssen Infektionen verhindern. Es muss die Impfung sein. Da würde ich sagen, nö, lass das doch. Wenn jemand meint, er ist lieber zwei Wochen krank statt drei Tagen, lass ihn doch. Er hat sich auch jetzt ausführlich informiert, auch wenn wir denken falsch und so. Für mich kann eine Impfpflicht nur über Bande gespielt werden, damit ich das akzeptiere. Und dann muss es diese Bande sein. Alle anderen Maßnahmen müssen aufgehoben werden. Die Impfpflicht muss das Ende der Pandemie sein. Der politisch verfügten Pandemie. Ansonsten ist die Impfpflicht auch nicht sehr viel mehr wert. Wenn es dann einfach nur heißt, wir haben durch die Impfpflicht ein bisschen weniger Corona.
Ich muss sogar mal ein paar Leute auf Twitter erzählen. Die sind alle geboostert. Da haben wir genau das, was jetzt da in den amerikanischen Podcasts schon aufbereitet wurde. Die sind alle geboostert, aber wollen nach wie vor nicht in irgendeiner Weise am normalen Leben teilnehmen. Ich bekomme es ja auch mit, wenn man auch schon mal eine Anfrage oder so bekommt, was dann da alles gemacht werden soll, wo ich da sage, nee, mache ich nicht. Also was wollt ihr jetzt noch alles von mir? Also das ist dann irgendwie Quatsch. Und ich frage, ist da überhaupt dann noch jemand ungeimpft? Nee, nee, wir sind alle geboostert. Vielleicht lebt man auch mal danach. Und dann erfährt man natürlich dann so privat, dass dann doch mitunter viel mehr geht als so die Twitter-Persona, bekannt gibt. Also das ist auch ganz interessant, wie da so gelebt wird. Also man könnte da ein bisschen Doppelmoral sprechen. Nee, nee, also Boris Johnson ist, glaube ich, ein sehr klassischer Fall, weshalb er auch nicht stürzen wird. Denn die Leute identifizieren sich ja nicht mit dem immer korrekten, sondern eigentlich ist das ja was unglaublich Entlastendes, zu sehen, dass selbst der Premierminister keinen Bock auf Lockdown hatte. Also das ist die umgedrehte Form, das ist genauso wie bei Trump. Also jeder Trump-Skandal, wo er sagt, oh Gott, da hat er sich aber unflächtig ausgedrückt, ist für seine Wähler eine Entlastung. Sogar der Präsident sagt solche Worte, die ich ja normalerweise auch nicht sage, das hat der Pfarrer mir ja auch verboten. Aber jetzt ist das doch entlastend, wenn der Präsident das tut. Deswegen habe ich da von Anfang an nicht geglaubt, dass es, wie es dann so gerne geschrieben wird, eng wird für Boris Johnson.
Na mal sehen, aber es wirkt schon wie so ein Staubsauger für die schlechten Gewissen, die überall mal abgesaugt werden können, wenn selbst da oben sich so verhalten wird. Wir hören noch einen Clip von Kikuli, denn jetzt haben wir letztes Mal viel Drosten und so weiter. Kikuli spricht ja Drosten auch nur selten mit Namen aus, aber er hat ja auch so eine lustige Formulierung. Jetzt, da Omikron zur Verfügung steht, was ja fast klingt wie so eine Impfung, die hergestellt wurde, fand ich das irgendwie ganz witzig.
Ja, das ist in der Studie auch mit untersucht worden. Die Frage, wie ist das, wenn jemand, der geimpft ist und zusätzlich quasi Omikron kriegt. Da gibt es eben einen richtigen Booster-Effekt. Also das sieht man eigentlich gleich, wie man das bei einer Booster-Impfung sieht. Diese neutralisierenden Antikörper, die schießen da um das Zehnfache bis Fünfzigfache hoch. Also in kürzester Zeit, das heißt, man sieht so einen echten Booster-Effekt, bei denen, die geimpft waren und zusätzlich Omikron bekommen haben. Ich glaube, es gab mal einen in Deutschland bekannten Virologen, der gesagt hat, jetzt bin ich geimpft, jetzt hätte ich eigentlich nichts dagegen. Oder so sinngemäß, ich hoffe, ich gebe es nicht falsch, mich wieder infizieren zu lassen. Das ist schon viele Monate her, ist dann auch heiß diskutiert worden, wie er das möglicherweise gemeint haben könnte. Aber der wusste natürlich auch nicht, dass es Omikron geben würde, dann ein halbes Jahr später. Aber jetzt, wo Omikron zur Verfügung steht, würde ich jetzt im Nachhinein verstehen, was er vielleicht gemeint haben könnte.
Da kann man natürlich alles raushören.
Das spielt der Virologen. Ich hoffe wirklich auf eine schöne Sendung noch mal, mit allen Virologen zusammen. Irgend ein Quiz moderiert von Kai Pflaume oder so. Die Pandemie zu Ende ist, wenn wir wirklich den endemischen Zustand haben, dann man bunter ab mit allen Virologen. Ja, so eine Abschiedsskala oder das ist ein bisschen auch wie Dschungelcamp. Da ist es ja immer so, dass dann, wenn das Dschungelcamp zu Ende ist, noch mal alle Kandidaten aufeinandertreffen und sich auch noch mal Vorwürfe machen. Und da kann man ja dann noch mal sagen, ja, aber Herr Streeck, Sie haben ja damals und Streeck sagt dann ja, aber Herr Trosten, Sie haben ja im März das noch unterschätzt und so. Also ich glaube, da kann man richtig viel noch mal machen.
Siehst du ja, deswegen gucke ich nur das amerikanische Big Prater. Und das war das Einzige, was ich showmäßig im Fernsehen gucke. Da ist nämlich am Ende nur Halligallig gute Laune. Und alle sagen sich nochmal, dass sie die besten waren. Naja, also Omikron ist der Booster für Geboosterte. Wäre eine breite, wir haben es schon gehört, noch mehr impfen geht da nicht. Das irgendwann ist auch Schluss. Ja, also es muss dann die Impfung sein, die Infektion. Aber die wirkt dann wie ein Booster. So drei Clips müssen wir aber hier noch hören zum Thema China. Denn Corona allgemein gewinnt jetzt. Und das haben wir auch schon betont, dass Drossel das auch ein ganz wichtiges Thema ist, das immer wieder überhört wird. Er hat es schon seit Monaten auf dem Zettel. Wir hören ja mal Scott Galloway, der wiederum Ian Bremmer, Brenner, referiert. Den kennen wir ja auch. Ich sehe ihn vor allem bei Twitter häufig, der so die großen geopolitischen Lagen immer so im Auge behält. China hat am Anfang alles richtig gemacht, Infektionen verhindern. Und jetzt sitzen sie in der Falle. Sie kommen nicht raus und es ist genau das Falsche jetzt, diese krassen Lockdowns zu machen, weil sie politisch das ganze ökonomisch, das ganze Land und damit auch die ganze Welt lahmlegen. Kikole beschreibt auch noch mal die Lage Chinas.
In China ist es natürlich am krassesten. Also unter den Fachleuten kenne ich niemanden. Da muss ich aber sagen, da sitzt kein Mainland China Experte mit drinnen, sondern höchstens mal jemand aus Hongkong, der da teilnehmen darf. Es ist so, dass von den Fachleuten niemand hier nicht die Katastrophe kommen sieht. Also alle sagen, da gibt es keinen vernünftigen Ausweg. Und wir haben wirklich Angst, dass da nicht nur natürlich, weil das ja auch um die Menschen in China geht, sondern weil es auch um die weltweiten wirtschaftlichen Verflechtungen geht. China ist ja, wenn Sie mal rumgucken in jedem Büro, wenn Sie sich umdrehen, ein Drittel der ganzen Gegenstände, die da liegt, sind made in China. Und wir sehen die Probleme der Lieferketten ja jetzt schon bei Halbleiter, bei Automotive und überall. Und das wird so sein, ist die Befürchtung, dass in China diese Welle ganz massiv durchrollt. Man wird das mit dieser No-Covid-Strategie nicht durchhalten, weil wir eben jetzt diese Omikron-Variante haben, wo die Impfung überhaupt nicht wirkt, muss man sagen, der chinesische Impfstoff. Und das eben mit den üblichen Methoden dann so quasi Test und Trace, wie das ja dann heißt, also Nachverfolgung, Quarantäne, mit diesen Methoden nicht aufzuhalten ist. Das ist einer der Gründe, auch der Blick in dieses Ausland, warum ich jetzt hier für Deutschland ja die Empfehlung geben würde, sich auf die Isolierung und nicht mehr auf die Quarantäne zu fokussieren in unserer Lage. Das können aber die Chinesen nicht, weil die haben ja viel zu wenig geschützte Menschen. Das ist fürchterlich, also die kommen da wirklich nicht raus. Also das ist eine ganz schwierige Sache.
Ich will mal eine These in den Raum stellen. Ich will mal eine kontraintuitive These in den Raum stellen. Und zwar lasse ich gestern im Manager-Magazin einen Bericht über China. Und wie schwierig es jetzt ist für zum Beispiel deutsche Manager, die aber in China eigentlich tätig sind oder die pendeln, wieder nach China einzureisen. Katastrophale Berichte liest man da. Leute, die dann im Hotel warten müssen, bis sie abgeholt werden von Leuten in Kampfanzügen, die dann irgendwelche PCR-Tests nehmen. Dann geht es wieder zurück ins Hotelzimmer. Die Fenster sind vergittert, dass man nicht rausspringen kann. Oder ich weiß es nicht. Man muss Wochen warten, manchmal bis man sich wieder wirklich freitesten kann, weil die dann zwar schon eine ganz, ganz niedrige Viruslast haben. Also bei uns könnte man dann alles wieder machen. Aber da ist man dann immer noch zögerlich. Und dann sagt man, nee, dann bleiben sie lieber sechs Wochen in diesem Hotelzimmer jetzt sitzen. Also katastrophal so, dass also viele sich zurückgezogen haben. Viele aus China jetzt ausgereist sind und auch nicht mehr zurück wollen. Dramatische Geschichten von zum Beispiel einem deutschen Manager, der mit einer Chinesin verheiratet ist, die waren hier, haben das Kind bei den Großeltern drei Wochen lassen wollen, drei Jahre alt. Das Kind durfte nachher nicht mehr einreisen, konnte dann monatelang die Eltern nicht sehen. Also nur so verrückte Geschichten. Man fragt sich eigentlich, was ist da los? Und dann merkt man zugleich, die Chinesen nehmen dieses Decoupling, nicht bezogen auf den Klimawandel, sondern auf die eigene Wirtschaft, jetzt sehr ernst. Sie sind ja eine sehr große Volkswirtschaft mit über eine Milliarde Menschen. Und wenn man da versucht, sich ein bisschen stärker abzuschotten vom Ausland, wenn man auch sagt, naja, ihr dürft hier jetzt eure Manager in euren Firmen nicht mehr haben, sondern wir setzen da unsere Leute hin, also Mainland Chinese People, die dort das Sagen haben, so kommen wir auch besser an Informationen und so weiter dran, ist für mich jetzt die Frage oder die These, die ich in den Raum stelle, was ist, wenn es gar nicht daran liegt, dass die Chinesen jetzt uneinsichtig sind und ja auch mal Biontech und Moderna erordern könnten, sondern wenn sie das jetzt gerade diese Ausnahmesituation tatsächlich nutzen, um dieses Decoupling voranzubringen, um die Überwachung auszubreiten, denn das ist ja ganz enorm, was durch Corona da auch nochmal im Bezug auf Social Scoring und so weiter passiert ist und wie sie auch damit jetzt so einen äußeren Feind aufmachen, Ich glaube, es ist ein sehr guter Plan, um so ein Nationalgefühl zu stärken, das natürlich auch immer mit Angst und Schrecken verbunden ist. Ich weiß, das klingt wirtschaftlich irgendwie vollkommen unlogisch, aber in gewisser Weise ist ja ganz viel, was China jetzt gerade gemacht hat in den letzten Monaten und Jahren, volkswirtschaftlich sehr eigenartig. Also dass man große Börsengänge verbietet, wie zum Beispiel den Börsengang der Ant Group. Das hätte ja China sehr viel Geld und Renommee gebracht. Die chinesischen Kurse sind ja alle im Keller. Europäische, amerikanische Investoren haben sich zurückgezogen. Die fokussieren sich jetzt auf Indien. Man fragt sich ja sowieso, was da los ist. Das ist so ganz eigenartig. Denn man hat da ja eigentlich mit vielen Einhörnern und so weiter Unternehmen gehabt, wo der Westen die ganze Zeit dabei war. Und obwohl man mit dem Westen so viel Geld verdient und obwohl die deutsche Autoindustrie da so stark etabliert ist, ist man gar nicht darauf aus, zum Beispiel das Verhältnis zu Volkswagen in irgendeiner Weise zu verbessern. Ganz im Gegenteil. Und warum? Vielleicht, weil man möchte, dass immer mehr Chinesen erkennen, eigentlich brauche ich doch gar keinen Volkswagen. Für E-Mobilität bin ich doch bei NIO, also bei einem chinesischen Anbieter, viel besser aufgehoben. Also könnte es sein, dass das Teil einer patriotischen, protektionistischen, volkswirtschaftlichen Vorgehensweise jetzt ist. Und dass da doch ein Plan dahinter steht. Also es klingt fast verschwörungstheoretisch, aber man fragt sich ja schon, wie kann es sein?
Das mit dem Plan ist natürlich schwierig, aber die EU-Logik verschwende keine Krisen, das kann natürlich sein. Jetzt haben die sich ihren Plan zurechtgelegt, wie man das Land unterjocht. Und da bietet sich natürlich an, jetzt diesen Plan einfach mal auszubreiten. Dazu muss aber ein entsprechendes Decoupling in der Ideologie auch stattfinden. Denn ja, man kann natürlich jetzt die Chance nutzen und sozusagen die politische Herrschaft so richtig manifestieren. Wir wissen aber von Qi, dass seine politische Herrschaft, und es scheint bei ihm ja sehr tief verankert zu sein, diese Überlegung, sehr eng mit der wirtschaftlichen Prosperität für möglichst viele Chinesen zusammenhängt. Also dieses ganze Argument, wir haben in 20 Jahren, die wir die Millenniumsziele weltweit verfolgen, sehr viele Menschen aus der Armut geholt. Nur zu 100% ist das in China passiert. Wenn man den Rest der Welt anschaut, nicht. Und kann natürlich sein, dass das jetzt sozusagen Qi 2.0 ist, der sich decoupled von diesem Ökonomieargument und sagt, ich kriege denen das schon noch vermittelt. Hauptsache erstmal politisch ist die Hierarchie fest. Und jetzt zurre ich sie so richtig fest. Das kann natürlich sein, aber, und wir hören jetzt auch gleich nochmal einen Clip, wir haben ja letzte Woche schon viel Spaß gehabt mit Bert Rürup und Michael Hüther in ihrem Podcast, wie sie über die Schuldenbremse lachen. Und die haben sehr ausführlich auch über China jetzt gesprochen. Das ist für die Rentenrepublik super interessant, weil Michael Hüther ist total überzeugt, die Chinesen erleiden jetzt schon mal im Kleinen das Problem, was sie im Großen erleben werden. Sie schrumpfen. Die demografische Lage wird sie einfach überrennen. Die chinesische Politik und die Wirtschaft kann nicht schultern, was ihr als demografische Aufgabe jetzt historisch schicksalshaft einfach auferlegt wird die nächsten 30 Jahre. Und der ideologische Regress, so nennt das Michael Hüther, tut noch sein Übriges. Also diese Idee, wir könnten das irgendwie so Mao-Style uns daran orientieren. Und wir haben ja schon besprochen, wie sich das immer näher ranrobt an Peking. Aber das ganze Land schon wieder aus so einem neuen Chiarismus getrennt wird. Michael Hüther ist davon überzeugt, es wird nicht aufgehen. Also diese ganz große Logik, da wird selbst Indien heute noch so abgeschlagen. Selbst Indien, das ja nun demografisch China absehbar überholt, wird da auch wirtschaftlich die Führungsrolle übernehmen. Und bezogen auf das kleinere Problem, also jetzt konkret Corona, klingt es bei Michael Hüther und Bert Rürup so.
Was man ja akzeptieren müsste, ist, dass der Westen den besseren Impfstoff hat. Und das ist schon etwas, was die Gesichtswahrung, glaube ich, nicht so ganz einfach zulässt. Man hat den versucht, schlecht zu machen, den von BioNTech und das auch von Moderna. Und jetzt steht man bei so einem eigenen Problem, dass der heimische Impfstoff nicht gut ist und glaubt ja, dass man das so einhegen konnte. Eine ganze Zeit hat das funktioniert. Aber wenn ich das jetzt so richtig verstehe wie Pandemien, und das ist ja auch mit der spanischen Grippe so gewesen, die nach drei Jahren, die begann 1918, haben zumindest die ersten Aufzeichnungen, und irgendwie 1920, 1921 war es dann durch, dazu geführt hat, dass das irgendwann das Virus so mutiert, dass es sozusagen endemisch wird.
Was wir gegenwärtig erleben.
Genau, was wir erleben. Und das heißt aber, du kannst es gar nicht mit solchen Maßnahmen beantworten und du musst impfen oder du kriegst anders eine Herdenimmunität herstellen. Und da steht China jetzt wirklich vor einem massiven Problem und wir alle samt damit, denn jedes Mal, wenn die Junghafen dichtmachen oder ein Stadt sind einfach enorme Behinderungen in den Liefersystemen ausgelöst.
Ja, leidet der Westen ja fast mehr als das Land selbst wirtschaftlich.
Also das Land selber leidet vor allem unter den Cuppling. Dass ihnen aufgezwungen wird, wir akzeptieren keine Impfstoffe von außen. Wir warten lieber noch drei Jahre, bis wir das selber mit der Technik hinbekommen. Wir wissen aber, wie kompliziert das ist. Das haben wir ja an CureVac gesehen, selbst wenn man die Technik erfindet und seit 20 Jahren dran rumtestet und experimentiert, klappt es am Ende dann trotzdem nicht. Und in der Ansicht ist das eine ganz schwierige Lage für China. Und auch hier die Ökonomen. Ich meine, Michael Hüther hat ja auch schon mit dem RKI und dem Helmholtz-Zentrum so ein Texte publiziert. Aber mittlerweile sind sich alle einig. Kekole, Drosten, Rürup, Hüther, alle. Das Virus läuft einmal durch. Die endemische Situation kommt erst mit den Infektionen. Die Infektion selbst kann man aber abschwächen durch Impfung vorher. Aber ohne Impfung hat man trotzdem Infektion. Und dieser Weg für China, da jetzt ohne Infektion. Und in China ist der Gesundheitszustand jetzt auch nicht so gut für die ganzen Leute. Das ist dann schwierig.
Es ist eine Binze zu sagen, dass autokratische Staaten nicht immer das Wohl des Volkes im Blick haben. Aber mich erinnert das so ein bisschen an eine Passage in einem Scherzkek Buch. Da geht es um die Sowjetunion und er fragt sich irgendwann, wen hat denn eigentlich die Partei repräsentiert? Also die Bauern waren es nicht, die Arbeiter waren es nicht, aber auch nicht die Intellektuellen und die Künstler sowieso nicht. Und dann geht er das alles durch. Ja, die haben natürlich am Ende nur noch sich selbst repräsentiert. Und die Frage ist jetzt auch hier, ob Xi und die seinen eigentlich nur sich selbst repräsentieren und für sich eine Machterhaltungspolitik am Ende fahren. Denn tatsächlich dient es weder der Volkswirtschaft noch dem Wohl des Volkes, wenn man diese Impfung nicht zulässt, wenn man immer wieder neue Lockdowns geht und wenn man ein Decoupling betreibt, das eigentlich auch nicht darauf ausgelegt ist, dass dadurch das Land wirklich zu einem besseren sich entwickelt. Wenngleich ja China darauf angewiesen ist, dass die Bevölkerung allgemein einen höheren Wohlstand erreicht, einfach damit auch ein innerer Frieden herrscht. Also das ist sehr, sehr widersprüchlich, was jetzt da gerade geschieht. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das weitergeht und ob es da nochmal eine große Wendung dann gibt, dass man doch sagt, jetzt müssen wir impfen oder man lässt das knallhart durchrauschen. Keine Ahnung, was da sein wird, denn das wird ja sonst noch Jahre so weitergehen. Und dann muss sich ja wirklich Europa was einfallen lassen. Man sieht das jetzt zum Beispiel am Automarkt schon sehr schön. Gebrauchtwagen sind inzwischen knapp. Neuwagen kommt man nicht mehr dran und ein Gebrauchtwagen war dann die Alternative. Und auch da gibt es eine extreme Knappheit jetzt. Also sehen wir da immer mehr, dass sich die Autoindustrie was einfallen lassen muss. Und man wird auch sehen, wie sich zum Beispiel die deutsche Autoindustrie an Elon Musk orientiert, der ja versucht, eigentlich eine Plattform aufzubauen mit Tesla, dass er nicht einfach, dass der Autos produziert und dann seine Lieferketten jeweils hat, sondern der sagt ja eigentlich würde ich gerne alles aus einer Hand machen. Und das ist dann die Frage, inwieweit das auch andere, zum Beispiel die deutschen Autokonzerne, tun werden.
Genau, letzter Gedanke zu China. Es beginnt jetzt Olympia, wo man sich sehr viele Menschen ins Land holt und dieses Neujahrsfest der Chinesen, wo mehr als eine Milliarde Reisebewegungen einfach erwartet werden. Das ist natürlich die hohe Situation, denn man hat jetzt schon den ersten Comic-Con Fall.
Aber das war doch schon das Neujahrsfest, oder?
Es steht jetzt irgendwie an, glaube ich. Oder war es jetzt? Also wenn, dann war es jetzt die Tage. Und wir wissen ja bei Corona, die Nachwirkung kommt dann so. Man hat jetzt in Peking den ersten positiven Omikron-Fall gehabt. Das wurde dann nachrichtlich ganz illustrativ übermittelt. Man wusste alles über diese Frau. Wen hat sie gesprochen? Wo war sie auf Toilette? Wann war sie? Was hat sie gemacht? Wen hat sie gesehen? Mit wem hat sie telefoniert? Nur eins weiß man nicht. Wo hat sie die Omikroninfektion her? Also es scheint tatsächlich zum Teil ein so schwaches Virus zu sein, dass es durch so junge Studentengruppen einfach durchgeht. Niemand merkt irgendwas. Und dann irgendwann erreicht es jemanden, der es dann doch merkt. Und da ist natürlich so eine Reisebewegung die größte Migrationsbewegung der Welt. Dieses Neujahrsfest, das ist natürlich dann richtig der Horror, weil dann findet eine richtige Durchmischung statt. Also mal gucken, da können wir dann wahrscheinlich Ende Februar schon drüber sprechen.
Wir werden sehen, wir müssen nochmal über Schulden sprechen. Wir haben ja schon gesagt, die Schuldenbremse bleibt bestehen, weil sie nicht so einfach auszuhebeln geht. Man braucht eine Zweidrittelmehrheit. Also hat man da neue Konstrukte sich ausgedacht und arbeitet auch mit einem Nachtragshaushalt. Wir können uns ja jetzt in dieser Ausnahmesituation mehr verschulden als sonst, können also über den engen Rahmen der Schuldengrenze hinaus agieren. Wenn wir aber jetzt das Geld für die Pandemiebekämpfung nicht direkt brauchen, können wir dann nicht vielleicht sagen, wir nehmen die 60 Milliarden und geben die später aus, verbuchen das aber noch auf den Haushalt 21. Also wir sehen, da wird viel mit Buchungen gearbeitet und das hat natürlich auch jetzt im Bundestag interessiert. Man hat eine öffentliche Anhörung gemacht mit lauter Experten, die das versuchen, mal einzuordnen. Darf man das überhaupt, was die Ampelkoalition davor hat? Die CDU macht ja Panik, wiederholt unauffällig 60 Milliarden. Stellen Sie sich das mal vor, als würde das irgendeinen jetzt direkt betreffen, als müsste ich da jetzt auch gleich mein Portemonnaie öffnen und eine Spende abgeben. Na ja, es gab diese öffentliche Anhörung. Und Helge Braun hat das Ganze moderiert, aber das spielt jetzt hier keine Rolle. Wir hören als Erstes Joachim Wieland, der mal sagt, dass das Geld auch, dass man jetzt für die Pandemie sich da beschafft hat, über den engen Rahmen der Pandemie hinaus eingesetzt werden kann. Zum Beispiel mit Blick auf das Klima.
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen, die das Bundesverfassungsgericht in seiner wegweisenden Entscheidung vom 24. März 2021 dringend fordert und dem Gesetzgeber aufgegeben hat, können ebenso zur Pandemiebekämpfung eingesetzt werden, wie Transformationsmaßnahmen, insbesondere im Bereich der Digitalisierung.
Also Klimaschutz und Transformation dienen der Bekämpfung der pandemiebedingten Folgen für die Wirtschaft.
Dem widerspricht ein anderer Experte, nämlich Gröpel. Der konzentriert sich dabei aber mal auf den privaten Haushalt bei seinem Beispiel.
Lassen Sie mich vielleicht mit einem kleinen übertragenen Beispiel beginnen. Im Ahrtal wurde ein Einfamilienhaus des Eigentümers zerstört. Er geht zur Kreditanstalt für Wiederaufbau. Er bekommt einen Aufbaukredit für sein Haus. Da bleiben aber dann überraschenderweise Mittel übrig. Und jetzt geht er zur Kreditanstalt und sagt auch, die restlichen Mittel, die möchte ich mir jetzt, die möchte ich für etwas ganz anderes verwenden. Die Anschaffung eines Elektroautos. Das fördert erstens den Autohändler im Ahrtal, der auch gelitten hat unter der Katastrophe.
Tja, aber ist ein Staat nicht irgendwie ein bisschen anders konstituiert als ein privater Haushalt und das Verhältnis des Schuldners gegenüber der Bank, könnte man fragen. So eine Anhörung ist ja immer ein Kräftemessen der Experten. Also natürlich sind da die Politiker da, die fragen dann meistens die Experten, die sie eingesetzt haben, um nochmal zu hören, ja, wir dürfen Schulden machen oder nein, wir müssen uns dringend an die Verfassung halten und die sieht nun einmal vor, dass so funktioniert das ganze Spiel. Interessant ist natürlich, was die Experten da untereinander verhandeln. Alexander Thiele, Jurist, antwortet dann erstmal nicht auf die Frage, die ihm gestellt wurde, sondern auf Gröpel.
Ein kurzer Hinweis zu dem Beispiel von Herrn Gröpel. Ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich sinnvoll ist, ein Beispiel aus dem Zivilrecht zu nehmen, um die Reichweite einer finanzverfassungsrechtlichen Ausnahmeklausel zu bestimmen. Also aus meiner Sicht ist der Vergleich nicht sonderlich tauglich.
Ja, denn wenn man sich auf dieses Feld begibt, einfach jedes Argument, nur weil die gleichen Substantive vorkommen, zuzulassen, dann ist alles möglich. Und dann ist aber auch alles richtig. Weil dann treffen so viele Rationalitäten aufeinander, dass alles Sinn ergibt.
Ja, deswegen muss man das Blickfeld ein bisschen weiten. Und das tut Thiele. Wie sieht eigentlich Krisenbewältigung ganzheitlich aus?
Dem Artikel 115 Absatz 2 geht es mit Sicherheit darum, diese Krise endgültig zu überwinden. Das will er sicherstellen, damit wir dann nicht erneut wieder in eine Katastrophe hineinschlädern, die möglicherweise sehr viel teurer ist. Das heißt, diese Art der Krise ist aus meiner Sicht entscheidend. Und daraus ergibt sich dann eben auch was Mittelbar und was Unmittelbar ist. Begriffe, die ja ohnehin völlig normativ geprägt und wertungsgeprägt sind. Was in einem Fall mittelbar ist, ist möglicherweise in einem anderen Fall also unmittelbar.
Immer wieder lustig, finde ich, wenn Juristen sich selber nochmal dran... Ich kann erinnern, dass es sie ja aus Gründen gibt, weil man nämlich Interpretationen vornehmen muss. Und die Sache nicht einfach so wie sie im Buch stehen, einfach interpretieren darf.
Sehr gut, kommt gleich auch noch mal ein wunderbarer Aspekt dazu, zu diesem Interpretationsspielraum. Und ganz genau darum geht es ja. Also ich würde sogar bei Gröpels Beispiel sagen, ja aber warum denn eigentlich nicht? Also wenn man doch von der KfW was bekommt und es ist noch Geld da, man dürfte jetzt nicht sagen, ich kaufe mir dafür Anzüge oder kaufe mir dafür einen Flug mit Jeff Bezos Rakete. Aber zu sagen, ich setze auch noch in der Garage auf E-Mobilität und lege mir da einen Anschluss, das wäre ja eigentlich sehr sinnvoll, das zu tun. Und genauso ist ja auch die Frage, wenn man Geld für einen Wiederaufbau bekommt oder wenn man jetzt eben Geld bekommt, um die Pandemie zu bewältigen. Und wo setzt man dieses Geld ein? Also grundsätzlich würde es dem BIP ja auch helfen, wenn man sagt, wir bauen noch fünf weitere Kohlekraftwerke in Deutschland. Das würde das BIP erstmal verbessern. Und damit hätte man etwas gegen die pandemiebedingte Wirtschaftsschwächung getan. Aber ist das dann genau der richtige Schritt? Nein, denn wir haben ja dieses Gesetz des Urteils vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, das sagt, naja, aber Klimawandel muss auch primär in die Entscheidung mit einbezogen werden. Und deswegen sind jetzt Kohlekraftwerke keine gute Idee, vielleicht Solaranlagen schon.
Da kommen wir nachher noch ausführlich drauf. Aber ich frage mich auch bei diesem Einstiegsargument hier. Also wenn ein Häuslebauern Kredit bekommt und dann kriegt er da Geld für, dann muss er das seiner Bank erklären, was er dann mit dem Rest Geld, das noch übrig ist und so weiter. Da frage ich mich natürlich, jetzt gerade hängen ja 20 Milliarden Anträge in der Luft, weil Menschen, die Häuser bauen, durch ein Programm des Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums Gelder beantragen durften, die ihnen aber jetzt nicht bewilligt werden, obwohl sie ihnen vom Gesetz eigentlich zustehen. Aber das Programm wurde einfach mal zwei Wochen eher beendet, wo es hieß, ja, wenn sie 50 Prozent unterhalb der energetischen Bedarfe des Ursprungs-Standard-Baus-Benchmark, den wir irgendwann mal keine Ahnung woher kommt. Und das Ding ist ja auch deswegen so überlaufen, weil einfach jeder heute nach diesem neuen Standard baut. Also mit 50 oder 40 Prozent des Referenzwerts in der Klimafreundlichkeit, das ist ja heute Standard-Bauen, so wie ich dann gehört habe, wo man sich natürlich auch fragt, ja wofür bekommen die denn dann das Geld? Ruft dann die KfW an und sagt, also die haben ja eigentlich sowieso ein Standardhaus, es wäre ja kompliziert eigentlich über 50 Prozent zu kommen und so weiter. Na ja, da guckt ja auch keiner nach, sondern da ist einfach ein Antrag, dann wird gefragt, sie brauchen das fürs Klima, dann sagt man ja, dann sitzt so ein Notar daneben, der guckt nochmal, was der Architekt gemacht hat, alles wird abgenickt und dann ist es erledigt. Was dann mit dem Geld passiert, ist eigentlich egal. Und so wie er dieses vulgäre Argument aus Mikro- und Makro-Brückenschlag einfach gemacht hat, kann man ja auch sagen, wir machen es jetzt einfach mal im Staat so, wie es eben nicht ist, wie sie behaupten, sondern Geld wird halt einfach verwendet, egal für was. Soweit ich weiß, bekommt sowieso jeder bei einem Kreditantrag für große Projekte, Häuser oder wie auch immer dann die Frage, sollen wir noch 20 oder 30.000 mehr aufnehmen, für den Fall, dass noch irgendwas ist und so. Und dann sagt man halt ja oder nein. Ja, also dieses ganze Argument ist so banane, aber das so im Bundestag vorzubringen, ist auch wirklich mutig, muss ich sagen.
Ja, finde ich auch. Thiele aber korrigiert das sehr schön und bezieht sich auch mal auf das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts.
Zweitens kommt es auf die konkrete Mittelverwendung an. Der Schwarz hat das ja bereits angesprochen. Ich glaube schon, dass es einen Unterschied macht, ob die Mittel verwendet werden für einen Bereich, der nichts mit dem Zweck des 115 zu tun hat, der möglicherweise sogar gänzlich diesem widerspricht, weil er rein konsumtiv überhaupt keinerlei finanzielle Entlastung für nachfolgende Generationen zeitigt, oder ob es sich um eine Mittelverwendung handelt, die tatsächlich dem Zweck eigentlich nachkommt des 115, nämlich finanzielle Entlastung zukünftiger Generationen sicherzustellen. Das tut ja das, was der Klimaschutz tut, was wir mittlerweile verfassungsgerichtlich auch bestätigt haben. Dass die finanziellen Auswirkungen massiv wären, wenn wir jetzt nichts täten. Und um es vielleicht etwas deutlicher zu sagen, es ist wenig sinnvoll, jetzt Geld zu sparen, damit es dann später sehr viel teurer wird.
Jens Südekum war auch zu Gast und betont noch mal den Sinn von Rücklagen.
Der Abgeordnete Fricke hat gefragt nach dem Zeithorizont dieser Maßnahmen. Ich glaube, die Nutzung einer Rücklage ist genau das Mittel der Wahl, um eine effektive Investitionsförderung tatsächlich bewerkstelligen zu können. Denn wir haben in der Vergangenheit oft gesehen, wozu es führt, wenn Investitionsförderung oder überhaupt Förderpolitik mit kurzfristigen Instrumenten probiert wird. Ganz oft führt es zu nicht abfließenden Mitteln. Und genau da kommt ein Konstrukt der Rücklage ins Spiel, wo eben das Jährlichkeitsprinzip im Prinzip ein wenig ausgehebelt wird und eine Überjährigkeit des Mittelabflusses eben gerade im Zentrum der Konstruktion steht.
Ja, das sollte man sowieso mal machen. Das sollte man sowieso mal machen mit diesem Jährlichkeitsprinzip. Denn das eine ist, dass die Mittel nicht abfließen. Dann hat es aber wenigstens nichts gekostet. Noch verrückter ist ja, wenn man sagt, die Mittel müssen abfließen. Und dann fließen die irgendwo hin, wo sie aber vollkommen sinnlos verpraten werden. Man kennt das auch aus Fernsehanstalten oder aus privaten Unternehmen. Das gesagt wird, wir haben noch Mittel, die müssen ausgegeben werden. Dann werden die Mittel nicht ausgegeben. Dann bekommt man im nächsten Jahr weniger bewilligt. Dafür hat man Angst. Also sagt man, ich habe es wirklich auch schon gehört von Leuten vom Fernsehen. Dann sagt man lieber noch, gut, dann nehmen wir für die Show noch ein 50-köpfiges Ballett. Denn die Mittel müssen ja rausgehen, statt einfach zu sagen, ach, das Geld wäre ganz gut, denn wir wollen ja im nächsten Jahr da eine größere Recherche machen. Da verwenden wir es dafür, geht nicht. Und das gilt bei ganz vielen Dingen so. Insofern, glaube ich, sollte dieser Ansatz viel häufiger mal angewendet werden, dass Rücklagen, gerade wenn man langfristig was plant und organisieren will, sehr, sehr sinnvoll sind. Übrigens auch im privaten Haushalt, da macht man das ja auch so. Da sagten wir auch nicht, ach, es ist schon fast ein Monatsende, ich muss aber dringend noch mein ganzes Gehalt loswerden.
Ja, das ist wirklich so Wahnsinn. Und man hört dann immer so, ich meine, das ist jetzt Bundestag und groß aufgehangen. Und dann hört man so hier ins Südekommen, denkt sich dabei, ja, macht total Sinn und kommt dann so ins Grübeln. Wie macht denn das die Politik eigentlich gerade, damit er das hier mal so als könnte man ja auch mal machen? Ja, und dann, ja stimmt, in jeder Schule ist es so, in jeder Bundeswehreinrichtung, in überall, in jedem Verein, der gefördert wird, müssen die Mittel weg. Dann bestellt man halt noch mal zwei Drucker und 700 Bleistifte. Hauptsache, man hat nächstes Jahr wieder Budget. Statt einfach zu sagen, das sparen wir mal auf für nächstes Jahr, dann bündeln wir die Budgets und dann schlagen wir mal richtig zu.
Damit hier nicht der Eindruck entsteht, ihr hätten jetzt lauter gute Leute gesprochen, wie Thiele oder Südekrum, möchte ich jetzt mal symptomatisch einen Ausschnitt bringen von Dieter Hugo vom Bundesrechnungshof, der sich das alles gar nicht mehr erklären kann. Was passiert da mit den Buchungen und den Zahlen?
Ein Kreditbedarf in Höhe von 60 Milliarden, der jetzt in eine unechte Rücklage des unechten Sondervermögens, LIKF, gesteckt werden soll, also Sie sehen schon, das ist alles unecht, das ist virtuell, es ist kassenmäßig und mittelmäßig, passiert überhaupt nichts mehr im Haushalt 21.
Ja, alles virtuell und man könnte auch denken, ja klar, man muss in Bilanzen mal wieder denken und vielleicht auch das Geld, wie Aaron Sahr ja vorschlägt, so als eine Infrastruktur wirklich verstehen und nicht einfach nur mal so, wie das hier ist, haben wir es, haben wir es nicht, können wir es ausgeben oder nicht, sondern dass man einfach sagt, was können wir jetzt damit ermöglichen, wir verstehen also Geld auch als Infrastruktur, das ist, was noch zu denken wäre, aber wenn man natürlich nur in diesen Bilanzen immer gedacht hat und der Herr tat das, dann ist man jetzt vollkommen überfordert bzw. in gewisser Weise zerbricht ja dann für viele Leute auch so das eigene Lebenswerk, habe ich gedacht. Also wenn das immer so wichtig war, wir müssen hier die Bilanzen und da kann nicht das vom letzten Jahr noch in das nächste überhängen, wenn das immer eigentlich das Dogma war, wenn das immer das war, woran man glaubte, wenn man Mitglied nicht der Kirche, sondern des Bundesrechnungshofs war und wenn dies jetzt nun anfängt zu bröckeln, wenn man sieht ach so, das ist auch etwas politisch Konstruiertes dahinter steht dann politischer Wille, der lässt sich aber auch ändern, dann gehen hier so manche Weltgebäude kaputt und das ist sicherlich auch schmerzhaft dann für jeden einzelnen.
Es ist vor allem besonders schade, weil bisher hat man immer gesagt, hört nicht auf dem Bund der Steuerzahler, das ist nur so eine FDP Einrichtung, guckt was der Bundesrechnungshof rechnet, nur der hat sich halt auch komplett Merkelisiert, da kommt jetzt mit der neuen Situation wirklich nicht klar, also es ist ganz traurig auch diese Brandbriefe, die da geschrieben werden teilweise.
Und sagt dann ist es alles virtuell, also in gewisser Weise ja, ist das natürlich virtuell, also wir haben ja jetzt nicht, dass irgendwelche Goldbarren umgesiedelt werden von einem ins nächste Jahr. Es ist ganz amüsant, wie hier noch auch über Geld dann nachgedacht wird.
Aber man muss das sich wirklich mal vergegenwärtigen. Die Bundesbank, die ja diese Rechnung tatsächlich ausführt am Ende, der ist es ja immer ganz wichtig, dass sie wie so ein Day-Trader mit null in den Tag reingeht und am Ende des Tages wieder mit null abschließt. Also da kann man sich vorstellen, wie auf so einer Raumschiffbrücke, da steht der Captain vorne und ruft dann die einzelnen Mitarbeiter auf und fragt die nochmal, könnt ihr da noch die Ausgleichsbuchung so und so machen, dass wir dann und dann versucht man möglichst nah am Tagesende diesen Nullbetrag ranzukommen. Und genau in dieser Denke hängt dieser Bundesrechnungshof auch. Wenn da jemand kommt mit, wir haben hier so ein virtuelles Konto laufen, auf dem sammelt sich irgendwie so Buchunghalter, dann kommen die damit wirklich nicht klar. Das ist ganz erstaunlich, dass das auf so einer elementaren Ebene da einfach nicht klappt mitzudenken, Schritt zu halten mit der modernen Welt.
Hans-Güter Hennike, auch ein Verfechter der Schuldenbremse, sagt das auch immer ganz deutlich in der FAZ, schreibt da Gastbeiträge, kommt auch hier zu Wort.
Aber das watile Macht ist im Grunde Bismarck von 1862 wiederholt, sozusagen eine Lückentheorie im Haushalt. Damals ging es um die Heeresreform, eine Lückentheorie sozusagen wieder einzuführen, indem man sozusagen im Nachgang sagt, na ja, ein bisschen müssen wir ja die gesamtwirtschaftliche Entwicklung doch wieder einbeziehen. Wir sind hier heute am 10. Januar 2022, geben eine Empfehlung für den Nachtragshaushaltsgesetzgeber, der sozusagen 60 Milliarden Euro in 21 Buchungstechnisch, das ist ja hier mehrfach erläutert worden, dass das Geld nicht mehr verschwinden lassen soll, damit dieses Geld, das ist eben gerade vonseiten der SPD-Fraktion nochmal eindrucksvoll gefragt worden, 2023 fortfolgende, ausgegeben werden kann. Wir reden sozusagen über einen Buchungstrick.
In gewisser Weise hat er recht. Also in gewisser Weise stimmt das, aber man kann fragen, wo ist sonst noch überall ein Buchungstrick zu finden? Und wir müssen uns einfach mal davon verabschieden, dass wir von diesem statischen Denken beherrscht werden. Und dass das aber etwas ist, was wir uns selbst auferlegt haben. Also das nicht irgendeinem höheren Gesetz entspricht. Das ist eben nicht wie bei der Virologie, wo man sagt, wir haben uns das jetzt mal so hinkonstruiert. Das Virus ist so und so gefährlich, sondern das Virus ist dann so gefährlich. Und hier aber hat man sich ein Konstrukt geschaffen und muss jetzt natürlich, weil man diese bekloppte Schuldenbremse hat, irgendeinen Weg finden, das Ganze zu umgehen. Insofern sind die natürlich schon auf der richtigen Fährte, wenn sie sagen, das ist aber jetzt irgendwie anders, wie wir das immer gemacht haben. Aber das hilft ja nichts. Man kann ja auch einfach mal anerkennen, es war vielleicht bislang auch nicht gut. Und die jetzt auf Bismarck zu verweisen, ist selbstverständlich für Thiele ein Anreiz, da selbst mal mit einem Vergleich zu kommen.
Ich gebe es zurück, indem ich Sie jetzt mit Hans Kelsen vergleiche und die reine Rechtslehre ins Spiel bringe und sage, ich bin etwas überrascht, dass Sie glauben, dass man den 115 ohne ökonomische Gesichtspunkte auslegen könnte. Das scheint mir doch ein Rückfall in etwas seltsam mit positivistische Zeiten zu sein. Selbstverständlich müssen wir bei der Bewertung, inwieweit eine wirtschaftliche, durch die Pandemie bedingte Krise überwunden werden kann, die Ökonomie zur Rate ziehen. Um Gottes Willen. Das machen die Juristen hoffentlich nicht alleine.
Und mit Pandemie und einer ökonomischen Einschätzung, wenn man jetzt wieder kommt, fragt, was glauben Sie, wann ist die Pandemie ökonomisch überwunden? Ja, 2035 vielleicht ganz genau.
Und natürlich spielen all diese Dinge mit rein in eine Entscheidung. Und man kann nicht einfach nur sagen, ja, aber Gesetz ist ja so, wie wir das damals gesagt haben, mit der Schuldenbremse. Und da ist jetzt nicht mehr von abzuweichen. Und wir können nicht die anderen Dinge mit reinbeziehen. Warum bezieht er sich hier auf Hans Kelsen und den Rechtspositivismus? Weil das natürlich ein rechtspositivistisches, rein rechtspositivistisches Argument wäre, wenn man sagt, nur das Gesetz gilt, alles andere, Klima und sowas. Das kann jetzt hier überhaupt nicht drin vorkommen. Wir wissen, dass es auch andere Punkte gibt, die bei der Rechtsprechung eine Rolle spielen müssen. Und die Juristerei hat das natürlich dann auch erkannt. Und das ist eine ganz interessante Auseinandersetzung mit Kelsen. Also wenn man das wirklich mal in pointierter und auch in interessanter Weise finden will, dann kann man sich ja rechtspositivistisch auch erklären bei den Nürnberger Prozessen. Also da waren ja Nazis, die dort saßen, sagten ja, aber das Gesetz sah wie folgt aus. Und an dieses Gesetz habe ich mich gehalten. Also das ist ein rein rechtspositivistischer Ansatz. Und dann ist aber die Frage, kann das ausreichen? Und würde das dann bedeuten? Dann kann man auch niemanden verurteilen. Und die Antwort ist natürlich nein. Man setzt diesem Rechtspositivismus noch etwas entgegen. Es gibt andere Dinge, Menschenrecht und so, die wichtig sind. Es gibt die Ratbruchschiffformel. Wer das jetzt mal als Spielfilm richtig spannend sehen will, muss sich das Urteil von Nürnberg ansehen. Da ist nämlich Maximilian Schell derjenige, der Anwalt, der rechtspositivistisch argumentiert und der dann zurechtgewiesen wird, muss man sich unbedingt mal ansehen, um diesen Vergleich von Thiele jetzt in all seinen Dimensionen zu erkennen. Für Thiele ging es aber jetzt hier vor allem darum, dass man mit dieser rein juristischen Sache bezogen auf die Schuldenbremse nicht weiterkommt. Ausgeblendet wird ja dabei auch, dass das ja auch ein Resultat eines politischen Willens schon ist, diese Schuldenbremse. Also es wird hier so ganz funktional von dieser Seite argumentiert, als sei dann nie die Politik mit im Spiel gewesen. Jetzt kommt die Politik in Form von, wir müssen den Klimawandel berücksichtigen oder so mit rein, dann sagt man ja, wir können jetzt nicht diese politischen Argumente noch mit reinbeziehen. Es ist sehr, sehr eigenartig. Ich würde aber sagen, das Glanzlicht bei dieser Anhörung war Friederike Spieker, die ja auch zusammen mit Flasbeck arbeitet. Und sie ist natürlich dafür, dass das jetzt mit den 60 Milliarden so gehandhabt wird. Aber das Problem ist viel größer und sie spricht hier, glaube ich, etwas an, was uns die nächsten Jahre beschäftigen wird. Wir hören uns diese Clips mal einzeln an.
Das Gesetz zu diesem zweiten Nachtragshaushalt scheint mir einen fundamentalen Widerspruch in der deutschen Wirtschaftspolitik aufzuzeigen. Und zwar eben einerseits geht es um die formale Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse und andererseits ist ein Rückgriff auf eine große Verschuldungsbereitschaft des Auslandes erforderlich, um die Ziele der deutschen Wirtschaft, nämlich die Konjunktur anzuwägen und die Konjunktur nicht einbrechen zu lassen, zu erreichen. Und das ist in meinen Augen ein großer logischer Widerspruch. Ich betone logisch ein Widerspruch, der nicht auf bestimmten ökonomischen Theorien aufbaut oder Modellen oder ideologischen Vorstellungen oder auch nicht auf juristischen Überlegungen, sondern auf der Grundgleichung, die in jeder monetären Volkswirtschaft gelten muss. Nämlich, dass die Summe aller Ausgaben gleich der Summe aller Einnahmen ist.
Ja, sehr gut. Das ist ja wirklich eins zu eins Flasbeck. Dieses Argument macht er ja seit Jahren. Irgendwer muss sich hier verschulden. Entweder der Käufer am Ende, der Konsument oder der Hersteller, der Unternehmer oder das Land oder das Ausland. Einer von den Vieren ist es und dass sie nochmal darauf hinweist, während die Männer gerade schon so ein Ping-Pong, wer arbeitet hier eigentlich gerade auf der richtigen Grundlage, dass sie nochmal sagt, also jetzt mal alle Ideologien und Ökonomien außen vor. Hier greift einfach die Logik. Das finde ich auch sehr tapfer.
Wie ist denn das jetzt mit dieser Nachfrage-Lücke in Deutschland?
Und diese Grundgleichung erfordert in Deutschland, dass das Sparverhalten der privaten Sektoren, also der privaten Haushalte und der Unternehmen ein Gegenstück braucht, nämlich ein Schuldner. Und die privatwirtschaftlich verursachte Nachfrage-Lücke wird von der EU-Kommission für dieses Jahr 2022 auf 330 Milliarden geschätzt und für nächstes Jahr auf immerhin noch 275 Milliarden Euro.
330 Milliarden Nachfrage-Lücke. Die Frage ist, wer soll denn jetzt in diese Nachfrage-Lücke springen?
Und wenn der deutsche Staatshaushalt so konzipiert wird, dass er diese Nachfrage-Lücke bei Weitem nicht füllt, muss für diese Nachfrage-Lücke das Ausland einspringen. Andernfalls stürzt die deutsche Konjunktur und mit ihr die europäische ab.
Das heißt, es gibt jetzt hier nicht genügend Nachfrage, zum Beispiel nach irgendwelchen Produkten, was auch immer. Jetzt ist aber die Sache, jetzt könnte man sagen, naja, gut, dann verkaufen wir halt weniger. Aber dann bricht die deutsche Wirtschaft zusammen oder bricht sehr stark ein. Das will man nicht, also muss man irgendwo andere Abnehmer finden. Wir wissen aber, dass wenn es andere Abnehmer dafür geben soll, dann müssen die ja auch irgendwoher das Geld nehmen. Die müssen sich zum Beispiel verschulden, um das bezahlen zu können. Wenn ein Land sehr viel mehr exportiert als es importiert, dann wird es reicher. Wenn ein Land immer mehr nur noch importieren muss, aber ihm nichts mehr abgenommen wird, dann wird es ärmer. Das war ja der Konflikt zum Beispiel zwischen China und England im 19. Jahrhundert. Die Chinesen Anfang des 19. Jahrhunderts haben unglaublich viel exportieren können, sagten dann auch den Engländern, wir hätten gerne immer Gold als Bezahlung, also wurden die immer reicher und die Engländer haben versucht, auch irgendwas dahin zu exportieren, aber das wurde gar nicht gewollt. Das führte dann dazu, dass auf Dauer England natürlich ärmer geworden wäre und dann begann dieses Ganze mit Opiumkrieg und so, das müssen wir jetzt nicht ausbreiten, aber wir können daran sehr gut sehen, wie also so ein Ungleichgewicht Volkswirtschaften ärmer oder reicher macht und wie man als reiche Volkswirtschaft auf Export orientiert, ausgerichtet, ist darauf, dass die anderen Länder Schulden machen zum Beispiel, um Produkte zu kaufen.
Also wenn man sich das so aufstößt, wir haben jetzt modernes Geld, also es hängt ja nicht mehr an einer Limitierung von Gold oder so, um dieses System aufrecht zu halten. Wir haben also in Deutschland den Exportweltmeister, der gleichzeitig keine Binnennachfrage hat, weil größter Niedriglohnsektor der Welt und so weiter. Gleichzeitig haben wir aber Käufer im Ausland, von denen man aber nicht einfach sagen kann, dass sie ärmer werden. Denn in Amerika haben wir ja die Sachlage, dass sich die Politiker auch fragen, wir haben jetzt dem Volk 5 Billionen Dollar geschenkt. Entweder den Superreichen durch irgendwelche Trickle-down-Ideologien, also Trumps Steuermäßigung oder eben Pandemiehilfe, kriegen einfach einen Scheck, Brieffkasten auf, 1000 Dollar rein, Brieffkasten zu. Fehlt niemandem das Geld, weil wurde ja geschöpft. Ich frage mich dann immer, wann merken wir das in Deutschland, dass hier die ganze Zeit Leute für sehr wenig Geld ziemlich krasse Sachen bauen, Autos, Maschinen, was auch immer, gleichzeitig, das ist jetzt sehr vulgär ausgedrückt, gleichzeitig sitzen in Amerika Leute und kaufen das alles mit Geld, das sie einfach in ihren Brieffkasten vorfinden. Und das kann man aber noch ein paar Jahrzehnte so machen, weil die Amerikaner haben halt den Dollar, wenn die Geld brauchen, sagt der Kongress, okay und so.
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt.
Hätte man so eine völlig verarmute Arbeiterschaft in Deutschland, die ziemlich geiles Zeug wie alle anderen auf der Welt baut und dann am Ende von so einer Erwerbsbiografie nach 35, 40 Jahren feststellt, und jetzt noch 10 Jahre kleine Rente, und dann war es das mit meinem Leben, Scheiße. Überall auf der Welt hat die Leute dann mit den deutschen Sachen rumgespielt.
Obwohl das wahrscheinlich nur auf Amerika zutreffen wird, denn eher sieht es so aus, Spieker, skizziert ist, dass Deutschland natürlich alle Macht aufwenden wird, um weiter Exportweltmeister zu sein und zugleich aber das Ausland immer wieder zu mahnen, nicht so viele Schulden zu machen. Die 60 Milliarden, sagt Spieker jedenfalls, sei nur ein viel zu kleiner Schritt.
Und insofern sind zusätzliche 60 Milliarden kreditfinanzierte Staatsausgaben, ganz egal wie sie verbucht werden, aus ökonomischer Sicht ein richtiger Schritt, aber ein viel zu kleiner und vor allen Dingen ein vollkommen falsch begründeter Schritt. Die Begründung bereitet nämlich, so wie sie im Gesetzentwurf steht, automatisch vor, dass sich Deutschland auf die Schuldenbremse wird konzentrieren wollen, egal wie formal sie eingehalten werden sollen und damit auch auf die europäischen Fiskalregeln. Es wird der deutschen Regierung extrem schwer fallen, der Öffentlichkeit plausibel zu erklären, weshalb sie selber die Schuldenbremse einhalten will, die europäischen Partner das aber im Rahmen des europäischen Fiskalpaktes nicht schaffen werden.
Das gefällt mir auch bei Adam Toos immer wahnsinnig gut, wenn so die Frage kommt, und zwar ganz panisch, auf Deutsch vorgetragen. Ah, jetzt verschuldet sich auch noch die Europäische Union und die EU-Kommission. Und was machen wir dann? Und 750 Milliarden, das ist doch alles wahnsinnig viel Geld. Und dann Adam Toos so, 750 Milliarden, das ist viel zu wenig. Wenn man das immer wieder so hört, also sehr gut.
In der Tatsache ist ja auch immer dieser Ton da, dass man sobald irgendwas mit Schulden in Europa, also nicht in Deutschland ist, sagt man gleich, oh, was machen die da wieder? Wo verschwenden die wieder das Geld? Na ja, die kaufen halt unsere Produkte. Da hin fließt das Geld, das können wir ganz klar mal sagen. Und das ist auch immer so schön, wenn so im linksliberalen Spektrum es heißt, wir dürfen nicht so eurozentrisch sein. Ich würde sagen, wir sind ganz oft deutschzentrisch und sind nicht immer eurozentrisch. Eurozentrisch würde nämlich bedeuten, wir versetzen uns mal in die Lage eines Portugiesen oder eines Griechen und dann sieht das Ganze schon ganz, ganz anders aus. Und Spieger spricht hier über diese Überlegenheit und Doppelmoral von Deutschland.
Deutschland kann selbstverständlich mit seiner großen Wettbewerbsstärke durchsetzen, dass sich das Ausland erneut im dreistelligen Milliardenbereich bei uns verschuldet. Aber die deutsche Regierung kann dann die EU-Partner genau deswegen nicht kritisieren dafür, dass sie ihre Verschuldung steigern müssen.
Jetzt könnte dann aber ja die europäischen Länder sagen, wir sind trotzdem auch sparsam. Was wäre denn da noch möglich, fragt sich Spieger?
Die kann auch nicht verlangen, dass die EU-Partner sich genauso verhalten wie die Deutschen, nämlich dass sie selber so stark sparen. Dann müssten die EU-Partner nämlich auf eine große Verschuldung des außereuropäischen Auslandes setzen. Und dieses außereuropäische Ausland wird einen so großen Leistungsbilanzüberschuss der EU nicht akzeptieren. Der läge in einem Bereich über einer halben Billion Euro. Es ist völlig ausgeschlossen, dass das unsere außereuropäischen Handelspartner akzeptieren werden.
Wäre auch nicht zu managen, ehrlich gesagt. Soll jetzt Nordafrika oder Pakistan?
Da müsste man auf jeden Fall mit China und Russland ganz anders reden. Also ich weiß es nicht, wie das gehen sollte. Also klar, sie sagt, es ist ausgeschlossen. Also kann das auch nicht des Rätsels Lösung sein, dass man unser Problem, dass wir an die anderen Länder, die Nachbarländer abgeben und die Nachbarländer sagen, wir geben das mal nach ganz draußen und gucken, ob die das irgendwie so wollen. Nein, das geht natürlich nicht. Aber sie sagt auch, mit Deutschland rational verhandeln fällt dann schwer.
Aber das Problem, das ich hier grundsätzlich sehe, ganz unabhängig von der genauen Verwendung der staatlichen Mittel ist, dass Deutschland sein Sparproblem nicht auf dem Rücken des Auslands lösen darf, wenn es gleichzeitig dann das Ausland genau für seine Schuldensteigerung kritisiert. Damit macht sich Deutschland in Europa und in der Welt zu einem ganz unglaubwürdigen Partner, mit dem man nicht rational verhandeln kann.
So, wie ist nun der Knoten zu lösen? Es geht am Ende doch nur so, dass man die Schuldenbremse abschafft.
Die Lösung dieses Knotens besteht meiner Ansicht nach ganz klar darin, dass die Schuldenregel durch eine sinnvolle Regel ersetzt werden muss, die das Sparverhalten aller volkswirtschaftlichen Sektoren mitberücksichtigt. Das heißt, dass investive Staatsausgaben auf jeden Fall kreditfinanziert werden müssen. Professor Gröbel hat richtig gesagt, dass die Schuldenbremse jegliche gesamtwirtschaftliche Betrachtungsweise ausschließt. Und genau das ist das Problem. Deswegen ist die Schuldenbremse grundlegend falsch.
Aber sie wird uns noch lange erhalten bleiben, denn eine Mehrheit gibt es jetzt nicht. Und ob das dann in vier Jahren möglich ist, ich bleibe da sehr skeptisch. Aber das ist ein ganz, ganz großes Problem. Und da soll man sich auch nichts erzählen lassen von europäischer Einheit. Und wir sind alle wunderbare Freunde und so. Das ist dann mit der Schuldenbremse und bei dieser Doppelmoral, die davor herrschen muss, kaum möglich.
Also die Schuldenbremse steht ja im Grundgesetz. Man braucht also eine Zweidrittelmehrheit. Du hast gesagt, die Mehrheit gibt es nicht. Sind sich alle einig? Ich frage mich, wie weit der Spielraum des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes ist, den neuen politischen Wind aufzugreifen, um auch Regelungen, die im Grundgesetz selbst drin stehen, nochmal abzuwägen. Müssen die da rein? Widersprechen sie anderen? Gleichheitsgrundgesetz und so weiter. Also im Ende braucht es ja vielleicht gar keine Bundestagsmehrheit, sondern auch nur ein bisschen einen juristischen Kick. Klar, Stefan Habart und so, ob man das jetzt von dem erwarten kann, aber mal sehen.
Das ist mal ein guter Arbeitsauftrag an Juristen.
Man kann jedenfalls bei dieser ganzen Thematisierung wirklich sehr kurzen Prozess machen, wie zum Beispiel Sven-Christian Kindler von den Grünen im Bundestag als über Haushalt und Finanzen und so debattiert wurde. Denn warum macht sich die Ampel es überhaupt so schwer, erstens zu sagen, wir brauchen diese 60 Milliarden vom letzten Jahr in diesem Jahr? Haben wir gehört, Bundesrechnungshof ist da irgendwie in daher, er will das irgendwie so verbuchen in seiner Dokumentation, das Staatsausgaben, die man da so hat. Als zweites hat er dann die Ampel gesagt, wir müssen es auch noch nicht nur zeitlich umwidmen, sondern auch sachlich. Also wir müssen aus Pandemie-Hilfe Klima-Dings machen und so weiter. Da bin ich auch gefragt, ja, weil am Ende was im Verwendungszweck drin stehen muss oder so. Also warum denn eigentlich? Kann man nicht einfach sagen, das ist jetzt Haushaltsgeld, es wurde bewilligt, zack, es steht zur Verfügung. Ist ja alles eigentlich ziemlich kompliziert. Und in der Hinsicht hat hier Sven-Christian Kindler, der ja nun in jungen Jahren auch schon gestandener Politiker ist, so eine sehr lockere Zunge, um im Bundestag es einfach ganz kurz und bündig zu machen.
Der Professor Jens Südekum hat darauf hingewiesen, dass wir ein ökonomisches Long-Covid durch die Pandemie haben werden. Und gleichzeitig sehr deutlich in der anderen klar geworden, dass der Nachtbeschauste dabei hilft, diese ökonomischen Schäden auch abzufedern und zu beseitigen. Und wie wir dieses ökonomische Long-Covid bewältigen, das wollen wir mit öffentlichen Investitionen, öffentlichen Investitionen und privaten Investitionen sozusagen das Impfen der Wirtschafts- und Finanzpolitik. Deswegen sagen wir sehr klar, wir wollen Investitionsspritze für unsere Volkswirtschaft, um diese Pandemie ökonomisch nachhaltig auch zu überwinden.
Wir haben jetzt Long-Covid, wir brauchen eine Impfung und wir brauchen eine Impfspritze, eine Finanzspritze. Warum nicht? Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack. Und dann ist das Geld dann einfach mal rausgegeben. Wir verkoppeln jetzt noch, was eben nicht gelungen ist, die Makro- und die Mikro-Ebene. Indem wir einfach sagen, ja, wäre schon schön, wenn die Deutschen, die ja sehr viel herstellen, die deutschen Unternehmer dann auch sehr viel verkaufen könnten. Muss das immer alles im Ausland verkauft werden? Nein, wir haben doch auch hierzulande Bedarf. Leute sind doch wirklich arm. Und damit könnte man auch zwei fliegend mit einer Klappe schlagen. Ich fand das auch hier, das läuft auch unter dem Tenor lockere Zunge. Die Wiebke Schröder vom Paritätischen Wohlsprachsverband hat im Blätter Podcast, weil sie auch einen Text schrieb, zum Thema Hartz IV folgende Anmerkung gemacht.
Mit Wiebke Schröder spreche ich jetzt darüber. Sie ist Sozialwissenschaftlerin und Referentin für übergreifende Fachfragen und Zivilgesellschaft beim Paritätischen Gesamtverband. Guten Tag Frau Schröder.
Hallo Frau Enzlin.
Letzten Monat habe ich hier im Podcast mit Maike Rademacher gesprochen. Ich habe es eben schon gesagt. Frau Rademacher sagt, Hartz-IV-EmpfängerInnen das Geld zu erhöhen, das löse kaum die wirkliche Probleme. Sie sehen das ja jetzt anders. Inwiefern denn?
Ja, in der Tat. Armut ist ein wirkliches Problem. Und es ist auch ein entscheidendes Problem im Hartz-IV-System. Und gegen dieses Problem hilft Geld. Um das vielleicht auch konkret zu machen. Genau würden 229 Euro mehr im Monat dafür sorgen, dass der Hartz-IV-Regelsatz für einen alleinlebenden Erwachsenen überhaupt bedarfsgerecht würde. Das ist das Ergebnis einer aktuellen Berechnung der Paritätischen Forschungsstelle. Der Regelsatz müsste also von aktuell 449 Euro steigen auf 678 Euro im Monat.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Wer da irgendetwas anderes erzählt, das ist so wie Leute, die einem kein Honorar bezahlen wollen. Die sagen, wir können ihnen eine Umarmung schenken. Oder der Arbeitgeber sagt, mehr Geld ist jetzt nicht drin, aber ich kann sie mehr loben. Nein, Geld hilft.
Und dann vor allem auch, weil die Hartz IV-Betroffenen das ja ausgeben, auch diejenigen, die es dann einnehmen. Das ist auf jeden Fall noch viel zu hoch.
Es ist nicht so absurd, dass man das nicht mal erkennt, dass das volkswirtschaftlich sehr viel bringen würde, wenn Leute sich auch Produkte, die in Deutschland gefertigt werden, z.B. Jeanshosen neuerdings auch, C&A macht jetzt in Deutschland Jeanshosen, Boss hat wieder viel nach Deutschland zurückgeholt. Also wenn sie die Sachen auch noch kaufen würden, dann wüsste ich nicht, was dagegen spricht. Aus einer ganz volkswirtschaftlichen Logik heraus.
Genau. Und jetzt, wo wir schon so elementar beim Geld sind, Bert Rürup und Hüta, die haben wir nun wirklich, wir hören es ja immer wieder, ich habe es jetzt schon häufiger gespielt, hier nochmal abseits der etwas härteren Thematik China usw. Corona ist alles ganz schlimm. Die beiden reden auch nochmal über Schuldenbremse, Pipapo. Und die Frage, wie bezahlen wir jetzt den Klimawandel? Und sie haben eine ganz neue Argumentation. Wir müssen ganz genau zuhören, um zu verstehen, was sie sagen. Können aber daraus den Schluss ziehen, wir müssen uns jetzt verschulden, denn wir können ja die finanzielle Last des Klimawandels, der sich ja erst in 30 Jahren so weit auszahlt, nicht den Generationen aufbrummen, die bis dahin tot sind, also jetzt sozusagen abkassieren, sondern wir müssen jetzt in die Verschuldung gehen, damit diejenigen den Klimawandel bezahlen, also die Abwehr des Klimawandels der negativen Folgen, die dann auch was davon haben. Klingt total verdreht, aber ich glaube, die haben es genauso in ihrem Podcast gesagt. Sozusagen der Verschuldungsbefehl an die Regierung.
Ja, ein Kredit und dann ist die künfte Generation belastet. Ja, aber hier passiert etwas. Wir entlasten die und wir belasten die heutigen Generationen.
Ja, und damit haben wir natürlich dann sofort den massiven Konflikt zur Schuldenräume.
Dann haben wir ihn. Und ich meine, das wird...
Wurde, wurde bis lang auch noch nicht thematisiert. Also diese Fragen, die wir heute diskutieren. Die liegen auf dem Tisch, aber es sind in der Diskussion weiße Flecken.
Sie werden auch verdrängt, weil dann kommt sehr schnell der Eigenwert der Schuldenbremse. Und die hat aber keinen Eigenwert. Sie muss ja eingeordnet werden in ein ökonomisches, gesellschaftliches, politisches Bedingungsfeld und muss zielerfüllend sein oder ist es nicht. Und wenn wir solche Investitionsbedarfe haben, dann sollen wir mal einer erzählen, warum die von der gegenwärtigen Generation durch Steuerzahlungen finanziert werden soll, wenn sie davon kaum etwas hat. Und das ist etwas, was man doch in guten Gründen, gut organisiert über eine Verschuldungsfahrt beschreiben kann.
Man muss die Argumentation schon ein bisschen verschieben. Wir sagen ja auch, Investitionen kann man kreditfinanzieren, da auch die monetären Benefits in Höhe eines zukünftig höheren Wachstums auch in den Genuss vererbt wird an die jungen Generationen. Aber genau diesen Effekt haben wir hier nicht. Wir haben hier keine monetären Benefits. Wir haben hier keine höheren, besseren Wachstumsbedingungen, die wir vererben. Das haben wir nicht. Wir haben bessere Klimabedingungen, die wir haben. Aber die schlagen sich nicht in den Kategorien unserer Volkswirtschaft und in der Gesamtrechnung nieder.
Ich glaube, die sind einfach irre geworden.
Ich verstehe gar nicht mehr, wo die dran sind. Mein ganzer Kopf ist schon verfrungen.
Ja, also ich habe rausgehört, die jetzigen Generationen, die man jetzt belasten könnte, die jetzt reichen, die Boomer und so weiter, die haben das zwar alles verursacht, nur wenn wir die jetzt finanziell belasten, um ihren eigenen hervorgerufenen Schaden zu beseitigen, dann haben die davon ja gar nichts. Also belasten wir nur die mit der Beseitigung des Schadens, die davon auch was haben. Und das sind die jüngeren Generationen. Da die nichts haben, wir können denen nichts wegnehmen, müssen wir jetzt verschulden. Also für mich steckt hier so eine Verschuldungsimperatur.
Aber wir können, glaube ich, auch da auf so einer Meterebene gut erkennen, es ist jetzt auch am Ende egal, wie das jetzt mit welcher Generation, wie begründet wird. Denn am Ende ist es eine Spielerei mit der Bilanz. Und es gibt die Möglichkeiten, viele weisen noch mal darauf hin, gerade sehr, sehr günstig Schulden zu machen. Auch das wäre schon eine deshalb kluge Sache, das jetzt zu tun und nichts zu sagen. Vielleicht ist es ja in 20 Jahren viel, viel teurer, Schulden zu machen. Warten wir doch darauf. Also wie immer man das dreht und wendet, für welche Generation, was auch immer, es muss getan werden. Und alles, was tatsächlich getan werden kann, sagt ja etwa Keynso, kann man sich auch leisten. Und das sollte man jetzt mal erkennen.
Und damit schließen wir hier mit einem letzten Clip zum Thema noch so eine Klammer. Im Bundestag wird diskutiert und ich hätte auch gerne mal diesen Hüter mit diesem Argument im Bundestag gehört, wo einfach der Regierung sagt, er soll die halt mal bezahlen, später haben sie nicht. Na gut, dann verschuldet euch mal für die. Das gilt ja auch im kleinen Rahmen, dass wir ganz viel finanziellen Bedarf haben und auch ganz viel wissen eigentlich, wie es so um die Bedarfe steht und die Geldlagen, nur wir ziehen gar keine politische Schlüsse daraus, sondern plötzlich kann man alles im Bundestag behaupten, kann mit Bismarck vergleichen, um sich werfen, alles ist plötzlich gestattet. Und über diese Art des, wie soll man sagen, nicht-wissens-sondern-bewussten-nicht-wissens-nicht-anerkennens von ökonomischer Wahrheit, Tatsache und so weiter, hat der sehr große deutsche Philosoph Felix Lobrecht, vielleicht kennst du ihn, er war in der Sternstunde Philosophie zu Gast im Schweizer Fernsehen, wo er sonst, ich hab da nur so Harare und so immer sitzen sehen, aber Felix Lobrecht auch. Ich hab's nicht ganz bis zum Ende gehört, weil am Ende…
Es wird die Reichweite sein, oder? Gemischt ist das der erfolgreichste Podcast Deutschlands?
Sie wusste dann auch nicht mehr, was sie ihn noch fragen sollte, nachdem er ihr schon tausendmal gesagt hatte, ja, ich bin heute super reich, ich komm aber aus der Gosse und damit kann man auch gerne spielen, aber da hab ich gar keine Lust drauf, vielleicht blablabla. Diese eine Minute gönnen wir uns aber trotzdem, Felix Lobrecht, zum Thema Armut, Herkunft, soziale, finanzielle Situation in Deutschland und die mangelnde Anerkennung dessen.
Also wir leben ja in einer sehr wachen, also woken Zeit, wo sich sehr viel mit verschiedensten Diskriminierungsmechanismen und Dimensionen auseinandergesetzt wird, sehr laut im Internet und dann einfach diese evident wichtige und größte und best erforschte Diskriminierungsdimension, nämlich soziale im Sinne von ökonomischer Herkunft, einfach nicht Thema ist. Es ist mir wirklich unbegreiflich, warum das nicht in die Analyse mit aufgenommen wird. Also und es geht gar nicht darum, irgendwie anderen Diskriminierungsdimensionen irgendwas wegzunehmen. Ich denke mir nur, aber das ist auch wirklich auch wichtig. Also es gibt ja nichts, was besser erforscht ist aus diesem Gebiet, als dass Armut sich reproduziert und Armut mit schlechter Bildung zusammenhängt und so weiter. Also nichts determiniert dein Leben mehr als deine soziale Herkunft. Und ich verstehe nicht, warum das einfach so wenig Thema ist. Da gibt es so gute Studienzahlen, Fakten drüber. Das ist mir wirklich unklar.
Und er hat absolut recht und sie weiß auch nicht, muss ich jetzt über Armut reden? Ich bin doch hier in einer Philosophiesendung. Ich will doch eigentlich nur über die hohen Gedanken und so. Aber wir haben es ja eben schon gehört von Wiebke Schröder. Wenn irgendwer kommt und sich fragt, was machen wir denn jetzt gegen Armut? Das schleppen wir schon so lange mit uns mit. Ja, gib den Armen einfach Geld und dann ist das erledigt. Es ist wirklich verrückt, wie wir in Deutschland ökonomisch diskutieren. Wir hatten hier ein Thema im Dezember schon auf dem Zettel, das wir da nicht besprochen haben, aber jetzt besprechen werden. Es geht um etwas. Wir können uns von Friedemann Karich in seinem eigenen Podcast, Piraten-Sender Powerplay mit Samira, wie heißt sie mit dem Nachnamen? Richtig. Du bist mit ihr gut bekannt, ich ja mit beiden nicht. Deswegen kenne ich nur die Vornamen. Also Friedemann Karich spricht über ein Medienphänomen, das ihm untergekommen ist, das hier anekdotisch erzählt berichtet wird, allerdings doch schon, sagen wir mal so, eine größere Runde macht. Es wird auch eine etwas größere Rolle in Rentenrepublik spielen im Buch. Du hast es Antinatalismus genannt, vielleicht kein falscher Begriff.
Beziehungsweise es gibt antinatalistische Bewegungen. Und im neuen Michel-Buel-Bec-Roman ist das auch Thema. Insofern kam mir dieser Begriff dann noch mal wieder.
Genau, der passt auch. Man kann ihn ausbreiten, wie man will. Es gibt alle möglichen Formen. Eine der ganz modernen ist auch Regretting Motherhood. Man bereut es, je ein Kind geboren zu haben und so weiter und so fort.
Aber ist Regretting Motherhood nicht tatsächlich eher darauf bezogen, dass man es bereut, welche Anforderungen es dann mit sich bringt, ein Kind zu haben, oder dass man glaubt, der Mutterrolle nicht gewachsen zu sein, während man es beim Antinatalismus ja eher mit einer Theorie zu tun hat, die sagt, wir sind zu viele, oder der Mensch generell ist das Problem etc.
Genau, und da ist der erste Clip von Friedemann Karich gleich ganz gut, denn er überspannt diesen Bogen. Es gibt ein mediales Phänomen und zwei Sichtweisen darauf, je nachdem, wo es ihm begegnet. Entweder in Kürze bei Instagram oder wo auch immer, oder etwas länger dann doch auf der redaktionell aufgearbeiteten und betreuten Seite. Also wir hören uns das mal an.
Es ging ein kurzer Beitrag um vom RBB 24, in dem tauchten zwei junge Frauen auf, die beide sehr klimabewegt sind, ökologisch bewusst und sich auch engagieren in verschiedenster Form für Klimaschutz, um Leute abwacht zu rütteln und die beide gesagt haben, wir bekommen keine Kinder. Wir würden gerne Kinder bekommen, aber wir haben uns dagegen entschieden, weil wir möchten angesichts der ökologischen Situation keine Kinder bekommen. Und der Beitrag wäre nicht weiter wichtig, wenn er nicht eine generelle Strömung, einen Trend, eine Mode, eine Argumentation manifestieren würde, die uns beiden immer wieder in letzter Zeit entgegenkommt, die ich auch letzte Woche schon mal kurz angeschnitten habe, die wir sehr interessant finden im neutralen Sinne, die wir besprechen wollen. Und er war interessanterweise auch inhaltlich, was in dieser guten Minute war, es glaube ich sogar nur im Fernsehbeitrag passierte und auch in dem Text auf der Webseite, anders gespint, als der RBB ihn dann verkauft hat auf Social Media. Was mich gewundert hat, ehrlich gesagt. Was mir bisher auch noch keiner erklären konnte, warum. Weil diese zwei jungen Frauen in dem Beitrag, von ihren Zitaten her, die man sah und lesen konnte, rein vom Kindeswohl her argumentiert haben und gesagt haben, ich würde vielleicht gerne Kinder bekommen, ich möchte aber in diese Welt keine Kinder setzen, die müssen ja dann quasi gleich ums Überleben kämpfen, das ist zu riskant. Überschrieben bzw. verkauft wurde der Beitrag aber auch, dass sie das wegen der Übervervölkerung und des Klimawandels nicht tun wollen, die Kinder zu kriegen.
Ja, also irgendwo passt die emotionale Erklärung, die man immer so aus der Literatur und der Weltgeschichte Kinder haben, ist toll, das war ja nicht mehr ganz zusammen. Und die Spannbreite ist dann riesig von, ich bin der Herausforderung nicht gewachsen, ich kann meinem Kind gar nichts bieten, mein Kind leidet, weil ich es in die Welt gesetzt habe, oder die große Klimabewegung halt. Die einen da irgendwie hinbringt. Und wir haben ja vorhin schon demografische Probleme und so weiter besprochen, spielt also da irgendwie so eine Rolle, dass es auch so eine inhaltliche Schiene gibt. Dass es nicht einfach nur demografisch zu wenig Kinder, keine Ahnung, sondern es gibt ja auch Gründe dafür, warum es immer weniger Kinder gibt. Dieses interessante Paradox, umso mehr Sozialpolitik für Unterstützung des Kinderwunsches gemacht wird, desto weniger verfängt das irgendwie. Umso mehr fragt man sich dann, ist es nicht doch vernünftig, aus ökonomischen, klimatologischen, welchen Ausnummergründen, denn doch kein Kind zu kriegen. Na ja, das ist sozusagen so eine normale Podcastaufarbeitung. Es gibt halt dieses Thema, es liegt in der Luft. Also spricht man es an, wird dann natürlich auch ein bisschen besprochen. In einem anderen Podcast, den ich natürlich auch sehr gerne höre, methodisch Ihnen korrekt, reden sie eigentlich über Thanos oder Thanos oder wie auch immer.
Thanos aus Marvel, der die Hälfte der Bevölkerung auslöscht, um alle zu retten. Das ist seine Idee und davon wollen ihnen die Avengers abbringen.
Richtig, genau. Und der hat die Eigenart zu schnipsen und da stellt sich natürlich für alle die Frage, kann man mit einem Metallhandschuh wirklich so schnipsen?
Die Frage stellt sich nur für dich, lieber Stefan.
Für mich eigentlich auch nicht, aber dieser wissenschaftlichen Herausforderung stellen sich die beiden, Nikolas und Raini, in mincorrect. Während sie darüber sprechen, kommt ihnen aber auch das gleiche Phänomen unter, dass es ja so mitschwingt. Sie thematisieren es wie folgt und ja, da geht es dann auch ein bisschen lustiger zu im Podcast. Also man muss ja auch überlegen, während die gerade darüber sprechen, geht es um Marvel-Filme, um die Frage, wie viel Gleitgel kriege ich so auf meinen Finger, dass die Winkelbeschleunigung und es klingt auch alles, ich habe mich auf Twitter auch schon ein bisschen drüber lustig gemacht, dass das eine sehr sexuelle Ausgabe war, so insgesamt. Und unter anderem dabei dieser kleine Snippet.
Interessanterweise könnte man ja wirklich sagen, wahrscheinlich wäre es für die Erde gar nicht so schlecht, wenn die Hälfte weg ist. Also ich will jetzt nicht die Hälfte auslöschen natürlich, aber wir leben ja halt mal über unseren Verhältnissen. Ja, klar. Also wäre alles besser, wenn wir weniger wären insgesamt. Und jetzt einen Satz, den man aus dem Zusammenhang reißen kann, wenn man möchte und für irgendwas anderes benutzen könnte. Wenn die Hälfte aller Menschen tot wären, wäre das schon nicht übel. Hallo, Verfassungsschutz, wir haben ja eine Meldung. Also Menschen tun ja den Planeten wirklich nicht gut. Es gibt ja auch jede Menge Catoons mit Planeten, die sich treffen und die Erde mit so einem Fieberthermometer. Und was hast du? Ich habe Menschen. Ja, genau. Aber mal abgesehen davon, diese Szene ist unglaublich unrealistisch.
Weil das Schnipsen klappt gar nicht mit einem heißen Metallhandschuh. Dann gibt es ja noch ein Podcast, Wohlstand für alle. Wir kennen ihn alle, hören ihn gern. Ihr habt Ulbeck, Hulbeck, Hulbeck, Hulbeck, Hulbeck, Hulbeck, Hulbeck, Hulbeck, Hulbeck, der neue Roman, Vernichten. Man muss ihn gelesen haben. Richtig, du fandest ihn sehr gut. Dir war das alles zu kurz. Ole wollte den Podcast immer beenden, aber du wolltest unbedingt noch was sagen. Und dabei sagst du ja auch Folgendes. Ein bisschen so auch im Widerspruch zu der Lage, die wir ansonsten auch immer so hören.
Wir haben ja immer wieder so Diskurse, das ist alles so anthropozentrisch. Und ich würde aber sagen, naja, die ganze Klimabewegung kann immer nur sinnvoll sein, wenn sie auf den Mensch bezogen ist. Also ohne den Mensch brauchen wir keinen Naturschutz betreiben. Denn die Natur betreibt auch selbst keinen Naturschutz. Genau, es geht jetzt nicht darum, dass man irgendwie sagt, dieser Planet Erde ist ja ganz lustig. Das wäre eigentlich toll, wenn der so richtig ergrünen würde. Und das ginge am besten, wenn wir keine Menschen darauf haben. Denn dann muss ich sagen, wieso? Also für welches höhere Prinzip opfere ich mich da? Dass ich sage, gut, dann hat man halt einen Planeten mehr, der funktioniert oder nicht. Es ist ja dann auch vollkommen hirnrissig.
Genau.
Genauso wie mir ja auch relativ egal sein kann, wie es gerade auf dem Mars zugeht, solange da nicht Menschen leben, die unter irgendwelchen Bedingungen zu leiden haben. Und wir müssen Klimawandel immer vom Menschen her denken, was aber nicht bedeutet, dass wir den Menschen immer zum Absoluten erklären müssen und deswegen auch jedes Tierleid in Kauf nehmen müssen. Nein, auch das gehört dann zu unserer Verpflichtung dazu, als Menschen zu sagen, wir müssen Tierleid reduzieren. Denn es ist ja keineswegs so, wie manchmal auch behauptet wird, der Mensch ist ja eigentlich wie ein Tier. Nein, der Mensch ist entweder besser oder schlimmer als ein Tier. Ein Tier handelt nach Instinkten und in der Natur gibt es Fressen und Gefressen werden vollkommen unmoralisch. Einem Tierleid zuzufügen macht mich nicht auch zu einem Tier, sondern macht mich zu etwas unter einem Tierstehenden. Ein Leid zu verhindern für ein Tier macht mich zu einem Menschen, zu einem Wesen, das über dem Tier steht, weil ich moralische Entscheidungen treffen kann.
Genau, weil du deine Perspektive hinterfragen kannst, Rationalitäten gegeneinander abwägen und austauschen kannst. Das sind ja alles so Sachen, die dich von der instinkthaften, intuitiven Welt entheben und im Grunde Menschheit begründen. Es gibt ja verschiedene Herangehensweisen. Ich will gleich mal eine Extremhistorisierung vorschlagen, weil ich finde, man muss es extrem historisieren. Wir können aber auch es Hollywoodisieren. Wir stellen uns jetzt den Film vor, so eine Mischung aus Interstellar und Don't Look Up. Also die Menschheit guckt in den Weltraum und sieht plötzlich taucht hinter dem Mars irgendwie so ein Planet auf, wie die Erde tipptopp, grün, blau, alles leuchtet, die Sonne geht schön auf, genau die richtige Temperatur, perfekte Natur nach unseren Maßstäben. Wir haben aber nur die Möglichkeit, 10.000 Leute dahin zu fliegen. Wer darf jetzt fliegen? Wer will? Wer kann? Die Bedingung ist, wir schicken da nur Menschen hin, damit es sich lohnt, keine Technologie. Wer würde alle Technologien heute austauschen, um dafür in vollständig funktionierender Natur zu leben? Und zwar auch nur im kleinen Maßstab, nur 10.000 Leute. Da geht es auch so schnell nicht kaputt. Also so schnell kann man die zivilisierte Natur nicht aufbauen. Würde man das machen? Würde man unsere Welt heute, wie wir so leben, austauschen gegen, ja gut, dann gehe ich nackt in die perfekte Natur. Diese Abwägung, einfach könnte man ja auch mal durchspielen, wie in so einem Don't Look Up Szenario. Es ist entdeckt, es wäre möglich. Jetzt muss halt eine Liste an Namen geschrieben werden.
Also bei Namen brauchst du nicht auf die Liste schreiben, denn das möchte ich natürlich nicht. Ich bin ja verzerrtet und überzivilisiert und so weiter und möchte es auch gerne bleiben und finde das auch gar nicht schlimm und möchte auch nicht allzu viele Naturbegegnungen haben. Die schönste Naturbegegnung ist für mich, wenn ich die wunderbaren Naturgemälde im Städel sehe zum Beispiel, ja, da muss ich gar nicht rausgehen, sondern da ist eigentlich die Natur in Kunst gegossen, erst wirklich für mich als Natur genießbar. Insofern kann ich diese ganzen Naturfantasien nicht nachvollziehen. Ich kann aber den einen Aspekt, den Friedemann Karich angesprochen hat, nachvollziehen, dass Leute sagen, mit Blick auf den Klimawandel, mit Blick auf die künftigen Katastrophen, die uns drohen, habe ich kein gutes Gefühl, Kinder in die Welt zu setzen. Ich kann verstehen, dass man da nicht optimistisch ist. Andererseits können wir sagen, auch in sehr viel dunkleren Zeiten haben Menschen Kinder in die Welt gesetzt. Nicht nur, weil es unterlaufen ist oder weil sie mussten, sondern auch, weil sie wollten. Insofern kann man das ja auch vielleicht nochmal mit den vergangenen Jahrhunderten relativieren, dann diese Position und schauen, dass wir natürlich auch, wenn der Klimawandel extrem zusteigt, in einer sehr privilegierten Position sind. Was ich allerdings auch da sagen würde, ist, man muss natürlich das Kind hier ein bisschen mal mit den Neoliberalen auffassen. Also Gary Asbecker sagt ja, ein Kind ist ja eine Investition in die Zukunft und eine sehr heikle Investition, weil man weiß ja nicht, wie das Kind sich entwickelt. Vielleicht will das Kind gar nicht zur Schule gehen und macht weiß ich nicht welche Dinge, macht nur Ärger. Dann hat man sich da ein bisschen verspekuliert. Und das Kind als Konsumgut aufzufassen, halte ich für grundsätzlich falsch. Man kommt aber sehr schnell in diese Denkweise hinein, wenn man diese sagt, lohnt es sich und wem mutet man was zu. Da ist also Vorsicht geboten. Es gibt allerdings in der postmodernen Theorie, auch in der Queer-Theorie zum Beispiel, diese antinatalistische Strömung. Zum Beispiel Lee Edelman, der so ein Buch geschrieben hat über Queer-Theorie and the Death-Tribe, also the Death-Tribe, der Todes-Trieb, dass man so eine No-Future-Kultur haben möchte, und sagt, jetzt ist Schluss, jetzt machen wir mit dieser Reproduktion ein Ende. Aber ehrlich gesagt ist das alles mal als Gedankenexperiment ganz nett durchzuspielen. Aber da, wo es ernsthaft zu einer Ideologie wird, muss man sich wirklich fragen, wie menschenfeindlich will man eigentlich argumentieren, wenn man glaubt, Natur vor den Menschen retten zu müssen. Weil dann sind wir ganz schnell in ganz, ganz schwierigen ideologischen Gefilden. Und in der Regel ist da auch dann ein Rassismus immer implizit oder explizit vorhanden.
Ganz genau. Und deswegen, weil man über drei Ecken auf jeden Fall bei ganz grundlegenden Fragestellungen ankommt, wo es auch nicht mehr heißt, also machen wir es jetzt mal ganz rational und so weiter, muss man es hier als Menschheitsfrage auffassen und das auch wirklich extrem historisieren. Da bieten sich zwei Bücher an. Zum einen, und das sind zwei wirklich wichtige Bücher, die ich allerdings selber noch nie vollständig gelesen habe. Also so wichtig sind die. Es reicht, dass sie da sind, dass man weiß, warum es da geht. Man muss sie nicht komplett durchlesen. Ist auch im ersten Fall ein bisschen schwer, denn es sind fast 850 Seiten von Hermann Pazinger, die Kinder des Prometheus im Werbeklappentext steht. Hermann Pazinger, international renommierter Prähistoriker und Präsident der Stiftung preußischer Kulturbesitz, bietet erstmals ein weltgesellschaftliches Panorama der Frühzeit. Einen wahrhaft atemberaubenden Überblick von den Anfängen der Menschwerdung vor 5 Millionen Jahren bis zur Entstehung der frühen Hochkulturen vor wenigen Jahrtausenden. Also da kann man sich das ganze Panorama von – er kommt dann doch recht zügig auf 300.000 Jahre Menschheitsgeschichte zu sprechen. Also man muss jetzt nicht 5 Millionen Jahre irgendwie sich mit nichts befassen, aber so 300.000 Jahre Menschheit ist es schon. Da sieht man dann auch, dass wir jetzt gerade hier 8 Milliarden sind. Das ist wirklich viel und das ist auch außergewöhnlich. Das war vorher nie so. Noch vor drei Generationen war das völlig undenkbar. Und das ist eine Ausnahmesituation, unter der ist es gerechtfertigt. Und das ist eine Frage jetzt irgendwie mal so zuzulassen, gerade in so einem dann doch sehr humanen Rahmen, wie wir es jetzt bei Karich, Mincorrect und bei dir gehört haben, dass man nämlich immer mal so drauf hinweist, also ja, Natur ist schön und gut, aber es sind ja trotzdem zu viele Menschen. Also irgendwo dazwischen ist halt so eine Diskussionsmasse, die man mal thematisieren kann.
Aber diese Entwicklung wird ja rückläufig sein. Also da gibt es ja ganz klar ein Problem.
Ja genau, der Piep ist vorbei.
Also dieses Szenario der Überbevölkerung und bald werden wir dann 50 Milliarden und sonst was sein, das wird sich ja auf keinen Fall einstellen. Und das ist auch wieder eine Frage von wie entwickelt sich Wohlstand? Wie entwickelt sich Technik? Es ist ganz stark eine Frage der Emanzipation, selbstverständlich. Und von daher muss man da auch mit Malzes und diesen Überbevölkerungstheorien, mit dem ja auch noch der Club of Rome in den 70er Jahren gespielt hat, gar nicht mehr kommen. Ich glaube, das ist sehr oft jetzt so der Trick, auch vielerrechter zu sagen, wir wollen ja jetzt hier uns in Deutschland mal nicht zu sehr auf den Klimaschutz konzentrieren. Guckt mal, in anderen Ländern haben die Leute viel zu viele Kinder. Also damit kann man natürlich alles sehr gut externalisieren. Du hast jetzt gerade schon die Anfänge angesprochen. Ich würde nur sagen, wir gehen ja auch zu den Anfängen zurück. Vielleicht können wir das auch noch mal auf unsere Fragestellung dann im Salon verhandeln. Denn wir lesen ja von David Graeber Anfänge. Und da bin ich doch sehr gespannt, wie wir da noch mal ein anderes Verhältnis zu uns Menschen bekommen, wenn wir eine andere Menschheitsgeschichte entfaltet bekommen.
Es kann jeden Moment klingeln, dann ich habe mir Anfänge auch als echtes Buch bestellt. Also auch als echtes Buch. Es kommt also heute noch auch als echtes Buch. Und zwar immer ein bisschen in Griffweite. Gunnar Heinsson, das ist die zweite, das zweite neben Patsinger. Gunnar Heinsons Dissertation. Wir kennen ihn mit Otto Steiger, Eigentum, Zins und Geld, die Fragen oder Wunder der Wirtschaft und so weiter. Was hat es damit auf sich? Und er hat in seiner Dissertation über das Privateigentum, das Patriarchat und die Geldwirtschaft geschrieben. Und es ist im Grunde dieses Buch, das daran anschließt, okay, Menschheitsgeschichte, die Menschen sind jetzt da, stellen dann aber fest, ich bin ja hier gar nicht alleine. Ich begegne ja auch anderen, vielleicht sogar schon Fremden, die nicht sozusagen aus meiner Familie und so weiter. Man hat ja noch kein Konzept von Familien, wenn man gar keine Fremden kennt. Und dieses Buch, und deswegen, du hast eben schon von Emanzipation gesprochen, ja, das Patriarchat spielt hier noch vor der Geldwirtschaft eine Rolle. Wie kann das denn eigentlich sein? Das Privateigentum steht aber ganz oben. Also die zivilisatorische Menschheitsgeschichte, nicht die biologische, sondern die zivilisatorische, die ist ganz eng geknüpft, und da ist ja Heinz Sondern wirklich der Autor dafür. Privateigentum. Und übersetzt heißt das Verfügung Gewalt. Wer besitzt hier eigentlich was? Und wer darf da ein bisschen Partizipation üben, nach welchen Regeln? Dann haben wir den ganzen großen Marxismus, der ja auch noch relativ eng am Eigentumsbegriff hängt, wem gehören die Maschinen und so weiter, aber dann doch sehr viel mit Arbeit, weil einfach sehr viel Arbeit da und sehr wenig Eigentümer da waren, hat man natürlich, hat den Fokus aufs Arbeit gelegt. Aber eigentlich ist es ja diese Eigentumsfragen, die immer wieder geklärt werden. Und wenn man das beides, diese beiden Buchtitel jetzt mal nimmt und sich dann so Podcast-Erlebnisse, wie wir sie eben gehört haben, dann gewinnt ja die Fragestellung so einen neuen Wert. Dann fragt man sich ja nicht, also dann kommt man so aus dieser egozentrischen, also ich bin jetzt in der Welt, aber es ist zu wenig Natur für mich da. Also es muss irgendwer weichen. Irgendwer darf gar nicht erst geboren werden oder so. Es kommen dann immer ganz viele mit, wie handhaben wir es jetzt mit dem Recht, dass Frauen selbstbestimmen dürfen, ob sie jetzt Kinder haben oder nicht. Darf man ihnen das aufzwängen? Also wir sind ja auch wieder in so heiklen Situationen, dass wir auch in Deutschland gerade wieder Abtreibungen thematisieren und diskutieren. Weil selbst Rollwin Alexander, als ich dachte aufgeklärter Berliner Journalist, dann plötzlich da völlig querschießt und meint, nein, die Frau darf das nicht alleine. Und dann muss jeder mitbestimmen, das ist auch politisch.
Und das ist Werbung, wenn darauf hingewiesen wird.
Ja, sowas.
Das sind ja auch irrsinnige Debatten, die da geführt werden.
Und die eigentlichen Debatten, die man mal führen müsste, ist wie ist es jetzt eigentlich mit dem Patriarchat und der Emanzipation? Wer darf hier was? Wie gestalten Überfügungsgewalt aus? Geldwirtschaft, wozu eigentlich Geld? Also zur Vermittlung von sozialen Prozessen miteinander. Wer hat hier eigentlich zu viel und wer hat hier eigentlich zu wenig? Wer macht hier eigentlich für andere die Natur kaputt, sodass für andere oder für mich zu wenig Natur da ist und so weiter und so fort? Und da gibt es und ich sage es jetzt schon mal, um auch ein bisschen vorzubereiten. Inge Auerbacher hat die Rede zum Gedenken der Opfer des Holocausts oder des Nationalsozialismus, wie es formal heißt, im Bundestag gehalten. Daraus gucken wir gleich einen Ausschnitt. Aber weil das jetzt sozusagen, sie gibt eine Antwort auf, ich habe es miterlebt, als wirklich zivilisatorisch mal alles zusammenbrach. Und das haben wir ja eben schon gehört, da schrammen wir mit solchen Fragen immer ganz nah dran sozusagen. Wir hören aber vorher noch Harald Lesch, der in einem Vortrag in der TU Ilmenau vor Publikum, es war nämlich 2018, so einen Vortrag hält über, wir machen die Natur kaputt, wir sollten uns doch mal zusammenreißen, wir sollten mal irgendwas tun und so. Und dann sitzen natürlich auch so Studenten im Publikum, die sich der eine oder andere Frage stellen, wie zum Beispiel, sind es nicht einfach zu viele Menschen? Und wie Harald Lesch darauf reagiert, finde ich einfach überragend gut, weil die Situation gut gemeistert wird in dem Moment, ohne vor einer zu großen Fragestellung zurückzuweichen und so, ach, das ist zu groß und so.
Man sollte es nicht tabuisieren, so Fragen wollen wir uns nicht stellen, sondern man kann so Fragen auch anders beantworten.
Richtig, die Frage ist gestellt und damit kriegt sie jetzt auch eine Antwort. Und zwar so wie Harald Lesch meint, man darauf antworten muss.
Also ich hätte ja hier eine Lösung für alle Probleme, es wäre kollektiver Selbstmord, aber so weit muss es ja nicht unbedingt kommen. Ich sehe keine Folie zur Bevölkerungsexplosion. Das wundert mich etwas, weil das hat Malthus, ich weiß nicht, ob Sie ihn kennen, 18. Jahrhundert, dem war es schon zu voll auf diesem Planeten.
Wissen Sie, das ist so billig, das ist so billig, auf die anderen zu gucken und dann, in Europa gibt es keine Bevölkerungsexplosionen. Wir haben überhaupt kein Problem in Europa, überhaupt keins. Wenn Indien und China komplett in die USA auswandern würden, hätte dieses Land immer noch eine geringere Bevölkerungsdichte als Großbritannien. Sie reden über die anderen, das sind Ihnen zu viele, aber von uns gibt es zu viele, wir sind das Problem, nicht die anderen. Es sind 500 Millionen Europäer, die wahnsinnig viele Ressourcen verbauen. Ein Afrikaner mit zehn Kindern im Sudan lebt immer noch ökologischer als jemand, der in einer Lodge irgendwo im Grünwald lebt. Also ich muss wirklich sagen, ich habe das ja schon ein paar Mal überlebt, das ist ein ganz schlechter Punkt, weil es gibt nicht zu viele von den anderen, das ist nicht das Problem. Unser Lebensstil ist es, der diesen Planeten killt, nicht der Lebensstil der Afrikaner, der Südamerikaner und vieler Teile von Asien. Und ich höre das nicht zum ersten Mal, dass immer wieder darauf hingewiesen wird, wir wären zu viel, aber nur dann, wir sind nur dann zu viel, wenn die anderen so viel leben wollen wie wir. Dabei haben wir das Problem geschaffen. Die Europäer haben das Problem, zusammen mit den Amerikanern, die Japaner, Australien, wir haben das Problem geschaffen. Und momentan, aktuell, können sie mal nachgucken, wunderbares Buch übrigens auch, von den Kollegen Holler, wie der zweite heiß ist, mir jetzt entfallen, von der Fachhochschule in München, der Hochschule in München, die haben ein Wahnsinnsbuch geschrieben, Erneuerbare Energien ohne heiße Luft. Das ist ein tolles Buch und da gibt es darum, wie viel Verbrauch pro Person und pro Tag jeder Deutsche und jede Deutsche an Energie. Das sind 125 Kilowattstunden. Wir verheizen also jeder von uns 125 Kilowattstunden, alles was drin ist, alles. Das ist der gesamte Energieverbrauch der Deutschen, umgerechnet auf 80 Millionen und 365 Tage. 125 Kilowattstunden legen jeder von uns am Tagesende dahin. Die Chinesen machen 40 Kilowattstunden, die in der 20. Was glauben sie, wenn die unseren Lebensstil erreichen? Das war's, danke. Ja, genau. Aber wollen sie die, aber was, das heißt aber doch nichts anderes, als dass wir zunächst einmal runter müssen und dass die nicht da hoch dürfen. Das heißt, wir müssen den Technologien bereitstellen, die wir entwickeln müssen, um die entsprechende Emission zu verringern. Also, wo ist das Problem?
Die einfachste Technologie, es nennt sich Gummi, wäre jetzt mal ein Ansatz, der ist relativ günstig.
So, ja, das ist auch typisch, also ich finde auch diese Unbildung des Studenten in jeder Hinsicht erstaunlich, dass er also glaubt, erst mal Harald Lesch erklären zu müssen, wer Malzüß ist. Also, Malzüß, Sie haben das schon mal gehört, hat sich schon mal damit beschäftigt. Und er versteht auch das Argument noch bis zum Schluss nicht. Also, dass er immer noch sagt, ja, aber Verhütung, wo ganz deutlich ist, ja, aber wir sind es ja schon die ganze Zeit, also das ist es schon die ganze Zeit. Und das ist keine Frage der Verhütung mehr, sondern wir sind es schon die ganze Zeit und werden es auch jetzt vorerst so bleiben. Andere werden vielleicht noch ausschließen. Und wenn wir dann nicht entsprechende Technologien entwickelt haben, dann wird es halt noch düsterer aussehen. Aber es ist sehr, sehr erstaunlich.
Ja, also der Student argumentiert so ein bisschen vor dem Bundestag. Er wird zum Thema Corona Hilfe gefragt und gibt eine rein juristische Antwort. Ich habe mir so ein paar Strukturdaten angeschaut. Ach so, ich könnte auch mal mit Ökonomen reden. Warum machen wir das eigentlich alles? Warum haben wir eigentlich eine Wirtschaft und so weiter? Ja, und das wird hier einfach ausgeblendet. Denn wir reden ja nur über die negativen Folgen des Klimawandels, weil es einen menschengemachten Klimawandel gibt. Und die Menschen, die den Klimawandel gemacht haben, sind wir. Das sind nicht die noch nicht geborenen Afrikaner. Und in deren Sicht gibt es also auch auf der sachlichen Ebene ganz viele Argumente, Menschen, selbst ungeborene Menschen, nicht zur Disposition zu stellen. Statt sie irgendwie so reinzuholen und so eine Rechnung, so und so viele Menschen machen irgendwas, also muss das verhindert werden. Wo setzt man an der Ursache? Das ist dann der Mensch gar nicht erst geboren. Er ist dann schon für die anderen geholfen und so weiter. Weil damit sagt man ja auch wieder, und da schließt man wieder an, an die Beginne. Also wir sind hier bei Gunnar Hainsand 2000 Jahre vor der ersten Polis in Griechenland und so weiter. Also da, wo wirklich der erste Mal der Acker als funktioniert besonders gut, ich bleib mal hier, ich wandere nicht weiter, das ist jetzt meiner und so. Wir sind also immer durch die ganze Geschichte unserer Zivilisation an diesen Patriarchatsfragen, wem gehört hier was, wer darf über was bestimmen, Verfügungsgewalt. Alles ergibt sich daraus, ja, unser Privateigentum, die Geldwirtschaft, die patriarchale Hierarchie und so weiter und so fort. Das muss man dann, also das kann man alles zur Disposition stellen, kann man alles diskutieren, die Existenz des Menschen aber nicht. So und das ist natürlich jetzt im Januar ein ganz großes Thema und ich spiele es auch, weil ich es wirklich immer wieder gelungen finde, wie der Bundestag das da organisiert, welche Redner sie sich ranholen, wie diese Reden gestalten werden. Es ist jedes Jahr wieder sehr aufrüttelnd. Und ich will damit ausdrücklich sagen, lieber Raini, vor allem lieber Wolfgang, dich lieber Friedemann, dieser Clip, den wir jetzt gucken, der ist jetzt nicht sozusagen Widerspruch zu euch oder sowas.
Zu mir sowieso nicht. Ich habe ja gar nicht gedacht, wir müssen den Menschen immer in den Mittelpunkt stellen. Wenn wir das nicht tun, brauchen wir alles andere nicht zu machen.
Genau, wir sind jetzt aus dieser Extrem-Historisierung zurück in unserer Historisierung, in der wir uns Deutschland mal anschauen. Die Verantwortung, die da immer noch da ist, die im Bundestag jetzt nochmal thematisiert wurde, weil man sie eben auch nicht abschütteln kann, wo allerdings wirklich extreme Fragen behandelt wurden. Der Zivilisationsbruch hätte dann natürlich nur am 27. Jahrzehnt Thema sein sollen. Alice Weidel dachte sich, nein, ich baue das mit Thema Impfpflicht auch mal in meine Rede rein. Seitdem, glaube ich, wurde sie überall abgeschossen, also da sind alle Sympathien verloren gegangen. Wer jetzt noch sozusagen der AfD da anhängt, der hat sich da einfach klar positioniert. Inge Auerbacher beschließt ihre Rede mit so einem ganz großen Wir, die Menschheit. Wir unterscheiden jetzt mal gar nicht. Wir sagen jetzt erstmal die Menschheit, danach kann man ja immer noch über alles Mögliche diskutieren. Aber erstmal heißt es die Menschheit, so richtig im Singular und das war wirklich toll. Also hören wir jetzt fast drei Minuten das Ende ihrer Rede.
Summa Summarum. So viel ich weiß, bin ich das einzige Kind, das unter allen Deportationen aus Stuttgart zurückkehrte. Zwanzig Personen von unserer Familie sind von den Nazis ermordet worden. Drei Jahre im KZ Theresienstadt. Vier Jahre im Bett wegen der schweren gesundheitlichen Folgen. Acht Jahre Schulverlust. Vier Jahre Stigmatisierung der Judenstern zu tragen. Stigma wegen der bösen Krankheit, die Partner daran hinderte, mich zu heiraten. Ich durfte nie ein Brautkleid tragen. Ich werde nie Mama oder Oma werden. Aber ich bin glücklich. Ich schließe mit einem Herzenswunsch. Menschenhass ist etwas Schrecklicher. Wir sind alle als Brüder und Schwestern geboren. Entzünde heute eine Kerze zur Erinnerung an die ermordeten, unschuldigen Kinder, Frauen und Männer. Entzünde eine Kerze für das Leben und halte die Dunkelheit zurück. Sei Hüter deiner Schwestern und Brüder, dann wird dein Glück immer blühen. Wir sind alle als Kinder Gottes geboren. Für Einigkeit und Frieden öffnen sich die Tore. Die Vergangenheit darf nie vergessen werden. Zusammen wollen wir beten für Einigkeit auf Erden. Lasst uns gemeinsam einen neuen Morgen sehen. Dieser Traum soll nie, nie, nie wieder verloren gehen.
Sie steht also da und schließt am Ende ihre eigene Biografie, aber auch so ein bedeutender Teil Menschheitsgeschichte und sagt, alle Kinder der Welt sind meine. Damit begründet sie so eine Art Familienidee. Das ist ihr Herzenswunsch. Und wir wissen ja, wie es in Familien funktioniert. Privateigentum gibt es da nicht wirklich. Was auf dem Tisch steht, gehört allen. Geldwirtschaft braucht man nicht. Man redet einfach miteinander. Patriarchat, daran arbeitet man noch, dass man das ausgetrieben kriegt. Aber das, was sie als Schlussfolgerung aus dem Holocaust und als Wunsch, als Herzenswunsch äußert, ist sozusagen das Gegenteil der 4.000, 5.000 Jahre Zivilisationsgeschichte, die wir jetzt haben. Also es ist immer drin. Die Gefahr des Holocaustes ist einfach immer drin grundsätzlich. Und sie wünscht sich einfach, nee, kommt. Kinder sind geboren und damit gehören sie zur Familie. Wir sind eine Familie. Das ist mein Herzenswunsch. Vergesst zumindest diesen Wunsch, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist sehr gut. Und das ist wirklich die Schlussfolgerung, die aus der Geschichte zu ziehen ist, die sie hier zieht und die sie hier wunderbar universalisiert, ohne das Persönliche rauszulassen dabei. Also das ist ja auch wirklich rhetorisch meisterhaft gemacht. Und dem ist eigentlich nichts hinzuzufügen, auch zu der Gesamtthematik, würde ich sagen.
Genau, mal gucken, wie wir dann diesen Gedenktag ohne Opfer machen, die das noch so aus dieser persönlichen Perspektive kennen. Das wird natürlich eine echte Herausforderung. Aber hier werden ja auch Dokumente angelegt. Ob wir jetzt diese Rede 2022 oder 2042 spielen, ist dann am Ende auch egal. In Sicht mal wieder eine sehr gute Veranstaltung im Bundestag.
Ja, wir widmen uns etwas Leichtem. Und zwar haben wir ja schon über die Künath-Doku-Serie gesprochen. Wir haben schon über die Habeck-Doku auf der Meta-Meta-Ebene gesprochen. Feldenkirchen mit Habeck über das, was er dokumentarisch festgehalten hat und so weiter. Es scheint ein neues Genre zu sein im deutschen Fernsehen, dass wir jetzt immer Politiker-Dokus bekommen. So auch der SWR hat es produziert, die Gewählten heißt diese Doku-Serie. Vier Teile hat sie und begleitet junge Abgeordnete, Abgeordnete, die zum ersten Mal in den Bundestag einziehen. Und das Ganze spielt kurz vor der Wahl beziehungsweise nach der Wahl, nach der Wahl spielt es. Und zwar geht es jetzt darum, wie die Koalition sich bildet. Hat die CDU doch noch eine Chance? Also mit anderen Worten, was da jetzt als selbst wird, ist Wahlausgang bis Dezember hinein. Das, was wir also alle ohnehin sehr präsent haben. Wir müssen ja eigentlich nicht nochmal erklärt bekommen, es gab jetzt keine große Koalition oder auch keine Schwarz-Grüne, sondern wir wissen, es gibt die Ampel. Aber dennoch macht man das jetzt mal. Und ich habe mich gefragt, warum gibt es eigentlich dieses Genre, was ist daran so interessant? Und dann hörte ich eine Abmoderation in einem Podcast, da wurde auf die nächste Folge hingewiesen, womit man sich dann da beschäftigen will. Und dann bekam ich, nachdem ich lange siniert hatte, plötzlich da die Antwort geliefert, warum sieht man sich eigentlich solche Dokus zum Beispiel mit Politikern an?
Und uns mal wieder um unsere Lieblingsthemen kümmern. Vor allem die Parteien und die Späße, die sie sich selbst zumuten, was uns als Publikum und Zuschauer natürlich umso mehr freut, denn da geht es immer lustig zu. Also so ist es richtig.
Da geht es immer lustig zu, Stefan. Sagst du uns im Fernsehpodcast. Und ist das ein Grund, warum wir diese Doku immer gucken? Warum wir sowas uns ansehen? Also ist das wirklich der Unterhaltungsfaktor? Ist das jetzt die Alternative zum Dschungelcamp oder so?
Also früher war ja Crime. Irgendein Skandinavischer hat irgendwas gemacht und das wurde dann in den Drehbuch und dann hat man das Oma Erna vorgesetzt. Dann muss es ja True Crime werden. Früher hatte man ja Reich und Schön und das hat man dann nicht true Reich und Schön gemacht, sondern man hat dann einfach die Mächtigen genommen. Es mussten aber die echten Mächtigen sein. Also sind seit ungefähr einem Jahrzehnt die Nachrichten wie eine Daily Soap aufgebaut, aber mit Skin in the Game. Es sind die echten Mächtigen, die wir da sehen.
Und man hofft auch ein bisschen, immer diese House of Cards Qualität zu erreichen, was natürlich schwierig ist, wenn man sich im Berliner Politikbetrieb um tut. So ist es aber auch hier bei den Gewählten. Man möchte da jetzt schauen, passiert da was Neues und man ist, glaube ich, ganz gut beraten, wenn man mit dem Fazit der ersten Folge in dieses Phänomen einsteigt.
Nach meinen ersten Begegnungen zeichnet sich schon ab. Da drängt wirklich eine neue Generation an die Macht, die einiges anders machen und auch den Stil von Politik ändern will. Geordnete, ruhige Prozesse statt öffentlich ausgetragener Machtkämpfe.
Jo, auf Merkel folgen jetzt die ruhigen Prozesse in Hinterzonen.
Ja, wir haben natürlich auch festgestellt, dass es Gott sei Dank nicht so viel Pressefotos gab während der Koalitionsverhandlungen, nicht diese ganzen Balkonszenerien, die wir noch alle gut kennen von den letzten Verhandlungen und so weiter. Aber Miriam Davut-Wandi und Jan Kabelke sind jetzt auf den Spuren der Macht in Berlin unterwegs und treten aber auch selber als Hosts quasi in dieser Doku auf. Das haben wir auch schon mehrfach jetzt erlebt bei solchen Formaten und versuchen jetzt so ein bisschen da zu gucken, was tut sich da neu ist. Ist das ein neuer Politikstil, was auch immer. Wir werden zu der Desillusionierung, du hast sie jetzt schon vorweggenommen, quasi später noch kommen. Wir versuchen aber erst mal so ein bisschen so was mitzubekommen. Was erfahren wir denn eigentlich da? Es ist relativ wenig. Also ich habe kurze Clips und auch nur wenige aus vier Folgen. Einmal hier Lars Klingbeil erzählt noch mal, wie das unter Merkel war.
Ich weiß, das ist aus den letzten Koalitionsverhandlungen. Da waren ganz viele Nachtsitzungen und im Nachhinein, muss ich sagen, gab es mal so Phasen, wo Merkel einfach drei, vier Stunden zwar mit am Tisch saß, aber ganz wenig gesagt hat und ich glaube, die hat sich einfach komplett ausgegrüht in der Zeit und hat den Akku aufgetankt und wusste, irgendwann sind die anderen so platt und dann steigt sie wieder so nachts um drei ins Game ein und dann zieht sie alle anderen über den Tisch.
Wow, er hat Merkel durchschaut. Ich habe das ja auch gehört. Ich will nur ein kleines Clip.
Du hast es natürlich wieder nur gehört, nicht gesehen.
Ja, ich habe mir einmal kurz die... es ist ja eine Art von Stimmungsbildern, die da gemacht werden, so auf Schulterhöhe einfach mitgelaufen, wenn die Politiker da rumlaufen. Weil Klingbeier hier gerade zur Sprache, die Merkel früher, die hat ja alle in den Schlaf ausgesessen. Lars Klingbeier findet selber ziemlich cool, müde zu sein.
Also ich merke es auch gerade, ich merke echt, dass mir der Wahlkampf total in den Knochen hängt.
Also wer von Karsten Schneider ein Kasten Bier kriegt, weil er 100 Kilo gestemmt hat auf der Bank, kann jetzt nicht eine Stunde später im Podcast sitzen, ah, es ist so anstrengend und meine Stimme versagt auch schon.
Ja, es ist so ein großes Klang jetzt, ich glaube, das haben dann die älteren Generationen einfach auch natürlich auch am eigenen Leib erlebt. Also Merkel wird ja auch erschöpft gewesen sein, aber das hat man dann auch einfach mal ausgehalten. Aber heute muss man ja alles kommunizieren, also das musst du dir auch noch übrigens überlegen, wenn du dein Buch vermarktest, du musst also am besten kommen mit irgendeiner tragischen Geschichte von deinen Großeltern oder so. Das ist, es rennt nach Republik oder man kann ja heute wirklich kein Buch promoten, ohne auf seine eigenen Mental-Health-Probleme zu sprechen zu kommen. Das ist wirklich absurd und das ist jetzt auch hier dieser Modus, wir reden privat, wir sind auch dicht am Mikro dran und reden. Ja, ja, und Klingbeil, sag dann, welche Probleme damals bestanden beim Korrekturlesen unter dem Schlafentzug?
Also ganz am Ende hatte ich halt mal so eine Situation, wo ich glaube ich zwei Nächte fast durchgearbeitet habe und dann musste ich aber am Ende noch mit den anderen beiden Generalsekretärinnen und Generalsekretären den Koalitionsvertrag noch mal Korrektur lesen. Also wenn du dann irgendwie gefühlt echt zwei Nächte durchgemacht hast und dann sollst du irgendwie 120 Seiten Korrektur lesen, dann kannst du nicht mehr. Und da ist ja jeder Fehler, der da passiert, wirkt sich dann auf vier Jahre aus. Wenn irgendwie ein falsches Wort drin steht oder wenn irgendwie der Andi Scheuer damals als Generalsekretär, ein kleiner Trickser, wenn der dann irgendwie versucht, da noch was reinzuschreiben, was da gar nicht drinstehen sollte.
Also das kann man sich gut vorstellen, dass Andi Scheuer da noch mal mit was kommt.
Ich könnte mich täuschen. Gut, er hat jetzt hier von der letzten Koalitionsverhandlung berichtet, aber war das nicht bei allen als Vorzug deklariert worden, dass wir nicht so genau mitbekommen, gerade wie die das verhandeln? Klar, ein paar Journalisten haben gelitten, dass sie nichts reportiert bekommen, aber ansonsten haben das doch alle positiv gesehen. Und trotzdem stürzt man sich da so im Nachhinein drauf und, aber jetzt will ich es im Nachhinein noch mal wissen. Also irgendwas passt da nicht zusammen. Ich fand es weiterhin super hin, also super krass langweilig, die Doku war einfach richtig langweilig. Wer schon einmal mit einem wichtigen Typen in dessen Auto hinten mit durch Berlin gefahren ist, weiß, welche Stimmung in diesem Film die ganze Zeit transportiert werden soll für alle Zuhause gebliebenen, die in, was weiß ich, Augsburg leben und sonst nichts erleben. Die dürfen dann mal so quasi mit dabei sein, aber das ist einfach auch öde, muss man wirklich so sagen.
Es ist glaube ich auch einfach kein interessantes Leben. Ich würde da ganz klar sagen, wenn man da im Bundestag ist, dann mag es da interessante Dinge hin und wieder geben, aber diese Sachen, die dort beschrieben und gezeigt werden, sind einfach nicht interessant. Da werden auch Leute dann begleitet zu irgendwelchen Auftritten. Wir haben das ja auch damals bei Kühnert gesehen. Dann muss er halt irgendwo hin, um in einer Talkshow aufzutreten. Man könnte jetzt auch die Blackfurs oder die Höner filmen, wie die von Auftritt zu Auftritt gehen und sich zwischendurch eine Wurst reinhauen und dann sagen, wir haben so wenig geschlafen, aber Alkohol ist gerade tabu, damit wir die ganzen Auftritte noch bewältigen können. Das ist so dieser Modus. Das ist interessant, wenn man das mal sehen will, was Menschen da so machen, von denen man sonst immer nur was auf der Bühne sieht. Aber eigentlich ist das so ein Pseudoplick hinter die Kulissen. Denn das Eigentliche, was ja dann verhandelt wird, das kriegt man nicht mit, da ist man nicht dabei. Und so bleibt man doch immer im Vorzimmer sitzen und wartet, bis die gleich wieder rauskommen und sagen, ja, das war eigentlich ein ganz gutes Gespräch, aber wir müssen dann noch mal auf andere Weise zusammenkommen. Ich denke, ja, schön.
Es ist Johannes Vogel, der in dem Video, dem einen kurz sagt, ich nehme auch mal ein Carsharing-Auto und nicht nur den Fahrdienst des Bundestags, um ein bisschen am Leben teilzunehmen. Irgendwer macht so einen komischen Spruch, also absolut.
Ja, so ist man nah dran. Und was ja auch zu dieser neuen Form des Journalismus dazu gehört, ist, dass man auf der Metaebene dann als Host der Sache das auch nochmal für den Zuschauer mitreflektiert, was wir jetzt gerade gesehen haben. Wir verarbeiten also.
Das erste Mal, seit wir dieses Projekt gestartet haben. Wir wollen mal kurz unsere Eindrücke der letzten Tage abgleichen.
So, jetzt gleichen wir ja hier auch unsere Eindrücke manchmal ab. Wir schauen uns eine Bundestagsdebatte oder so an und dann sagen wir etwas dazu, ordnen es ein oder kritisieren es. Aber hier bleibt das jetzt wirklich auf dieser ganz menschenden Ebene. Wie fühlen sich denn alle gerade in Berlin-Mitte?
Wie war's? Wie hat er auf dich gewirkt?
Fertig, ehrlich gesagt, sehr, sehr statisch.
Er meinte heute zu mir, dass er eigentlich ins Büro kam, mit der Hoffnung, ein bisschen Mails abarbeiten zu können. Das muss man ja auch erstmal hoffen, dass man Mails abarbeiten darf. Genau, deshalb wirkte er schon sehr, sehr schäp von letzten Wochen, ehrlich gesagt. Und er meinte auch, wann war das? Wir waren zum Mittagszeit da. Er hatte auch noch nichts gegessen. Er meinte auch, so ja, irgendwie hat er sich das Essen fast schon abtrainiert. Dann war ich schon fast ein bisschen besorgt.
Oh man, das ist, wir haben es bei Habeck auch schon besprochen. Das sind Leute, deren Job besteht nur darin, in bequemen Stühlen zu sitzen, in wohlklimatisierten Räumen und zu reden. Die machen nichts anderes. Und die haben Personal. Die haben Sekretärin, die haben Fahrer, die haben alles, was sie brauchen. Dieses Rumleiden.
Und die können auch zur Not mal mit einem Snickerscoot über die Runden kommen. Das macht dann gar nichts. Ach, die haben genug Zeit zu essen. Die haben auch Zeit zu essen und ich würde jetzt auch mal sagen, Lars klingen wir jetzt nicht so aus, als würde er vom Fleisch fallen. Also das ist jetzt auch alles ein bisschen albern. Aber wir sehen eigentlich hier so eine, das macht mir mehr Sorge, so eine Journalisten-Generation, die total auf diese Narrative herein fällt. Und ganz auf dieses, oh, wie werden die sich jetzt gerade fühlen? Und da würde ich sagen, wenn das jetzt bald die politische Berichterstattung wird, dann macht man es den Politikern sehr einfach, irgendwelche Dinge zu machen, die unser Leben radikal verändern und die aber in gewisser Weise journalistisch dann nicht mehr aufbereitet werden, weil wir nur damit beschäftigt sind, zu sagen, oh, sieht der Robert gerade müde aus oder braucht vielleicht der Lars auch mal wieder mehr Schlaf?
Kommst du irgendwie klar seit der Wahl? Also du hast auch letztens in mir gepostet, glaube ich. Ich will Squid Game gucken, aber ich habe gar keine Zeit. Es guckt gerade, glaube ich, jeder außer dir wahrscheinlich trotzdem Squid Game.
Das ist auch sehr hart für mich, weil ich habe leider einen großen Fehler gemacht, was auch eigentlich ziemlich dumm war, so mit einer Folge anzufangen, wo ich auch hätte wissen können, man sollte keine Serie, wo alle erzählen, dass sie süchtig macht, anfangs der Zeit.
Ah, Ricarda Lang hat also angefangen, Squid Game zu gucken. Nach einer halben Stunde sind ja die Hälfte der Leute tot. Dann fragt sie, wieso geht das noch zehn Folgen? Das verstehe ich gar nicht. Ich habe doch gar keine Zeit, können die nicht einfach alle jetzt sterben?
Mit Katja Kipping geht man in eine Buchhandlung. Man denkt, was wird sie jetzt für ein Buch sich da aussuchen, um es zu verschenken? Und sie wählt dann Harry Potter. Habe ich auch gedacht, wer kauft dann im Jahr 2021 noch Harry Potter und kann das verschenken? Weil ich dachte einfach, dass das überall ist. Also das ist so wie, ich habe dir das neue Telefonbuch mitgebracht. Ach ja, toll. Also das fand ich auch sehr, sehr interessant, dass man auch aus solchen Momenten da nichts rausnimmt. Also dass auch die Politiker sich offenbar auch keine Mühe geben. Da was zu machen. Also ich hätte ja wenigstens noch ein bisschen was inszeniert und wäre da mit der Gesamtausgabe von Marx und Engels rausspaziert oder so. Aber nein, auch das gibt es dann nicht mal von Katja Kipping. Ja, was vielleicht noch ganz erhellend ist, wie funktioniert eigentlich Politik in Berlin sehr häufig? Na ja, man ist zum Beispiel auf Gabor Steingards Journalismus Schiff Pioneer zu Gast mit Jens Spahn und Johannes Vogel und macht da so eine launige Runde, die natürlich nicht zur Information da ist, sondern eigentlich nur, um zarte Bande zu knüpfen mit der Industrie in Deutschland. Und da ist dann eine Dame von einer Zementfabrik, die Chefin einer Zementfabrik, die jetzt Johannes Vogel schon mal ganz klar sagt, was sie erwartet von der Ampelkoalition.
Das ist für uns eben der Punkt, dass sie das mitnehmen, dass wir energieintensive Unternehmen, wir brauchen diese Ausnahme, sonst sind wir weg vom Fenster.
Aber ich kann einfach versprechen, I'm fully aware. Nee, jetzt den Punkt war ich jetzt noch zu Ende. Danach darfst du. Also uns ist das sehr bewusst. Also ich spreche jetzt für die Freien Demokraten. Können Sie absolut sicher sein, wir glauben alle, glaube ich, dass wir Klimaschutz als Innovations- und Wachstumsagenda angehen müssen. Und auf gar keinen Fall darfst du lassen, der Industrie Deutschland gehen, im Gegenteil.
Nee, und solange machen wir natürlich noch viele, viele Ausnahmen für euch. Und eher sehen wir mal zu, dass die Hartz-IV-Empfänger die Heizung ein bisschen runterdrehen, bevor da irgendein Zementhersteller noch Probleme bekommt in den nächsten zehn Jahren. Es ist einfach so absurd, diese Szene. Und da müsste eigentlich jetzt die journalistische Intervention kommen, wenn man schon Hosts hat, die auch in Erscheinung treten. Und das aber einfach nur einzufangen und stehen zu lassen und stattdessen sich um Schlafprobleme zu kümmern, ist absurd. Aber man merkt auch dann, wenn zum Beispiel diese Kommunikation mit Jan Kabelke stattfindet und Johannes Vogel, dass da auch jemand sitzt, der gar nicht richtig was entgegnen kann. Denn Rentnerrepublik Vogel macht hier mal ein ganz tolles Gedankenexperiment für den Journalisten auf.
Was glaubst du, wie lange kriegen die Rentner in unserem Land noch Geld?
Tipp mal.
Morgen würde nichts mehr reinfließen, wie lange kriegen die Rentner noch Geld?
Fünf Jahre?
Einen Monat.
Einen fucking Monat.
Das ist richtig auf Kante genäht.
Da wird nichts angesprochen. Unser Rentensystem ist eine Umlage. So heißt das.
Ich würde da einfach schon mal sagen, was ist das für eine interessante Rentenvorstellung? Offenbar glauben ja immer noch viele Leute, man hat so einen Rentenpot, der ist da, wie so das Sparbuch vom Kind, das man mit sieben Jahren mal angelegt hat. Und das ist jetzt hier für die nächsten 60 Jahre der Pot. Und da holen wir jetzt immer raus, die Millionen. Und wir wissen aber schon seit Jahrzehnten vom sogenannten Mackenroth-Theorem folgendes, ich zitiere hier mal Macken rum. Nun gilt der einfache und klare Satz, dass aller Sozialaufwand immer aus dem Volkseinkommen der laufenden Periode gedeckt werden muss. Es gibt gar keine andere Quelle und hat nie eine andere Quelle gegeben, aus der Sozialaufwand fließen könnte. Es gibt keine Ansammlung von Periode zu Periode, kein Sparen im privatwirtschaftlichen Sinne. Es gibt einfach gar nichts anderes als das laufende Volkseinkommen als Quelle für den Sozialaufwand. Kapitalansammlungsverfahren und Umlageverfahren sind also der Sache nah, gar nicht wesentlich verschieden. Volkswirtschaftlich gibt es immer nur ein Umlageverfahren. Und das ist notwendig auf Kante genäht.
Man kann natürlich auf ganz einfache Weise in solche Quizfragen reinstolpern, wenn man sagt fünf Jahre, ach so nur einen Monat, indem man einfach gar keine Ahnung von irgendwas hat und sich selbst über die Fragestellung des Politikers, und zwar nicht die konkrete Quizfrage, sondern Rente, sich schon wundert. Das kleine Ding, was wir jetzt hören, das werde ich vielleicht auch mal für Rentenaufblick irgendwie so ein bisschen transkribieren oder so, dass man das mal wirklich darstellt, in welcher Albanheit das ist. Der Journalist ist also auf dem Weg, wird von sich selbst begleitet. Er ist sozusagen im Selbstgespräch für uns, um dann auf Johannes Vogel und die Rente zu treffen.
Ich bin ein paar Tage später mit Johannes Vogel verabredet. Er ist mit Ende 30 schon das dritte Mal im Bundestag. Diesmal ist trotzdem alles anders für ihn, denn diesmal verhandelt er den Koalitionsvertrag mit. Und er hat sich dafür direkt einen ganz schönen Brocken vorgenommen. Er will das Rentensystem umbauen, Stichwort Aktienrente. Der Staat soll Geld langfristig am Kapitalmarkt investieren. Erstmal ein schräges Thema für einen jungen Politiker. Wie ist er darauf gekommen?
Erstmal ein schräges Thema für einen jungen Politiker. Wie ist er darauf gekommen?
Für einen fast 40 Jahre alten Mann ist das total schräge, mal über die Rente nachzudenken. Man könnte ja tatsächlich sich nur mit Sneakern beschäftigen.
Ich meine, wenn man... Also die Rente ist ein Umlagensystem, das wusste er ja nicht. Es war ihm ja völlig unklar, dass das so aus dem Cashflow heraus finanziert und geboren wird. Nur die Rente ist ja nicht nur der Betrag, den man später als Einnahme erhält, sondern es ist ja auch die Ausgabe, die man sein ganzes Berufsleben lang bezahlt. Und das wird sich Watt gar nicht dafür interessieren.
Auf die Steuer gucken und irgendwie denken, komisch, wofür gehen eigentlich immer diese Prozente da ab? Aus der Kirche bin ich doch ausgetreten, aber ich bekomme ja noch gar keine.
Da übrigens, und das wissen wirklich wenige, ich habe das jetzt erst über meinen Vater erfahren, man wird ja angehalten, länger freiwillig zu arbeiten. Die FDP hat das ja ganz klar drin, freiwilligen Regelungen länger zu arbeiten, als man für seinen vollständigen Rentenanspruch bis 65, 67 Jahre zu erarbeiten, kann man ja länger arbeiten. Ich habe mich immer gefragt, aber wie motiviert man die Leute länger zu arbeiten? Sie kriegen ja dann eine Rente. Einfach nur das Gehalt weiterzahlen, aber man bezahlt ja dann keinen Rentenbeitrag mehr, weil man hat ja schon jeden Rentenbeitrag. Man kriegt eine automatische Gehaltserhöhung von, und es ist ja nicht unerheblich 15, 10, 7, 8 Prozent oder was das dann auch jeweils ist. Also in der Ansicht, da gibt es tatsächlich noch ein bisschen Gesprächsraum, denn wir wissen ja, du hast es ja vorhin auch schon betont, die Arbeit ist ja nicht automatisch Ausbeutung, sondern die Arbeit ist ja häufig auch Umfeld der Kollegen, Gemeinsamkeit, Geselligkeit. Man muss ja nicht fünf Stunden dann durcharbeiten, sogar noch eine Drei-Tage-Woche oder sowas, da kann man sich ja durchaus arrangieren mit unter 70 und trotzdem ein tolles Leben führen und man hat gleichzeitig mehr Gehalt.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass das für viele Leute eine Option ist. Also es darf nicht so sein, dass das die Verpflichtung wird, weil das für viele Berufe auch überhaupt nicht geht. Aber ich glaube, dass es vielen Leuten sogar guttäte oder was ich auch beobachte, ist, dass Leute in Rente gehen, ein, zwei Jahre das auch machen. Dann ist alles renoviert, neu angestrichen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann sagt man, ach ja, guck mal, die suchen so Fahrer für zum Beispiel Transport von Senioren am Wochenende oder sonstige Dinge. Und dann fängt man dort an, nicht weil man jetzt sagt, gut, diese 400 Euro, die sind jetzt toll im Monat, ist auch nicht schlecht. Aber es ist oft auch, dass man noch mal in einem anderen Austausch stand, als wenn man nur zu Hause und in den Baumärkten unterwegs ist. Also das kann schon eine Option werden. Jetzt mal was zum Lachen, Stefan, du weißt, der Olaf Scholz ist ja eigentlich nur wegen einem so erfolgreich gewesen, nämlich wegen Lars Klingbeil und seinem unglaublichen Wahlkampf.
Ich war bei der Bundestagswahl als Wahlkampfmanager erfolgreich und das eröffnet jetzt gerade wahnsinnig viele Spielräume.
Ja, also sind nur fünf Sekunden, da steckt aber alles drin. Lars Klingbeil, ich habe das mit Mick ausführlich besprochen, weil wir es auch nicht ganz glauben konnten, aber Lars Klingbeil Münzt wirklich den ganzen SPD Erfolg auf sich. Und es sah ja wirklich mal so aus, als würde Olaf Scholz einfach zerrieben zwischen dem Feuerwerk von Markus Söder und der völlig, würde ich auch sagen, ein bisschen übertriebenen Begeisterungen für Robert Habeck, die zwei Männer auf der Bühne. Was soll der Olaf Scholz da im Hintergrund noch irgendwie? Wen interessiert der Beitrag von Olaf Scholz? Die beiden klären erst mal, wer hier Kanzler wird. Wir wissen, es ist nicht dazu gekommen. Und in der Art und Weise, wie Lars Klingbeil jetzt auch öffentlich nochmal seinen Triumph zur Schau stellt, macht mich auch ein bisschen traurig. Denn auch Olaf Scholz hat die nur installiert als, also der wird mir niemals gefährlich und muss gleichzeitig alles abfangen. Also es ist wirklich ganz betrüblich, das so zu sehen.
Aber es wäre schön, wenn man so ein Gemüt hatte. Ich habe mir vorgestellt, wie es so wäre, wenn ich so sage, toll, ich habe das hier gerettet nochmal. Also eigentlich großartig. Also man muss sich super fühlen. Man braucht glaube ich auch dann nicht mehr so viel Schlaf.
Das stimmt.
Tilman Kuban, auch ein junges Gesicht wäre übertrieben, aber auch ein Mensch, der noch nicht uralt ist, jetzt im Bundestag, würde auch begleitet.
Du hast mir gerade auf dem Weg erzählt, dass du hier ein Praktikum gemacht hast.
Wann war das?
Das war 2007.
Damals war man irgendwie so als kleiner Praktikant da oben auf der Tribüne und hat sozusagen runtergeguckt in den Ausschuss. Ja und jetzt sitzt man dann irgendwann selbst da.
Ich hasse diese Art des Journalismus so sehr. Da kennt man viele Beispiele mittlerweile. Wenn man weiß, das ist ein Politiker, der kann reden. Ich werf die nur so ein Stöckchen hin. Es reicht, wenn der plaudert. Der soll einfach nur plaudern. Die Kamera läuft. Nach drei Minuten mach ich's halt aus. Ich will eigentlich gar nichts von dem Wissen. Hauptsache, der plaudert. Wann hast du dein Praktikumier gemacht? 2007. Ich frag jetzt nichts nach. Du antwortest selber nach so eine Sekunde Stille und erzählst mir irgendwas.
Genau, er weiß dann schon, man hat da von oben nach unten geguckt und jetzt steht man selber da mitten in der Manege. Man ist schon dann dankbar, wenn so ein Realo auftritt. Also ich bin dann wirklich kein Fan von Omid Nouripour. Ich schon, kommt der hier aus Frankfurt? Ja, aber der ist natürlich in sozialen Fragen abzulehnen. Aber er dekonstruiert mit einem Handstreich das ganze Format und auch die Ausgangs- und Eingangsthese, indem er einfach mal erklärt, wie Politik geht.
Im Kern geht es hier um knallharte Machtkämpfe, egal in welcher Konstellation wir hier sitzen. Es kann sein, dass man sich nicht gegenseitig die Fresse poliert, wie es andere in anderen Zeiten gemacht haben, aber es wird in andere Wege gehen. Es geht immer um Verteidigungskämpfe.
So ist es. Das sollen noch mal die jungen Leute lernen. Das finde ich wirklich hervorragend, dass sie das auch dann drin gelassen haben, denn das ist dann einfach mal gegen dieses ganze Gefühliche. Und man will dann noch nicht mal das Politiker einfach sagen, nee, ich will jetzt mal gar nicht in diesem gefühligen Modus sprechen. Also Ricarda Lang sagt ja, dass ihr die Shitstorms jetzt nicht mehr viel ausmachen.
Du hast ja schon einige Shitstorms erlebt. Hast du denn Angst, dass dadurch noch mehr Fähigkeit zu kommen könnte?
Angst habe ich davor eigentlich nicht mehr. So schlimm wie diese Shitstorms waren, die ich erfahren habe, ich will das gar nicht kleinreden, hatte ich immer natürlich eine Rolle, wo ich ein großes Netzwerk an Solidarität hatte, eine große Öffentlichkeit. Ich finde, ich glaube, härter als auf das, was die Leute, die wirklich krass in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, ist das, was auf der kommunalen Ebene passiert, was bei Ehrenamtlichen passiert. Und das treibt mich gerade eigentlich mehr um als meine eigene Rolle.
Ob Ricarda wirklich so abgebrüht ist, dass ihr der ganze Hass im Internet nichts mehr anhaben kann?
Ja, warum kann man das nicht auch einfach mal stehen lassen? Und ich meine, wir haben jetzt ja auch die Rede vielleicht gesehen von Ricarda Lang, sie ist ja jetzt Vorsitzende der Grünen und hat sich beworben und hat dann gesagt, ja es gab da diesen ganzen Hass und darüber könnte ich jetzt unendlich reden, aber wir müssen jetzt einfach mal einen Schritt weiter gehen. Ich bin Ricarda Lang, 28 Jahre alt, ich sehe aus, wie ich aussehe und ich bewerbe mich hier für die Grünen, weil das auch gar keine Rolle spielt, wie ich aussehe. Und das nehme ich ihr absolut ab und dass man aber da gar nicht von loskommt dieses, können wir jetzt noch mal ein Therapiegespräch mit dir führen, wie das dir ergangen ist bei den Shitstorms und was macht das mit dir, Hass im Netz und all das.
Ja, das ist natürlich für Journalisten, die aus dieser Ecke kommen, wo man tausend Podcasts selber hat, in denen man immer noch mal jemand anderen zu Gast hat, nicht schwierig zu verstehen, dass man jetzt plötzlich einfach mit sehr mächtigen Menschen zu tun hat, die das nicht brauchen, die die Aufmerksamkeit eigentlich nicht brauchen. Und wenn sie sie nutzen, dann für sich zu nutzen, wissen, dieses Angebot haben sie ja nun hier alle angenommen, also alle sichtbaren Politiker haben dieses Angebot hervorragend gemeistert, sich hier sichtbar zu machen. Ich meine, Lars Klingbeier sitzt da echt und erzählt mir von seiner Müdigkeit in einem absolut vermeidbaren Termin, nämlich mit der Journalistin darüber zu reden, dass er müde ist, soll er sich halt ausschlafen und diesen Termin einfach canceln. Aber da kommt er ja in diesem Video nicht vor, das ist natürlich, ja und dann ist genau so war das hier gebaut, das ist echt schlimm.
Das war so ein bisschen auch wie bei Harald Wälzer, der dann sagte, ja zum Teil habe ich am Tag drei Vorträge gehalten, weil ich denke ja, warum machst du das denn auch? Muss man ja nicht, ist ja keine Normalität. Ja, diesen Clip habe ich jetzt eigentlich mal rausgenommen, nur um zu dokumentieren, wie eigentlich so die Mächtigen mit Corona umgehen und es ist vielleicht so ein Gruß an alle Eltern, die jetzt vielleicht heute gerade versuchen, diesen PCR-Test für ihr Kind zu bekommen.
Ja, also das ist der Clip. Ich kenne ihn ja jetzt glaube ich schon, nachdem wie du ihn bedanzt hast. Der ist für mich, denn ich erinnere mich noch mal alle daran, ich gehöre zu dieser großen Schar an Menschen in Deutschland, bei denen 9 Uhr aus heiterem Himmel das Telefon klingelt, das Kind ist dran, ich stehe vor der Schule, ich musste gerade raus, weil mein Antigen-Test Corona-positiv ist. Soll ich jetzt nach Hause kommen oder was soll ich jetzt eigentlich machen? Wenn solche Corona-Fälle woanders auftauchen, geht es so zu.
Wir hatten eine Situation, wo es einen positiven Corona-Fall gab und dann kam das RKI mit einer, das ist auch noch nie öffentlich geworden, mit einer Eingreiftruppe für Bioterrorismus ins Willy-Brandt-Haus mit vier Ärzteteams und die haben einen PCR-Test mit allen gemacht. 80 Alpha-Männchen und Alpha-Frauen, die alle irgendwie 500 Journalistenkontakte in ihren Handys haben. Ich hätte 500 Euro gewettet, dass das nicht länger als eine Stunde intern bleibt und es ist nichts öffentlich geworden.
Lars, das ist keine Story. Deine 80 Alpha-Männchen auf der Straße, die ohne den Fahrdienst benutzen zu dürfen oder ohne Nahverkehr zu Fuß zum PCR-Test latschen, ohne zu wissen, wo ist eigentlich der nächste PCR-Test.
Was?
In der Charité gibt es das gar nicht, da müssen wir bis runter nach was weiß ich wohin. Dann wäre es eine Story gewesen, aber so nicht. Da ist jemand zu uns gekommen und hat einen PCR-Test bei uns abgenommen. Ja toll, das wünschen wir uns für alle ehrlich gesagt. Das ist wirklich, das ist unglaublich.
Und einfach mal prophylaktisch, weil da irgendwo ein Fall war und dann haben wir gesagt, jetzt testen wir mal das Ganze Willy-Prandt-Haus durch, nicht dass da irgendwas sich ausbreitet, damit die Koalitionsverhandlungen gefährdet sind. Und das ist nochmal ganz klar, also Corona ist nicht irgendwie der große Gleichmacher. Wir haben das mal anfangs immer deutlich gemacht, aber hier kann man es nochmal sehen. Und deswegen wahrscheinlich auch diese sehr unterschiedliche Einschätzung. Man ist ja Leute zu Corona und dem Umgang damit und testen und ist ja alles ganz toll. Da muss man sagen, ja für wen und welche Privilegien genießt man dann, wenn man das so äußern kann. Wir schließen das ganze ab mit einer großen Frage, die uns dann in den nächsten Jahren begleiten wird oder die wir auch uns gleich beantworten können.
Ob es dem Neuen Mächtigen gelingt, wirklich einen anderen Politikstil zu etablieren? Ohne Intrigen und gegenseitiges Ausboten? Das wird sich noch zeigen.
Joe Biden ist jetzt ein Jahr Präsident. Die größte Herausforderung ist ihm aber noch nicht gelungen. Amerika ist gespalten wie eh und je.
Ja, es ist ganz fürchterlich, was da stattfindet. Also ist es reine Zeitverschwendung. Man guckt seine doppelte Geschwindigkeit oder du hörst es dann nur. Ja, natürlich wird jetzt nicht alles ganz anders werden. Und Politik wird immer mit Intrigen operieren. Und vor allem wird es immer um Macht gehen und das auszublenden oder zu glauben, dass das nur, weil man jetzt ein bisschen anders mit Journalisten umgeht, dass sich das ändern. Das ist ja sowas von naiv, dass ich es gar nicht fassen kann, dass das Erwachsenen Leuten unterläuft.
In der Mache ist ja bei denen weitere vier Ausgaben, denn sie sind ja angekommen in der Regierung. Jetzt regieren sie ja auch. Sie sind die, aus den gewählten werden ja die Regierenden. Und ich möchte hier, ich wünsche mir, also ich gucke das natürlich auch als, ich höre das natürlich dann auch als interessierter Mensch. Und ich habe aber eine Bitte. Mein Podcast-Player schafft dreifache Geschwindigkeit. Und er schafft auch mir die Pausen, wenn niemand was sagt, rauszuschneiden, automatisiert. Wenn aber in diesen Pausen irgendeine komische Musik läuft, weil das der Dramatik der Bilder irgendwie hilft, dann nützt mir das nichts, weil dann bleiben diese Pausen drin und ich höre diese Musik in dreifache Geschwindigkeit. Könnt ihr mir eine Version ohne diese Musik nur mit den O-Tönen schicken? Dann kann ich es noch schneller hören. Das fände ich dann auch gut. Wir sind ja hier im Podcast, der sich um was kümmert, also auch um eine der ganz großen Fragen. Und alle fragen sich Taxonomie, was? Ist das ein neues Spiel? Nein, die Taxonomie. Wir haben es als Begriff alle schon gehört. Keiner weiß, was es ist. Es ist ein bisschen so, man könnte das durchaus in vier mal eine halbe Stunde abhandeln, wenn man es nicht ganz so interessant finde, wie gut Lars geschlafen hat. Es ist nämlich so, es gibt ein neues Klassifikationsschema in Europa. Es gibt viele. Wir haben uns ja immer lange aufgeregt über die Butter, welches Maß, welches Gewicht, die Banane, welche Neigung und so. Und in diesem großen Kanons an Klassifikationssystemen kommt jetzt eine neue Taxonomie dazu und die betrifft die Nachhaltigkeit des Wirtschaftens allgemein. Es geht also bei der Taxonomie nicht nur um Finanzen und es geht auch nicht nur um den Finanzmarkt und nicht nur um Investitionen, sondern wir stellen uns jetzt einfach vor, ab sofort wird auf alles, was mit irgendwie Wirtschaft zu tun hat, so ein Aufkleber A bis F drauf geklebt, so wie das auf jeder Glühbirne und auf jedem Kühlschrank und so weiter ist. So wichtig ist dieses Ding. Es ist die Verordnung 2020 852 des Europäischen Parlaments und des Rats vom Juni 2020 und sie behandelt die Einrichtung eines Rahmens zur Erleichterung nachhaltiger Investitionen. Es geht also um, erstens, das ist neu, eine neue Einrichtung, Vorgaben für nachhaltige Investitionen und Wirtschaften. Die Offenlegungsverordnung wird dafür geändert, man muss nämlich jetzt darüber reden und es geht auch nicht nur ums Klima oder so, sondern allgemein um ökologische Nachhaltigkeit nach sechs großen Kriterien und wird das so ein bisschen aufgefächert, wie auch immer. Kennt man ja, da gibt es dann so ein Algorithmus, da läuft das alles durch und dann kommt am Ende die Note B raus oder sowas. Und es geht um alle, also Finanzmarktteilnehmer müssen ab sofort darüber aufklären, wie nachhaltig ihre Investitionstätigkeit ist, unabhängig davon, ob sie gerade das Ansinnen haben, aufgrund eigener Werbeüberlegungen irgendwas mit Klimaschutz zu machen, ja oder nein, sondern alle Produkte müssen das künftig, sowie auch alle über ihre Energieeffizienz aufklären. Alles, was auf dem Markt ist, muss gelabelt werden und Unternehmen, die nicht am Finanzmarkt tätig sind oder wie auch immer, auch nicht finanzielle Erklärungen, müssen künftig eine Auskunft darüber enthalten, wie nachhaltig denn die unternehmerische Tätigkeit ist. Also jedes Unternehmen, das irgendwo gelistet ist oder so, hat Bilanzierungspflichten und da gehört das nun rein. Das alles ist konkrete Gesetzgebung, es ist eine Verordnung, sie gilt in dem Moment, wo sie verabschiedet ist und dann im Amtsblatt veröffentlicht ist und der Ursprung liegt unter anderem in der UN-Generalversammlung 2015, da wurden schon die Millenniumsziele, Nachhaltigkeitsziele usw. behandelt und zum Thema nachhaltige Entwicklung einer Agenda 2030 beschlossen und Europa hat sich gedacht, das ist unsere Gesetzgebung zu diesem Thema. Es geht also um ganz schön viel, dafür, dass man zwar recht viel über die Taxonomie in Deutschland redet, aber immer nur Atomkraft, ja oder nein und so. Damit hat man das ganze Thema ganz schön sabotiert. Wir hören mal oder sagen wir so, wir haben das letzte Mal aufgehört hier im Dezember mit Olaf Scholz, der nochmal sagte, die Taxonomie ist eine ganz kleine Frage in einem ganz großen Problem. Und wir haben gesagt, ne Olaf, die Taxonomie ist ein ganz zentraler Pflok, der jetzt eingeschlagen wird und darum rankt sich einfach alles. Das darfst du nicht so marginalisieren. Stellt sich raus, Claudia Kemfert, pflichtet uns bei in ihrem Klimapodcast.
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hat ja deutlich gemacht, dass er nicht so richtig daran glaubt, dass dieses Taxonomieprinzip funktioniert. Aber Sie glauben da auf jeden Fall dran.
Ja, und ich hab den Satz jetzt auch nicht verstanden von Herrn Scholz, wie er das meint, dass das nicht funktioniert. Natürlich funktioniert es, die Investoren machen ja gerade diese Rahmenbedingungen, schnüren ihre Portfolios und schreiben da rein, was nachhaltig ist und was nicht nachhaltig ist. Und fossiles Erdgas ist auf Dauer nicht nachhaltig. Es werden ja jetzt Investitionen getätigt, das darf man ja nicht vergessen, beide Technologien, Atom- und fossiles Erdgas, wenn man jetzt Investitionen tätigt, werden diese Technologien über mehrere Jahrzehnte im Einsatz sein.
So, wir haben ja hier schon über den grünen Knopf gesprochen, als wir über das Lieferkettengesetz und so weiter. Es gibt schon ganz viel, sehr viel ist auch aus der Privatwirtschaft erwachsen, die Franzosen im Ereignislabel, Skandinavier sicherlich auch, alle möglichen privaten Blackrock, wir haben den Brief gelesen von Larry Fink vor zwei Jahren schon, wie er meinte ESG, also auch Environment ist eine maßgebliche Form. Genau, und dann ist dann einfach geregelt, wenn dein Unternehmen mehr als 25% Umsatz mit Kohleverstromung oder wenn mehr als 25% Umsatz mit Kohleverstromung zusammenhängt und so weiter, dann kriegst du dieses Label nicht, dann ziehen wir es aus unseren großen, wie heißen sie die ITFs, die Bündel, die den Markt bringen.
Genau, die ITFs und die anderen Franzos und es sind ja die professionellen Anleger, die am entscheidendsten sind bei der Börse, zwar gab es jetzt mit GameStop oder so mal bei so einer kleinen Aktie, kann sich da mal die Community zusammentun und irgendwas auswirken, aber wenn jetzt alle kleine Aktionäre in Deutschland sagen, wir investieren nicht mehr in die und die Industriezweige, dann wird man das vermutlich noch nicht mal abbilden können an der Börse, an Kursen abbilden können. Ganz anders sieht das aus, wenn Vanguard oder BlackRock und auch die Anleger, die staatlichen, sich entscheiden, nur noch ESG konform zu investieren. Wir müssen aber auch noch festhalten, gibt es auch noch andere Felder, auf denen Geld zu verdienen ist. Also welche Fonds funktionierten im vergangenen Jahr auch sehr, sehr gut? Atomkraft, Tabak, Öl und Waffen.
Genau.
Ja, also auch diese Zweige gibt es noch und auch da wird noch Geld verdient. Aber es gibt ein großes, großes Diskutieren darüber, was alles als ESG-konform eingestuft werden kann. Und ich würde auch sagen, es ist ein Hauptthema überhaupt beim Klimawandel und auch an den Finanzmärkten. Da geht es jetzt nicht nur um besonders nachhaltige Fonds, es gibt ja auch so Nachhaltigkeits-ETFs oder so. Aber was kommt generell noch in diese ESG-konforme Rahmenung rein? Und was fällt da raus und was bedeutet das dann? Das ist, ob im Handelsbatt oder in der Börsenzeitung, Tagesthema, jeden Tag.
Genau, wir haben ja in den letzten Jahren sehr viel über das Rating gesprochen. Bei der Griechenland-Krise, wenn die großen Agenturen das Rating runterziehen, dann wird es richtig teuer für die Länder und diesen Druck gilt es im Grunde zu erzeugen. Klar, private Labels und Initiativen, Schild und Gut, selbst von BlackRock, aber wenn die EU-Kommission per Taxonomie so ein Rating vergibt, dann bedeutet das doch irgendwas. Nun, der Druck wurde bislang nicht aufgebaut, das haben wir alle gesehen, wir sind auch wahnsinnig spät dran damit und leider ist es jetzt auch keine tolle Story, die man hier erzählen muss zu diesem Thema, aber die Entstehungsgeschichte ist trotzdem ganz interessant, denn es gibt noch große Verwerfungen, über die man hier auch reden muss. Fangen wir mal hier an. Politikpodcast 237 vom Deutschlandfunk. Man redet über das Thema, weil es in der Luft liegt, Taxonomie und kommt erst mal auf die Dramatik auf Seiten der EU-Kommission zu sprechen.
Es war Mitternacht, es war fast Mitternacht und nicht irgendeine Mitternacht. Es war die Nacht des Jahreswechsels in der Silvesternacht. Kurz vor 22 Uhr kam dieser Vorschlag in die Regierungshauptstätte der EU, verschickt von der EU-Kommission und ich will mal eine Hörerinnen-Mail hier kurz mal ansprechen. Es gab mehrere, aber Marlene, können wir hier prognostische Fähigkeiten bescheinigen, die uns schrieb nach dem vorletzten Podcast. Ich fand es nur schade, dass im Teil über Taxonomie nicht zur Sprache gekommen ist, dass es sich um einen Delegated Act der Kommission handelt und die Einspruchs- und Torpedierungsmöglichkeiten der Mitgliedsstaaten stark eingeschränkt sind. Und auch sagte sie, es wäre denkbar, dass die Kommission jetzt versucht, den negativen Backlash gegen den Act unter Weihnachten und Omikron zu begraben.
Ja, man hört schon die Journalisten dichten einer höheren hessierischen Fähigkeiten an, weil sie selber etwas ganz anders sehen, was sich dann doch als etwas anders herausgestellt hat. Erstens Delegated Act, was ist denn das eigentlich? Wir dachten, es gibt ja irgendwie dieses große, so entsteht ein Gesetz, auch in der Europäischen Union geht es nach Regeln zu, die wir irgendwie kennen. Offenbar nicht. Und zweite Anmerkung von der Frau, wollten die da irgendwas unter den Teppich kehren? Na zumindest das hat ja nicht ganz so gut geklappt, aber Peter Carpern stellt ja auch nochmal da, na im Grunde ist es auch egal.
Insbesondere in der deutschen Diskussion scheint mir das völlig unterzugehen. Da kommen wir vielleicht später noch drauf. Da wird ja jetzt gerade beraten, ob sich Deutschland denn bei der Abstimmung enthalten soll oder zustimmen oder ablehnen soll. Während ich ja eher der Meinung bin, sehr, sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich wird es überhaupt gar keine Abstimmung geben. Und das hat wiederum mit diesem Delegated Act zu tun, da kommen wir gleich noch drauf. Ja, diese Theorie der versteckten Entscheidung, die hat es hier gegeben über Weihnachten und Silvester. Jetzt haben wir heute den fünften Januar und wenn man sich die Medienlandschaft, insbesondere in Deutschland anschaut, muss man sagen, besonders erfolgreich war die EU-Kommission ja offensichtlich nicht, wenn sie versucht hat, dieses Thema heute den Teppich zu püren.
Weil wir in Deutschland haben sehr viel über die Taxonomie, ohne jemals zu verstehen, was es sich dabei handelt, gesprochen. In Frankreich allerdings, wir sind ja böse auf Frankreich gerade, weil die haben ja da die Atomkraft reingemogelt, da allerdings nicht so sehr.
Nein, es wurde wirklich an diesem Dokument gefeilt bis 21.53 Uhr war es genau, da hat jemand dann auf den Send-Button geklickt und dann ging die E-Mail raus.
Die Allermeisten konnten vermutlich am Neujahrstag, als sie davon herfuhr, mit dem Begriff Taxonomie nicht viel anfangen. Christiane, wie war das bei euch in Frankreich? Dieses Thema hatte in Deutschland einen gewissen Vorlauf, wenigstens unter uns Journalisten wussten wir, dass da was kommt. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, wir haben da irgendwie atemlos darauf gewartet, aber wie war das in Frankreich?
Also, dass da was kommt, das wusste man natürlich auch hier, aber ich finde das wirklich interessant, dass die deutsche und die französische Sicht auf dieses Thema so dermaßen unterschiedlich sind. Es hat so gut wie überhaupt kein Medienecho hier gegeben. Also, da musste man schon wirklich ein bisschen wühlen.
Ja, und vielleicht haben sie Franzosen wieder clever gemacht, wie damals in Stuttgart 21 es nicht gelang. Es sind ja schon vollendete Tatsachen. Die EU-Kommission kommt ja nicht mit unverhandelten Zeug an die Öffentlichkeit, sondern...
Na ja, hinzu kommt ja auch, dass so was wie Atomkraft in Deutschland viel klarer gesehen wird und zwar parteiübergreifend, dass man auf keinen Fall mehr Atomkraft will, während man in Frankreich ja ganz anders dazu eingestellt ist. In Wilbecks Roman, der ja im Jahr 2027 spielt, ist es so, dass der Wirtschaftsminister, wo immer er irgendwo im Ausland ist, so ein paar Atomkraftwerke mitbringt. Also das ist so ein Steckenpferd von ihm, dass er immer wieder irgendwo neue Atomkraftwerke errichten lässt. Und es gibt ja auch die Theorie, dass Macron und Draghi das Machtvakuum sehr gut auszunutzen wussten. Jetzt Merkel ist weg und sie war ja natürlich bei solchen Dingen immer ganz schwierig. Also da konnte man nicht mal gerade so an den Deutschen vorbei. Aber hier die Ampelkoalition war noch mit sich selbst beschäftigt. Merkel war weg. Da haben Draghi und Macron über kurze Bande gespielt und konnten so die EU maßgeblich beeinflussen in dieser Entscheidung.
Genau, denn Deutschland, klar wir haben eine Öffentlichkeit, die jetzt erregt ist. Ich bin auch ein bisschen durch den Wind. Atomkraft ist jetzt echt mal wieder so ein bisschen zurück und das ist echt nicht gut. Nur, bevor die Öffentlichkeit aufmerksam wurde, dass es so ist, weil die Europäische Kommission was Fertiges sozusagen der Öffentlichkeit kommuniziert hat, hat ja Deutschland da durchaus mitverhandelt und das gucken wir uns mal sozusagen chronologisch rückwärts an, denn erst mal kam die EU und meinte, ja das ist jetzt so und alles was hier in Deutschland an Aufregung stattfindet, ja gut, das ist halt deutsche Aufregung.
Der Delegierte Rechtsakt bedeutet, dass die EU-Kommission mutmaßlich am 18. Januar, wenn jetzt die Konsolidierungsphase mit den Mitgliedstaaten und den Experten vorbei ist, ihren endgültigen Entwurf auf den Tisch legt. Jedenfalls sieht so die Planung der Kommissionssitzung für den 18. Januar aus und danach haben die Mitgliedstaaten vier, maximal sechs Monate Zeit, um diese qualifizierte Mehrheit zustande zu bringen, um diese Regelung noch aufzuhalten.
Ich dachte, dass dieser Konsultationsprozess praktisch die letzte Phase ist. Da kommt also danach noch mal ein Spielraum?
Nein, diese Konsultationsphase läuft jetzt zwölf Tage lang, bis zum 12. Januar. Das ist die Phase, in der die Mitgliedstaaten und auch die Experten, insbesondere Finanzmarktexperten, die damit eingeschlossen sind, sagen können, wir hätten gerne noch dies geändert, wir hätten gerne noch das geändert. Dann wird die Kommission diese Änderungsvorschläge sich anschauen und am 18. Januar, so ist der Plan, die endgültige Taxonomie auf den Tisch legen. Und dann gibt es eben nicht ein Datum für eine Abstimmung in irgendeinem Ministerrat. Deswegen wundert mich die heute so mit Werf geführte Debatte in Deutschland darüber, ob sich Deutschland denn enthalten könne oder ob es nicht doch dagegen stimmen müsste. Und dann haben die Mitgliedstaaten vier, maximal aber sechs Monate Zeit, um diese qualifizierte Mehrheit zustande zu bringen. 20 Mitgliedstaaten, die 65 Prozent der EU Bevölkerung vertreten. Heute ist klar, dass es diese Mehrheit, diese Blockade-Mehrheit nicht geben wird.
So, es ist also im Grunde in trockenen Tüchern, was nicht bedeutet, dass die deutsche Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke nicht noch mal die Gelegenheit im Fernsehen nutzt, hier so ein bisschen mit rumzudampfen und Deutschland auch als das Opfer mit darzustellen.
Wie nachhaltig soll denn der Regierungschef der Neue Deutsche, Bundeskanzler Scholz, jetzt noch mal tätig werden? Oder ist das nur eine Protestnote, die sie jetzt nach Brüssel schicken, wohl wissend, dass das Ding durch ist?
Eine Stellungnahme der Bundesregierung ist keine Protestnote, sondern eine Stellungnahme, die aber in der Tat für die Kommission rechtlich nicht bindend ist. Das heißt, es ist ein Kommentar, den die Bundesregierung dazu abgibt. Wir haben es hier mit dem Sonderfall zu tun, dass die Kommission einen eigenen Rechtssetzungsakt vornimmt. Nicht das Parlament, nicht die Mitgliedstaaten, sondern die Kommission. Deshalb sind die Einflussmöglichkeiten darauf, von der rein juristischen, der rein formalen Art und Weise, nicht sehr groß. Umso wichtiger, finde ich, dass es eine klare, deutliche öffentliche Position gibt. Und da hat sich auch Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz klar gegen Atomkraft ausgesprochen. Im Übrigen auch FDP-Chef Lindner.
So, Steffi Lemke, von der ich ja viel halte, aber das hier war unterirdisch, steht also da und sagt, wir sind ein Opfer der Europäischen Kommission. Die macht nämlich einfach ein Delegated Act ohne uns, so die Behauptung. Und ja, Frankreich hat sich da durchgesetzt und wir konnten gar nicht mitreden. Und jetzt sind wir dieser Atomkraft ausgeliefert. Das ist ja wirklich super traurig. Ich trauere mit Ihnen, deutsches Volk. Während wir dann hören im Deutschlandfunk, nee, da gab es vorher schon so Kontakte zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich, wie man das mal so regelt. Es ist auch eine gescheiterte Kompromissfindung.
Und dann gab es einen weiteren EU-Gipfel im Dezember. Klaus, du wirst dich hier erinnern. Nachts die gemeinsame Pressekonferenz von Scholz und Macron, wo Emmanuel Macron kurz vor Weihnachten gesagt hat, wir werden einen, wir haben in den letzten Tagen miteinander über dieses Problem gesprochen und wir werden auch in den nächsten Tagen weiter gemeinsam darüber sprechen und wir werden einen guten deutsch-französischen Kompromiss finden. Dazu ist es dann allerdings nicht gekommen. Diese Kompromisssuche ist abgebrochen worden, etwa an den Weihnachtstagen. Genau kann ich das jetzt nicht terminieren im Kalender, aber Deutschland war nicht damit einverstanden, dass die Atomkraft da reinkommt. Frankreich war davon nicht runterzubringen und dann hat an einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt, ungefähr Ende der Weihnachtstage, die Kommission gesagt, wenn ihr sowieso nicht unter einen Hut zu bekommen seid, dann legen wir jetzt das vor, was wir für richtig halten.
So, wir können schon ungefähr erahnen, was jetzt an Geschichte folgt, die auch wirklich nicht ganz unbedeutend ist, denn dass man da erst zwei Stunden vor Mitternacht, Silvester, und da kotzen auch alle im Strahl an der Kommission, weil das ist auch für die eine ungewöhnliche Arbeitszeit, alle ran müssen, um irgendwelche Formulierungen zu machen, weil sich Deutschland und Frankreich, Deutschland wollte von Frankreich, dass Atomkraft gestrichen wird.
Aber Gas soll natürlich drin bleiben, weil Gas für uns ganz entscheidend ist.
Deutschland hat also hier Gas gegen Atomkraft und so weiter hin und her ausgespielt und musste dann mit den Folgen irgendwie leben und hat nicht gesagt, dann legen wir jetzt mal alle Aufmerksamkeit auf Atomkraften, regen uns ganz gemeinsam Schulterschluss, das Volk und die Regierung darüber auf, während wir gleichzeitig das Gas da drin haben. Wir reden aber erstmal über die Atomkraft im Einzelnen, denn das ist nun wirklich eine ganz große Tragödie, dass wir hier bei einer Regelung die eigentlichen Label, es geht ja nicht darum, irgendwas zu verbieten oder so was, irgendwas abzuschalten, sondern es geht ja nur, zukünftige Investitionen haben einen kleinen Vorteil, wenn sie nicht den Planeten zerstören. Und dieses Label soll jetzt auch auf Atomkraft mit draufgeklebt werden. Das ist also eine ganz große, wir haben es heute mit großen Worten, zivilisatorische Niederlage, die wir Europäer, die wenn wir wieder unser Schicksal der ganzen Welt aufbürden, hier einfach mal wieder ausspielen. Es ist unglaublich eigentlich, dass Patriarchat in diesem Sinne hat sich mal wieder durchgesetzt, die Verfügungsgewalt in Europa. Man war sich nicht einig, wie man es macht. Also macht man einfach beides, Atomkraft und Erdgas. Christiane Kess, die also im Deutschlandfunk aus Frankreich berichtet, betont hier nochmal die Bedeutung der Atomkraft in Frankreich.
Ich habe heute Morgen gehört, dass es durchaus nicht so ist, dass die Franzosen wie ein Mann oder eine Frau hinter der Atomkraft stehen, sondern dass das Land doch auch relativ gespalten ist. Mit einer knappen Mehrheit, glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, die hinter dieser riskanten Form von Energiegewinnung stehen. Aber wenn wir die Kosten anschauen und die Geschichte der vergangenen Jahrzehnte, wie kann es sein, dass der Ausbau so massiv vorangetrieben wurde?
Was diese starke Unterstützung der Atomkraft betrifft, die ist da. Ich glaube, die letzte Umfrage war 60 Prozent. Das finde ich schon viel. Da würde ich nicht unbedingt von einem gespaltenen Land sprechen, vor allem weil der Rest jetzt auch nicht unbedingt Atomkraftgegner sein müssen. Das ist das eine. Woher es kommt, es hat einfach eine lange Geschichte. Es geht ja wirklich auf Charles de Gaulle zurück, der aus dieser historischen Erfahrung von französischen Niederlagen und dem Verlust der Kolonien an diesem Mythos der Stärke und der Unabhängigkeit festhalten wollte und dann damit die Atomkraft auch belegt hat. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, dass Frankreich auch Atomwaffen hat, also nicht nur bei der zivilen Nutzung, auch bei der militärischen. Gibt es diesen Mythos der Unabhängigkeit, der jetzt in der aktuellen Debatte eigentlich nur durch den Linkspopulisten Jean-Luc Mélenchon in Frage gestellt wird, der darauf verweist, dass man so unabhängig da gar nicht ist? Denn immerhin braucht man für Atomkraft Uran und die muss man sich aus dem Niger holen. Die kommt ja schließlich nicht aus Frankreich.
Also in Frankreich ist Präsidentenwahl im Mai und alle Gegner, die für Macron besonders gefährlich werden, aus der rechten Richtung sind atomkraftbefürworter. Nicht unbedingt, weil die Mehrheit der Franzosen das toll findet, sondern weil es da so eine historisch traditionelle Verstrickung gibt, so wie wir einfach nicht von der katholischen Kirche lassen können, egal was da vor sich geht. Also in der Ansicht ist das hier ein ganz großes Problem, runtergedampft auf eine ganz kleine Ego-Schiene. Wer wird jetzt eigentlich nächster Präsident? Also das ist ja eigentlich schon ziemlich bekloppt.
Und dann mit diesem Souveränitätsgedanken, der natürlich für die Schalde-Gaulle-Tradition, die ja auch immer in Frankreich noch verankert ist, auch wenn sich jemand nicht mehr so offen dazu bekennen würde, aus dem Mittelspektrum, die aber dennoch da ist, ist das etwas, was man, glaube ich, nicht kleinreden sollte. Und dennoch gibt es ja noch bei der Atomkraft, und ich bin ja auch ganz klarer Gegner, diese neuerliche Entwicklung, das gerade von Silicon Valley Seite aus oder von Billy Gates aus gesagt wird, Atomkraft wird uns retten können. Das ist doch eigentlich die Technologie, die wir brauchen. Und es gab ja auch schon so einige Science-Fiction-Romane beziehungsweise Sachbücher, die sagten, so könnte dann ein klimaneutrales Wirtschaften aussehen, ganz auf Atomkraft gestützt. Man arbeitet, da gibt es ja auch dann große Reportagen, jetzt im Time-Magazin laufend zum Beispiel zu diesen Mininuklearwerken, die da gebaut werden. Also, dass man so Mini-Atomkraft-Werke baut, nicht ganz wie bei L'Oréal, wir bauen ein Atomkraftwerk, aber doch so, dass man also nicht mehr diese auf langfristige Planungen ausgelegten Meiler da hat, wo man sagt, gut, da braucht man jetzt 15, 20 Jahre, bis die überhaupt mal etabliert sind, dass man guckt, in kleineren Formen das herzustellen. Also, es gibt da so eine neue Erzählung des Fortschritts mit Atomkraft, die aber meines Erachtens das Hauptproblem, nämlich der Endlagerung, nicht zu lösen weiß. Zwar werden da Versprechungen gemacht, dass man vielleicht dann doch bald irgendwann auch Formen des Recyclings finden kann, von denen man jetzt noch nicht weiß, aber das scheint mir doch alles Zukunftsmusik und eher Investoren geschwätzt zu sein.
Also, es gibt neue Atomkraft-Dinger, mit denen kann man den alten Atom noch mal richtig verbrennen. Die erzeugen dabei keine zusätzliche Energie, sondern die verschaffen, also machen nur das Problem weg. Es ist nicht sehr hoffnungsstiftend, es ist sehr wohltuend, dass man bei Lanz zum Beispiel diesen jungen Hüpfern, die noch mal die Bewunderung für Silicon Valley und so weiter dann irgendwie erzählen, nee, Leute, das ist es. Ich höre mir das gerne an, aber ich bin auch müde, dagegen zu argumentieren. Aber das ist alles so ein Schwachsinn. Das kann man hier nicht ernsthaft versuchen, insbesondere nicht, wenn wir Windräder haben. Also, was ist denn bitte, wieso jetzt Atomkraftwerke? Nun gut, jetzt beginnt also dieses Theater-Spiel öffentlich. Das hier, was wir am 22. Januar gehört haben in den Tagesdämen, ist einfach nur Theater.
Die Bundesregierung hat den Vorschlag der EU-Kommission abgelehnt, Investitionen in Atomkraft als nachhaltig einzustufen. In einer Stellungnahme hieß es, Atomenergie sei nach wie vor risikoreich und teuer. Außerdem sei die Endlagerfrage nicht gelöst. Erdgas sei langfristig auch nicht nachhaltig, werde aber als Brückentechnologie für eine Übergangszeit gebraucht, um den schnellen Kohleausstieg zu ermöglichen.
Aha, hier wurde das Gas schon mal genannt. Da kann also Steffi Lemke noch so viel rumtönen. Eine Stellungnahme ist nicht nur eine Meinungsbekundung, sondern das ist eine geschlossene Erhaltung der Bundesregierung. Pipapo, das zählte alles nicht. Vorher wurde der Kaffee vergossen, jetzt ist nur noch mediale Nachbetrachtung. Was bedeutet, dass Robert Habeck im Fernsehen sitzt und sagt, es macht eigentlich alles keinen Sinn. Wir hören jetzt den Wirtschaftsminister, wir die ganze Taxonomie, über die wir hier reden, eigentlich in Frage stellen.
Dabei hat Olaf Scholz als ehemaliger Finanzminister diesen Kompromiss federführend mitverhandelt. Warum jetzt dieser scheinheilige Protest?
Scheinheilig ist das nicht. Es ist einfach meine feste Überzeugung, dass Atomkraft und Gas keine erneuerbaren Energien sind, keine nachhaltige grüne Energie sind. Hier geht es bei der Taxonomie um ein Label für die Finanzmärkte. Wir werden sehen, ob die Finanzmärkte das überhaupt annehmen. Sie müssen sich das so vorstellen, sie haben ein bisschen Geld über. Sie wollen das anlegen. Eine Bank, eine Versicherung sagt, du kannst das hier in diesem grünen Fond anlegen. Und dieser grüne Fond hat nukleare Energie bei sich. Willst du das machen? Dann können wir alle sagen nein. Ich bin also gar nicht so überzeugt davon, dass das Label nachhaltig für nukleare Energie den großen Erfolg bringt, den sich vielleicht die Franzosen davon erhoffen. Die Leute denken ja trotzdem noch mit.
Ja, die Leute denken ja mit und diese Taxonomie steht ja in Konkurrenz zu anderen Labels. Und am Ende geht es immer um Profite. Warum sollte man in etwas, das dieses Label trägt, wo es dann heißt, ja das fließt trotzdem alles in Atomstrom und Gas, macht ja keinen Sinn und ist bescheuert. Und besonders blöd ist eben, dass Robert Habeck als grüner Bundeswirtschaftsminister in seinem ersten Amtsmonat sozusagen jetzt plötzlich gegen Atomkraft wieder kämpfen muss. Und zwar weil Olaf Scholz nicht ordentlich verhandelt hat vorher und dieses Gas für Deutschland so wichtig ist.
Nur dann, wenn aber Milliarden private Investitionen, also von Unternehmen, tatsächlich auch richtig kanalisiert werden. Und zwar in Richtung auf grüne Zukunft kanalisiert werden. Da gibt die EU Richtlinien dafür vor. Die EU will jetzt allerdings auch die Atomkraft als grün einstufen. Das will eine große Mehrheit in Europa. Die steht da tatsächlich dahinter. Für Sie, Herr Habeck, nehme ich an, ist das der Gau. Haben Sie mal überlegt, ob nicht die anderen vielleicht in diesem Punkt dann doch recht haben angesichts dieser großen Klimakrise? So ein bisschen frei nach dem Motto der Autofahrer, der auf der falschen Seite fährt und der sagt wie? Eingeisterfahrer, Tausende.
Ja, das habe ich überlegt und bin zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass es falsch ist, auf die Atomkraft zu setzen. Ich kann das kurz deutlich machen. Wir haben in der letzten Zeit in Europa drei neue Atomkraftwerke, im Bau oder in der Zulassung, in Finnland, in Großbritannien und in Frankreich. Alle sind deutlich verspätet, bis zu zweistelligen Jahreszahlen, 10, 15 Jahre verspätet. Und die Kosten sind immens, bis zum Sechsfachen nach oben gegangen.
Ja, Stefan Rahmsdorf hat auf Twitter am 28. geschrieben, Kosten der Atomkraft laut französischem Rechnungshof müsste die Betreiberfirma EDF bis 2030 etwa 100 Milliarden Euro ausgeben, um die Laufzeit der bestehenden Meile um zehn Jahre zu verlängern. Das entspräche dem Dreifachen des Börsenwerts des EDF. Das ist also totaler Wahnsinn, dass wir hier allein aus Macron muss irgendwie die Rechte besänftigen und darf da jetzt nicht zu viel in den Wahlkampf verfeuern oder so, was da an Identitätspolitik zur Verfügung steht. Dass wir deswegen jetzt über Bande Olaf Scholz, wollte dann auch noch ein bisschen Gas, einen Bundeswirtschaftsminister haben, der plötzlich wieder gegen Atomkraft kämpfen muss. Es ist jedenfalls so, dass wir, und dagegen eine gute Aufklärung im Bundestag, Katharina Beck von den Grünen, selbst die Franzosen haben es ja eigentlich richtig gemacht.
Wir als Ampel möchten Deutschland bei Sustainable Finance zum führenden Standort machen. Lassen Sie uns diesen eigentlich sehr guten Marktmechanismus, Taxonomie retten und gemeinsam zum Erfolg machen. Selbst das französische staatliche Label Greenfin schließt Atomenergie aus. Also lassen Sie uns unseren Führungsanspruch nun Realität werden lassen.
Die Franzosen haben ein eigenes Label, das Atomkraft nicht einschließt. Und auf Europa soll plötzlich anderes gelten. Das wäre doch echt totaler Quatsch. Wozu dann überhaupt diese Art von Label?
Ich glaube auch, dass dieser Umschwung, selbst wenn er jetzt käme, einfach zu spät ist. Du hast es jetzt gerade skizziert, wie sehr das verschoben wird. Habeck hat das ja auch jetzt gerade gesagt, dass das sehr schwer alles mit der Planung ist. Und jetzt auch Leute, die sagen, wenn Deutschland jetzt wieder nur mal mehr auf Atomkraft wieder setzen könnte. Auch das ist jetzt mit Blick auf den Klimawandel, selbst wenn man mal diese ganzen Probleme, die damit verbunden sind, ausklammert, einfach sinnlos, weil man sagen würde, ja, da könnte man mal 2050 vielleicht das eine oder andere in Bewegung setzen. Das ist aber viel zu spät. Insofern können wir das gar nicht mehr als Thema hervorholen. Das ist ja sowas, was jetzt aber unter so jungen Journalisten, die jetzt so ein bisschen auf Ich bin nicht grün machen, so wie heißt die Jasmin M. Barek oder so, die dann auch so auf, wir müssen also, das ist ja auch so, das ist ja auch so, ich habe so ein ulkiges Interview mit der gelesen bei Turgi 2. Sie ist ja auch so, wir dürfen jetzt keine weiteren Schulden, wir dürfen unsere Probleme jetzt nicht vertagen, so wo man denkt, hat man jetzt schon ganz die CDU-Ideologie in sich aufgenommen in so jungen Jahren und dann auch noch mal so ein bisschen kokettieren, ich provoziere mal irgendwelche Gutmenschen, indem ich mich noch mal für Atomkraft ausspreche, weil ich dann als so wahnsinnig vernünftig und ökonomisch durchdacht komme und da würde ich sagen, nein, das ist überhaupt nicht der Fall, es ist einfach idiotisch damit jetzt noch mal anzukommen und es kommt auch viel zu spät und das alles andere mit den kleinen Kraftwerken und und und, das ist für Investoren bestimmt interessant und da werden noch mal ein paar Aktien ordentliche Flüge hinlegen, aber was da am Ende daraus wird, zeigt sich in 20 Jahren und auch da können wir sagen, es ist zu spät.
Ja, also für neue Atomkraftwerke gilt das alles, das wäre totaler Wahnsinn. Niemand würde jetzt von jetzt auf wegen Taxonomie oder was auch immer Vergünstigungen ein ganz neues Atomkraftwerk planen, denn man würde darauf verpflichtet, mit allen Folgekosten selber klarzukommen, man könnte sich nicht einfach wie früher einfach, ja der Staat wird es dann schon zu big to fail, der braucht ja das Atomkraftwerk. Nee, die 10 Milliarden, die man denn extra braucht, die müsste man dann schon selber absichern. Schlimmer noch, selbst die bestehenden Atomkraftwerke sind ja nicht wirklich betreibbar.
Und ich bin da heilfroh, dass Deutschland klar gegen Atom ist. Aus drei Gründen, die hier wohl noch einmal genannt werden müssen. Erstens, physische Unsicherheit, Tchernobyl, Fukushima, und selbst in Frankreich mussten im Dezember 2021 vier Reaktoren der modernsten Generation aus Sicherheitsgründen abgeschaltet werden.
So, Sicherheitsgründe. Es gibt noch einen Weg, Atomkraft profitabel zu machen, und das ist auf die Sicherheit zu pfeifen. Ist das eine gute Idee? Wir sind jetzt im Jahr 2022, seit mindestens zwei Jahren, müssen wir einfach sagen, es ist alles möglich. Die ganze Welt einmal in Lockdown schicken, weil irgendwas ist und so. Alles ist möglich. Wir können nichts mehr ausschließen. Entsprechend sitzt Johannes Hano, CDF-Korrespondent mit viel Erfahrung aus Japan, bei Markus Lanz und erzählt hier mal so ein bisschen, wie war das eigentlich mit Fukushima? Erstens, woran lag es? Und zweitens, was hat es bedeutet?
Japan wäre, er hat gesagt, wenn die Wolke nach Tokio reingezogen wäre, und wenn wir das gemacht hätten, was die Amerikaner uns gesagt haben, die mit ihrem Flugzeugträger vor Japan kreuzen, ihr braucht eine 80 Kilometer Sperrzone, dann wäre Japan nicht mehr existent als ökonomische Macht. Japan wäre in der Mitte gespalten gewesen, Tokio wäre entvölkert worden. Das waren reale Planspiele, die man in Japan hatte, die der japanische Premierminister uns bestätigt hat.
Das finde ich auch gut. Als du einen Termin beim japanischen Premierminister bis zur Journalist fragst, also sie hätten damals, wenn der Wind zufällig in die andere Richtung gewählt wäre, Tokyo entfölkert, hätte ich gemacht. Es ist unglaublich.
Und insofern gehe ich mal davon aus, dass das auch stimmt. Insofern glaube ich, dass wenn wir diese Technologie einführen, und in Japan ist es ja so, die Tor-Turm-Kraftwerke stehen in Gegenden, die relativ weit ab vorm Schuss sind, muss man sagen. Wenn man sich mal anguckt, wo stehen die zum Beispiel in Deutschland oder in Frankreich, wenn das da schief geht, rund um Hamburg, im Rheinland oder so, dann ist Schicht im Schacht, so einfach ist das. Wir haben nicht den Platz, den die Japaner da hatten, weil das 250 Kilometer von Tokio weg ist. Wenn das Fukushima in Hamburg passiert wäre, dann würden wir hier alle nicht mehr sitzen. Und dann wäre Deutschland am Ende. Das muss man sich ganz klar machen, ökonomisch am Ende. Und ich glaube, dass von daher, wie gesagt, ich habe das selbst miterlebt, welche katastrophalen Folgen das hat, wenn es schief läuft, dass man sie nicht kontrollieren kann. Technologisch wäre das wahrscheinlich alles kontrollieren gewesen. Der menschliche Faktor, den muss man mit einbeziehen, der war leider der schlimme Faktor bei der ganzen Sache, wie in Tschernobyl übrigens auch. Das kann man nicht ausschließen. Und diese Folgen, die Atomenergie mit sich bringen, das hat mich zum überzeugten Gegner gemacht, ganz ehrlich.
Ich will das auch gar nicht ausschließen, den menschlichen Faktor, denn wir schließen den jetzt auch nicht gerade aus und sehen, was das bedeutet. PCR-Test, wo sind Sie? Es liegt am menschlichen Faktor, es ist ja nicht irgendeine Naturgegebenheit, dass wir in Deutschland so wenig haben und dass alles so schleppend läuft. Und wir können uns vorstellen, wenn diese Trägheit, die hier schon für gewisse Krisen und Tragödien sorgt, bei so etwas erleben, dann können wir wirklich sagen, gute Nacht. Und ich weiß auch nicht, wie man immer noch darauf setzen kann. Und man musste auch wirklich mal diese jungen Journalisten, die sich so mit leichten Provokationen da, wie diese im Barick oder so hervortun, mal einfangen gehen, weil man ihnen einfach, wie das hier sehr schön gemacht wird, auch mal klar sagt, es ist ökonomisch wirklich absolut unsinnig, das zu machen. Man braucht hier gar nicht mit die arme Natur oder so ankommen, sondern man kann einfach sagen, es ist ökonomisch dumm.
Ja, wir haben ja vorhin schon kurz festgehalten, in Deutschland sind wir zwar revisionsbereit für die Entscheidung, die wir gestern trafen, aber uns mal hinzusetzen, langfristig einen Plan zu machen mit den Daten, die wir haben. Man kann ja durchaus mal simulieren, wie das so ist, wenn so ein Atomkraftwerk explodiert. Und dann sieht man ja, welche Grundstücke werden betroffen davon, nichts mehr wert zu sein, aber wirklich gar nichts mehr. Und wenn man dann irgendwie ermittelt durch so eine Modellierung, wo sind eigentlich die Modellierer bei diesen Fragen, dass zehn Prozent der deutschen Immobilien nichts mehr wert wären und damit auch zehn Prozent der Bevölkerung komplett rausgenommen wäre und auf zehn Prozent dieses Verlustes auch keine Ausgleichsbewegung volkswirtschaftlich möglich wäre, sondern dass Deutschland dann wirklich zurück im Mittelalter wäre. Heute heißt es immer, die SPD hat sich in Nuancen nicht klar zu Russland. Wir sind kein sicherer Anker mehr in Europa. Was wäre, wenn einfach zehn Prozent unserer Liegenschaften nichts wert wären und auch da alle Produktionsausfälle inbegriffen und so weiter. Das kann man sich da überhaupt gar nicht vorstellen.
Ja, wir können das mal hochrechnen. Man kann es eigentlich nicht hochrechnen, aber die Münchner Rück hat ja mal jetzt so grob überschlagen. Was hat denn das jetzt mit dem A-Tal da eigentlich gekostet? Ja, und dann kommt man auf solche Beträge und dann kann man sagen, das ist ja ein Klacks verglichen mit einem Super-GAU.
Richtig, also hier stehen einfach Billionen und Billionen in der Gefahr. Na ja, jetzt kann man zumindest einen kleinen Erfolg vermelden. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Und hat ja Frankreich im Zuge dieser Verhandlungen nicht das bekommen, was es ursprünglich mal wollte. Ich erinnere mich, ich erinnere nochmal an das Statement von Ursula von der Leyen im Oktober. Sie hat gesprochen von Erneuerbaren, von Gas als Brückentechnologie und von Atomkraft für die Grundlast. Da war kein zeitliches Limit drin. Da war nicht mit ausgesagt, dass Atomkraft etwas für einen Übergangszeitraum ist. Aber genau das ist es, was sich jetzt in der Taxonomie findet. Das heißt, da hat Frankreich jedenfalls Abstriche machen müssen, weil die Nutzung der Kernkraft jetzt unter den Taxonomie-Gesichtspunkten begrenzt ist.
So, begrenzt auf 2030. Du hast ja eben schon angemerkt, wenn man jetzt anfängt mit Bauen, ist man 2030 never damit fertig. Was ist das für eine Idee? Atomkraft, wo man weiß, das strahlt jahrtausende lang, als Brückentechnologie jetzt noch mal zu fördern. Das ist so durchgeknallt. Das ist Trump-Pest. Das kann aber nicht mit rechten Dingen zugehen. Das heißt, niemanden hier jetzt umdreht.
Klima, also das ist vielleicht ein Problem. Wir hatten das irgendwann mal im Salon auch mal irgendein Text angesprochen, den ich mitgebracht hatte, wenn man zu sehr nur über Klima redet und nicht im ganzen Umweltschutz sieht. Also wenn ich jetzt tatsächlich nur sage CO2, ja, CO2 wird wenig produziert bei Atomkraft. Das ist verschwindend gering, aber das heißt dann nicht, dass es gut ist für das Klima im Sinne von Umwelt. Denn wie du sagst, das bleibt dann halt so ein paar tausend Jahre.
Genau, das bleibt. Und damit haben wir es hier mit einer ganz schrecklichen Realität zu tun. Zum Glück, dankebarerweise haben wir Claudia Kämpfer, die beim MDR in ihrem eigenen Klimapodcast, ich glaube alle zwei Wochen oder so, immer mal ein bisschen drüber aufklärt. Und es ist drübsinnig, drübselig.
Jetzt hat die EU-Kommission vorgeschlagen, dass auch Gas- und Atomkraft als klimafreundlich gelten sollen. Sie haben gesagt, dass diese Liste an Investoren Signale senden soll. Muss man jetzt wirklich damit rechnen, dass in der EU ganz viele neue Atomkraftwerke und Gaskraftwerke entstehen?
Ja, leider. Und deswegen ist es eben auch falsch. Und diese EU-Entscheidung zur Taxonomie wirklich falsch ist, rückwärtsgewandt und nicht mit den Klimaschutzzielen zu vereinbaren. Und sie behindern ja auch noch den Umstieg hin zu einer Vollversorgung mit erneuerbaren Energien. Im Übrigen ist es auch im höchsten Maße juristisch angreifbar. Also die ersten Gutachten, die da schon kamen, zeigen, dass genau das eben, dass man das jetzt öffnet und sagt, man schafft eben hier Rahmenbedingungen und sagt, Atomenergie und auch Gas sind nachhaltige Technologien. Dass das eben tatsächlich diesen EU-Zielen, Klimazielen widerspricht und damit auch juristisch angreifbar ist.
Ja, wir haben ja schon gehört, das geht auf eine UN-Generalversammlung zurück und so weiter. Und es kann nicht das Resultat nach zehn Jahren oder was auch immer sein, dass wir jetzt wieder eine bevorzugte Förderung, es verbietet ja niemand, in sein Geld in Atomkraft zu stecken. Es geht ja um eine bevorzugte Förderung, die sozusagen staatlich abgesehen ist. Das zu machen, das ist einfach dumm. Gut, also was ist nun die deutsche Rolle? Peter Kaperne klärt uns hier ein bisschen auf. Wir sind wirklich alle mit Schuld und man muss es sich nochmal vergegenwärtigen. Dieses erste, allererste Green Finance Label, was damals Peter Altmaier für Deutschland, das ging um zwei Prozent Zusatzrendite, die der Staat garantiert. Also man hat eh Profit durch die Investition, der Staat liegt aber nochmal zwei Prozent drauf. Wir haben es also jetzt hier ungefähr auch in diesem Rahmen damit zu tun, dass sich das Label vielleicht mit zwei Prozent zusätzlichen Profiten am Ende für diejenigen, die ihr Geld reinstecken. Es geht um nicht viel, zwei Prozent. Was haben wir alles dafür geopfert und wie schuldig hat sich Deutschland da auch gemacht? Hier Peter Carpern macht mal den Aufschlag.
Wenn Atomkraft, die zum Gründungsmythos der Grünen gehört, deren Ablehnung zum Gründungsmythos der Grünen gehört, so wie der Ausbau der Atomenergie zur DNA-Frankreichs gehört, sich jetzt eschauffieren darüber, dass diese so viele, jahrzehntelang bekämpfte Energieproduktionsform plötzlich ein grünes Siegel bekommen soll, das kann man verstehen, die Aufregung darum. Andererseits werde ich auch den Verdacht nicht los, dass die Grünen ganz besonders laut Atomatom schreien, damit möglichst wenig im Moment über das Thema Gas gesprochen wird. Oder genauer gesagt darüber gesprochen wird, dass die Grünen seit gerade einmal fünf Wochen Teil einer Regierung sind, die den zweifellos klimaschädlichen Energieträger Gas auch mit einem grünen Label versehen will. Insofern hat dieses Atomgeschrei in Deutschland meines Erachtens auch die Funktion eines Ablenkungsmanövers.
Das ist natürlich im Deutschlandfunk sehr vorsichtig, könnte sein, dass es eine Art Ablenkung gibt, die sich in Deutschland mit der Angelegenheit der Atomkraft nicht mehr verändern kann.
Ich glaube, das ist ein ganz besonderer Punkt. Also das hat damit zu tun, wie man Investments macht. Und die deutsche Position war gar nicht primär, lass uns die Atomkraft da raushalten, sondern die war primär, lass uns bitte das Gas da auch noch reinkriegen.
Ja, Olaf Scholz hat sein Gas da reingekriegt, weil ihm ansonsten seine Kanzlerschaft so ein bisschen um die Ohren geflogen wäre. Er hätte nämlich dann wirklich mal klären müssen, wie machen wir das jetzt eigentlich? Zum Beispiel, genau. Also ganz wichtig, diese Nord Stream 2, wo sie ja völlig Banane ist und gegen jeden Zeitgeist irgendwie Lobbyismus jetzt betreibt. Alle glauben immer, der Schröder ist der Lobbyist, aber es ist Manuela Schwesig eigentlich, die da irgendwie, also das ist ganz verrückt. Robert Habeck muss es jetzt ausbaden. Er hat ja seinen eigenen Klimaplan jetzt vorgestellt, der auch mit Taxonomie, aber nicht primär, sondern das ist so sein großer, so stelle ich mir Deutschland vor, vor allem Windkraftausbau. Gleichzeitig weiß er, es liegt Ärger in der Luft. Also arrangierte das jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen, dass ja, da findet Protest statt, aber lasst es mal bitte Atomprotest sein, weil da kann ich mich einfach anschließen.
Vor der Tür gibt es die nächsten Proteste. Brüssel will, dass mehr Anleger Geld in die Energiewende investieren, will aber dafür auch Atom- und Gasenergieessen nachhaltig kennzeichnen. Habeck solle das ablehnen, fordern sie, tut er.
Gas und nukleare Energie hätte es nicht gebraucht.
Nur warum lehnt der Minister das Label Grün auch für deutsche Gaskraftwerke ab? Das Geld der Investoren dafür könne man doch brauchen, sagt die Opposition.
Wir können nicht aus der Kohle aussteigen, aus der Kernenergie aussteigen. Und so wie sich der eine oder andere Grüne das vorstellt, dann auch sofort aus dem Gas, aus der Gasverbrennung aussteigen. Das wird nicht gehen, so wünschenswert das auch ist. Und insofern also herzlich willkommen in der Realität der Energiewende.
Diese CDU ist nicht mehr zu vertragen, aber sie ist immer noch so ein bisschen da, der Zombie. Jedenfalls ist das mit dem Gas in Deutschland wirklich schwierig, denn auch ehemalige oder noch aktive Grüne sitzen da und sagen, wir brauchen Gas, wir brauchen Gas. Und das Zugeständnis an die Atomkraft und die Franzosen ist da dann immer mit einbegriffen.
Es gibt wesentliche Stimmen in der Grünen Partei, die meinen, man solle den EU-Vorschlag auch wegen der schmutzigen Gasindustrie ablehnen. Man soll ehrlich sein, sagt Kerstin Andreea, auch Mitglied der Grünen, von Beruf Energielobbyistin. Wenn man in Deutschland Klimaneutralität erreichen wolle, brauche man Gas.
Wir haben uns gegen die Kernenergie entschieden und wir haben uns gegen die Kohleverstromung perspektivisch entschieden. Das heißt, wir brauchen Gas auch heute als Erdgas und perspektivisch als dekarbonisiertes Gas oder Wasserstoff, um unsere Versorgung zu gewährleisten. Wenn wir Versorgungssicherheit nicht gewährleisten können, dann bricht in der Gesellschaft die Akzeptanz für Klimaneutralität, für diesen Veränderungsprozess weg.
Kann man alles so sagen.
Ist denn Versorgungsknappheit angesagt, wenn wir auf Gas verzichten? Das schon. Wir werden ja jetzt allein, weil wir in den letzten 16 Jahren Merkel so gut wie nichts getan haben für erneuerbare Energien, mit dieser Abhängigkeit von Gas oder Atomstrom erst mal leben müssen. Insofern ist dann zu fragen, woher holt man jetzt das Gas? Macht man das mit dem NATO-Partner ganz alleine? Ist es vielleicht auch sinnvoll, mit Russland die eine oder andere Beziehung aufrechtzuhalten, da ja auch niemand einen heißen Krieg vor der Haustür will? Das ist ja auch ganz erstaunlich, wie da manche bei Twitter so den Eindruck haben, dieses Mal aber werden wir die Demokratie in die Ukraine bringen und alle Menschen werden glücklich sein. Nur ich frage mich aber, zu welchem Preis? Und es ist doch, will doch auch niemand mehr. Und auch die amerikanischen Soldaten wollen nicht und so. Also ich frage mich immer, was diese Art von Serbel rasseln soll. Ich finde es gut, dass jetzt Baerbock da auch Töne anschlägt, die jetzt Merkel nicht angeschlagen hätte und von Maas auch nicht zu erwarten sind. Aber natürlich muss es immer um eine deeskalierende Strategie gehen. Da ist ja auch nichts zu gewinnen in dem Sinne. Aber wir werden uns ja schon in den nächsten Jahren erstmal mit einer Abhängigkeit abfinden müssen, die gemacht ist durch das Unterlassen der vergangenen Jahre.
Genau. Das, worüber wir hier reden, ist ein ganz kleiner Shift, eine ganz kleine Weggabelung, ob wir jetzt den einen Pfad in zwei Wege teilen und dann sagen, das ist aber wirklich ein grüner Pfad. Und der kriegt zwei Prozent mehr Profit als der andere. Das heißt nicht, dass man den anderen nicht gehen darf oder so. Das heißt nur, dass es diese bevorzugte Förderung nicht mehr gibt. Es geht also gar nicht um so viel. Langfristig gesehen dann schon. Aber für 2022 geht es erstmal um nicht besonders viel. Und das richtig Dramatische ist, dass wir in Deutschland einfach nicht aufgeklärt sind. Wir haben ja immer noch vor Augen, ja gut, wir haben so ein Klimabudget, da sind so CO2 oder CO2-Äquivalente und dann rechnen wir das halt so durch. Dann stellen wir irgendwie fest, im Corona-Jahr 2020 haben wir es kurz gepackt, aber auch nur wegen äußerer Einflüsse. Wir sind einfach alle nicht mehr zur Arbeit und in den Urlaub gefahren. Also ging die Rechnung irgendwie auf. Jetzt ist es irgendwie wieder blöd. Sogar die Rechnung, sogar bei dieser Rechnung belügen wir uns die Tasche. Eigentlich ist unsere Harald-Lesch-Aufregung müsste noch viel größer sein. Eigentlich zerstören wir die Welt noch viel mehr, als wir glauben. Denn unsere Erdgas und wie viel CO2 kommt denn eigentlich raus oder CO2-Äquivalente, Hashtag Methan, das wissen wir gar nicht.
Bei der Erdgasförderung entstehen eben diese Methanemissionen. Und die Klimawirkung von Methan ist in den ersten 20 Jahren bis zu 87 Mal stärker und in den ersten 100 Jahren bis zu 36 Mal stärker als das von CO2. Das sagt der IPCC-Bericht, auch im jüngsten IPCC, also Intergovernmental Panel of Climate Change, diese internationalen Klimaberichte, weisen das nochmal deutlich aus. Aber in Deutschland wird immer noch ein viel zu geringer und veralteter Faktor genutzt, um eben diese CO2-Äquivalente von Methanemissionen zu bestimmen. Und das ist hoch problematisch, das müsste man anpassen und auch diese Berechnung über diese Klimaauswirkung von Methan dann auch über diesen langen Zeitraum mit berücksichtigen.
So, es wurde ja mal geregelt, wie man überhaupt dieses CO2 und die Äquivalente misst. Dass man nicht einfach, ja gut, haben wir mal überschlagen, keine Ahnung, das schreibt man mal in die, sondern dass man das wirklich mal standardisiert. Das liegt aber noch nicht viele Jahre zurück, sondern das war jetzt in Glasgow zum Jahreswechsel. Da hat man sich überhaupt mal drauf geeinigt. Und jetzt müssen wir es auch noch anwenden. Also wir sind ganz weit hinten dran mit der Anerkennung, was das hier eigentlich bedeutet. Und kloppen uns jetzt echt mit Frankreich darum und belügen uns dann selbst, sodass plötzlich Atomkraft und Gas, bei dem wir uns durch falsche Rechnung bewusst belügen, das schicken wir noch auf den Zukunftspfad. Und das ist einfach völlig Banane. Peter Carpern, hier noch mal aus dem Deutschlandfunk. Dieser kleine Raumgewinn, den man machen kann, es sollen zumindest nur für den Übergang auch beim Gas gelten.
Dass Gas und Atomkraft in dieser Taxonomie enthalten sein würden. Das war die Nacht des EU-Gipfels hier in Brüssel. Und da hat sich Ursula von der Leyen vor die Presse gestellt und hat gesagt, wir werden erheblich mehr Geld in erneuerbare Energien investieren müssen, aber wir brauchen für die Grundlast Atomkraft und für den Übergang Gaskraftwerke. Und damit war völlig klar, dass diese drei Komponenten erneuerbare Gas und Atomkraft in dieser Taxonomie drin sein würden.
So, Deutschland wollte Gas, Frankreich wollte Atomkraft, Ursula von der Leyen wollte ihr eigenes Vermächtnis schützen, Green Deal. Und jetzt musste sie selber zurückstecken. Sie weiß, genau so kann man diese Ziele nie erreichen. Und hat sie zumindest noch auf, lasst uns wenigstens eine Übergangsregelung, dass es nur für den Übergang gilt. So irrsinnig das auch ist, bei Atomkraft von Übergangstechnologie zu sprechen. Aber lass uns wenigstens das in die Richtung drücken. Nun gut, so konnte sie das dann verkünden. Es ist zumindest für den Übergang. Vielleicht regiert dann jemand anders. Und dann wird das auch, dann ist das sozusagen tradiert. Und vielleicht hat bis dahin der Markt sowieso alles eingeholt. Wir hören hier mal kurz Ursula von der Leyen im O-Ton. Denn es gibt ja noch eine weitere Sache. Wir haben ja schon gesagt, es gibt viele Labels. Was macht die EU-Taxonomie so besonders?
Na, einen Punkt gibt es da schon noch. Die Taxonomie ist ein Prüfsiegel für Finanzprodukte. Es ist für Privatanleger und es gibt den Privatanlegern Transparenz. Es zeigt ihnen, ob ein Finanzprodukt zum Übergang zur Klimaneutralität beiträgt.
So, es hat sie hier auf Französisch die privaten Investoren hervorgehoben, um die Geld, denen soll das signalisiert werden, wie ihr Geld verwendet wird. Stimmt aber gar nicht. Klautia Kämpfert klärt uns ja auch noch mal auf. Es geht natürlich auch um die Regulierung. Was machen wir eigentlich mit staatlichem Fördergeld? Das orientiert sich ja dann auch daran.
Schwierig wird es ja auch vor allem, weil es ja auch mal um Fördergelder dann geht. Wenn die EU, sage ich mal, 100 Milliarden zu verteilen hat, dann richtet sie sich ja auch nach der Liste. Und da geht es ja dann wirklich auch um richtig viel Geld.
Ja, ganz genau, darum geht es hier auch. Also, es geht um richtig viel Geld. Es geht um Subventionen und Atomenergie rechnet sich nur mit riesigen Subventionen. Wenn da die Fördergelder dann verteilt werden, geht das eben jetzt in diese Kanäle. Und das ist tatsächlich nicht nachhaltig. Also, wenn Länder investieren wollen und da stranded investments, also herausgeschmissenes Geld praktisch für Investitionen ausgeben wollen, sollen sie das selber tun, aber bitte nicht mit EU-Geld. Das ist tatsächlich der Fehler.
Also, die EU hat jetzt sich ein Delegated Act genommen. Sie kann also selbst entscheiden. Hat sich dann natürlich ein bisschen breitschlagen lassen von Frankreich. Und Deutschland, um sich die Treue zu sichern. Gleichzeitig hat sich die EU aber auch, wie wir wissen, wegen Corona schon selbst verschuldet, wird also auch fürs Klima wahrscheinlich noch Eigenmittel aufnehmen. Wozu eigentlich? Na, um dann Atomkraft zu fördern. Also das ist das Ergebnis der Taxonomie irgendwie.
Es ist ja tragisch. Und ich frage mich auch, ob es so sein wird, dass wir jetzt plötzlich ein interessantes Land bzw. Europa ein interessanter Kontinent wird für Amerikaner, die jetzt gerade an solchen Mini-Atomkraftwerken arbeiten. Also ob die jetzt versuchen werden, das hier hin zu verkaufen und ob das dann auch gelingt und dass dann auch diese Förderung da anfallen, also dass dann auch sehr viel dahin abfließt und die jetzt gerade eine unglaubliche Jubelstimmung haben, weil sie sehen, okay, das ist doch vielleicht noch eine Zukunftstechnologie, die vielleicht auch nicht nur für den Übergang gedacht ist, denn wenn man mal so kleine Atomkraftwerke als praktikabel verkauft hat und wenn man sagt, die Gefahr eines Chaos ist da auch viel geringer usw. dann könnte man natürlich da doch nochmal was etablieren, wo mit den richtigen Politikern gerade am Hebel und Frankreich ist da ja immer sehr atomaffin gewesen, zumindest was die Regierenden anbelangt, hat man da jetzt vielleicht nochmal sehr gute Investitionschancen, was sehr bedauerlich ist, denn hier wird jetzt sicherlich von Deutschland aus nicht nochmal eine große innovative Atomtechnik kommen, aber in den USA z.B. arbeitet man ja ganz, ganz stark daran und bekommt da auch sehr viele Gelder, auch dann von Bill Gates und Co. so dass das vielleicht dann doch noch ein längeres Thema für uns werden wird. Und was wir natürlich machen, ist hier wieder einmal Probleme verschieben in die ganz, ganz weite Zukunft.
In Europa gibt es jetzt staatliches Spielgeld, um solche Atomträume wahr werden zu lassen. Die Amerikaner haben ihren eigenen Druck. 17% plus bei der Kohleverstromung im Jahresvergleich. Das ist auch so eine Bilanz des ersten Jahres. Beiden zwei Clips noch. Zum einen, was wäre wünschenswert? Steffi Lemke, unsere Umweltministerin, hat es bei Lanz mal kurz thematisiert. Ein Dekarbonisierungsekt, der die Taxonomie mal begleitet, wäre echt cool gewesen.
Wir sagen, und auch das tut die Bundesregierung gemeinsam, dass wir kurzfristig Gas als Übergangstechnologie brauchen werden. Wir können nicht aus Atomkraft und Kohle aussteigen und genau in den gleichen Zeiträumen auch komplett aus Erdgas aussteigen. Das steht auch so im Koalitionsvertrag. Dafür hätte es aber dieses Nachhaltigkeitssiegel nicht gebraucht, das ja langfristig wirken soll. Das zielt nicht auf Übergangstechnologien ab. Und deshalb wäre es viel besser gewesen, hätte die EU-Kommission eine Art Dekarbonisierungsekt vorgelegt. dort geklärt, wie mit Übergangstechnologien umgegangen werden soll. Der Vorschlag stand im Raum, der ist nicht verfolgt worden. Ich bedauere das.
Kann man ja immer noch verfolgen. Auf der anderen Seite, wir haben hier im Podcast auch schon häufiger darüber gesprochen, die politischen Ansehen, die sind alle irgendwie ein bisschen gescheitert. Das über die Preise zu regeln, ist sehr verheißungsvoll. Kann gelingen, wenn man natürlich die Preise dann auch entsprechend strukturiert. Na ja, geben wir das letzte Wort. Kempfert, Claudia Kempfert, sie gibt so ein ganz sachliches Fazit. Und da fällt da nochmal so ein Begriff, bei dem wir einfach denken müssen, vielleicht sollte das auch einfach mal der Aufhänger sein.
Warum nutzen wir nicht mal diese gesamte Energie, die wir immer für solche vergangenen Technologie da uns damit beschäftigen müssen für die echte Energiewende, die so viel billiger, sicherer, friedensstiftender ist? Und das sind die erneuerbaren Energien auf der ganzen Welt.
Friedensstiftender, so ein Windrad ist unglaublich friedensstiftend. Keine Pipeline, kein Krieg, kein Öl, das irgendwo anders rausgebuttelt werden muss.
Keine Kartelle, keine Spekulation an der Börse auf Energie, die andere wieder benachteiligt und und und. Ich glaube, das ist eigentlich das große Thema, also dass man hier nochmal Frieden sichern kann durch Energie, durch alternative erneuerbare Energie. Ja, es ist sehr traurig und wir bleiben ein bisschen so. Also ich kann jetzt nicht mit etwas heiteren schließen. Und ich will es auch nur kurz anreißen. Es war wieder Weltwirtschaftsforum in Davos. Und wieder hat es nicht richtig stattgefunden, sondern nur via Webcam. Es soll einige Monate später dann tatsächlich mal wieder ein richtiges Treffen geben. Aber es waren natürlich die Spitzen der verschiedenen Regierungen zu Gast, unter anderem auf Olaf Scholz. Und wir versuchen das jetzt wirklich ganz abzukürzen. Und ich will nur auf so ein paar Aspekte hinweisen. Da ist erstmal auffällig, dass Olaf Scholz Harari zitiert.
Eine der meisten wunderschöneren Stätten, die ich während der Pandemie gehört habe, kam von der israelischen Historin und Autor Yuval Harari.
Haben wir nicht schon gehört, dass die auch so pseudosexuelle Verhältnisse eingehendivieren?
Das in der Tat. Aber wir hören hier Kooperation. Das ist etwas, was wir Menschen tun können. Und das soll ja auch immer leitend sein bei allem, was da in Davos gesagt wird. Man will miteinander kooperieren. Das verstehen offenbar nicht alle so. Indiens Präsident Modi war auch da. Aber nach Kooperation klang das nicht. Sondern er hat einfach mal so gesagt, hier könnt ihr investieren, hier geht es richtig voran.
Over 5 million software developers are working in India. Today India has the third largest number of unicorns in the world. Over 10.000 startups have been registered in the last six months.
Unicorns sind doch noch mal besondere. Hatten die echt so viele, milliardenschwere?
Er sagt, dass Unicorns blühen ohne Ende. Er geht dann später noch mal drauf ein. Ich habe den Ausschnitt jetzt nicht mitgebracht, aber mehrere Staatspräsidenten sind dort und berichten immer davon, wie viele Unicorns sie jetzt haben. Das scheint wohl jetzt eine neue Währung zu sein, mit denen man immer anbeten will, wir haben 60 Unicorns, wir haben 50 in einem Jahr. Auch wie bezahlt wird es für Modi, der ja das Bargeld, also das Kleingeld abgeschafft hat, sehr wichtig? Ja, auch das soll uns jetzt mal ein Vorbild sein und er weist auch noch mal darauf hin, wir haben das mit dem Wirtschaftswachstum die ganze Zeit auch während der Pandemie gut hinbekommen, was er natürlich ausklammert ist, dass er ja seiner Bevölkerung extremsten Schaden zugefügt hat, dass er die ja wirklich von eine Welle in die nächste laufen ließ und dass ihn das alles nicht interessiert hat. Und er zeigt jetzt aber nur auf das BIP und sagt, der läuft doch prima. So, also wir haben hier die lockere Geldpolitik gemacht der Westen, aber Indien hat weiter strikt an den Reformen festgehalten und nur deshalb konnten sie so prosperieren. Also es ist schon der Wahnsinn, was sich Modi hier erlaubt und er zählt natürlich auch wieder irgendwas über Nachhaltigkeit, aber das lassen wir gleich ganz weg. Man könnte auch eigentlich alles weglassen, was Scott Morrison da sagt, der Premier von Australien. Es ist nur ärgerlich. Er ist ja eigentlich ein Klimawandel-Leugner oder zumindest Skeptiker und seine Idee, wie das jetzt alles zu lösen ist, ist für ihn aber ganz klar Technologie.
Wenn das nicht passiert, dann wird alles nichts ändern und die Emissionen werden weiter aufwachsen.
Also Morrison geht ja gerne mal auf die Bühne mit einem Stück Kohle in der Hand. Im Wahlkampf. Der Ansicht ist, ein Verweis auf Technologie statt auf Rohstoff, schon mal ein Fortschritt.
In der Tat, er sagt dann auch, wir kooperieren ja schon mit den ganzen Ländern, um zu helfen. Und dann zählt er aber Deutschland, Großbritannien und Japan auf und tut aber so, als würde er was für die Entwicklungshilfe leisten. Es ist wahnsinnig absurd und ich würde aber auch in Frage stellen, ist da jemand wirklich für ein Verständnis für Technologie vorhanden? Also ist das ein Mann, der das in irgendeiner Weise begriffen hat? Denn der klingt jetzt zumindest so, als hätte er in der Konferenz aus der Telefonzelle heraus teilgenommen. Aber das ist bei diesem ganzen Kongress so, dass man sich wundert, man hat es damit sehr mächtigen, sehr reichen Leuten zu tun. Hätte man da nicht mal für 150 Euro das Stück Podcast-Mikrofone verschicken können? Absurd. Es war auch der Vizepräsident von Nigeria da, Yemi Osinbayo, und auch er äußert sich zur Taxonomie. Das ist ja was, was man auch einbedenken muss. Wir haben es da mit sehr unterentwickelten Ländern auch zum Teil zu tun, die jetzt gar nicht die Möglichkeit haben, wie wir. Also wir konnten ja auf Gas verzichtet haben. Das haben wir aus anderen Gründen nicht getan, um ja nicht irgendetwas in unserem Wohlstand anzugeben. Aber wir müssen natürlich in der globalen Perspektive sehen, für so ein Land ist es jetzt nicht möglich zu sagen, hier macht mal. Ursula von der Leyen spricht auch in Davos und sagt dann, wir haben da ganz tolle Ideen, wie Afrika viel mehr Sonnenenergie und alles nutzen kann, das mag ja gut sein. Aber es ist ja auch erstmal so, dass in solchen Ländern das Geld nicht selbst vorhanden ist dafür und man natürlich dann auch wieder Leute in eine Schuldenfalle rein bewegt und dass es nicht darum nur geht, dass Europa den Afrikanern da helfen will, wenn die mit der erneuerbaren Energie um die Ecke kommen.
Ja, also im Rentnerpublik habe ich auch so ein Argument drin, wir in der westlichen Welt, wir schrumpfen jetzt. Damit sinkt auch immer so ein bisschen die Innovationskraft, denn das kommt vor allem von jungen Leuten. Also die tollen Entwicklungen werden eigentlich immer so U40, U30 gemacht. Was bedeutet, dass wir unter schwierigen Voraussetzungen jetzt Innovation technologisch zeigen müssen, mit nur einem Ziel, das Zeug dann nach Afrika zu verschenken? Denn das einzige, mit dem die uns das vergüten können, dass wir ihnen die Technologie kostenlos zur Verfügung stellen, ist, dass sie nicht den billigsten Weg gehen und einfach jede Kohle und alles, was da im Boden liegt, einfach verfeuern. Denn das hält Bevölkerungswachstum von einer Milliarde dann nicht stand. Das haben wir ja natürlich hier in Europa schon mal vorgemacht. Das hebt nicht das Lesch-Argument auf, weil wir haben es alles schon so weit zerstört, dass nur noch 10% plus bedeutet, dann ist alles vorbei. Wenn noch mal 100% dazukommen, dann ist es wirklich finito.
Aber du hast jetzt gerade schon was Schönes reingebracht. Wir dürfen nicht geizig sein, sondern wir müssen freigebig sein. Wir müssen sagen, hier sind die Technologien dafür. Aber es scheitert ja schon bei den Impfungen. Und ich würde gerne da einen ganz kurzen Blog nochmal zu machen, denn das war auch Thema in Davos und wir müssen das einfach nochmal ansprechen. Also erstmal hören wir jetzt nochmal Scholz, der im übrigen Jahr im Gegensatz zu Merkel hier auf Englisch auch vorträgt.
Weil die so wahnsinnig teuer sind.
Genau, die sind so wahnsinnig teuer. Wir hatten ja da mal von Adam Tews schon mal so ein Interview oder wir haben es beide bei Twitter geteilt, wo er sagte, ja Deutschland könnte das doch eigentlich gut selbst finanzieren. Schulden sind gerade günstig, würde eigentlich noch Geld dabei verdienen und könnte die ganze Welt impfen lassen. Also wir haben ja immer gesagt, wir brauchen jetzt gar nicht so sehr über dieses Patentrechtliche zu sprechen. Aber wir können einfach mal sagen, wir könnten auch, wenn alles mal so bleibt, das locker finanzieren. Das sagt auch Yemi Osenbayo von Nigeria. Es wäre absolut finanzierbar und wäre überhaupt gar kein Problem. Wir sind die einzige Region im Welt, die weiter aus der Ausgabe oder. Ja, die meisten davon wurden aber bezahlt und die meisten davon gingen in die Türkei, nach Großbritannien, also da waren auch keine armen Länder dabei. Das ist so was von verrückt, dass das hier nochmal so hervorgetan wird, als wäre Europa der Retter der Welt. Nein, ganz im Gegenteil, die Patente will man nicht freigeben. Das hat natürlich auch Gründe, die einfach darin liegen, dass jede Volkswirtschaft in der internationalen Konkurrenz besonders gut dastehen will. BioNTech spielt eine ganz, ganz große Rolle für unsere Volkswirtschaft inzwischen.
0, 5 Prozent BIP.
Ja, 0, 5 Prozent BIP, da wird dann auch ein HWK plötzlich nicht mehr für die Patentfreigabe sein. Und man fragt sich ja, aber warum wird dann eigentlich so wenig gemacht? Oder worauf wartet man dann noch, wenn man das doch über Spenden klären könnte? Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt hier eine Antwort von Ursula von der Leyen.
Vaccine manufacturing mRNA technologies. What we've already started with Senegal, South Africa and Rwanda is that we go in a public-private partnership together in this case with BioNTech to bring the technology to the continent to Africa and together with our African partners to have private capital to come in to de-risk that capital and to create manufacturing capacities in these regions.
Ja, ich will mal zitieren aus einem Tagesspiegelartikel, Zitat, bei der Bestellung scheint ein Fehler passiert zu sein. Die Überschrift dieses Textes ist, Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach bestellte offenbar zu viel Impfstoff. Deutschland hat zu viel und zwar wegen diesem Theater, das Lauterbach verkündet hat, ich hab Inventur gemacht, wir haben zu wenig. Ich habe aber alles geregelt, beruhigen sie sich, der Retter ist jetzt da. Ich habe ausreichend bestellt, stellt sich drei Wochen später aus, viel zu viel. Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig.
Klar sagt man, da können wir noch einen Private-Public-Partnership-Kram aufbauen in Afrika und können da nochmal ordentlich absahnen. Denn darum geht es natürlich, das wird jetzt hier so ein bisschen geschildert, wie wir helfen den Afrikanern. Das ist ja nicht der Fall. Also es ist eigentlich beschämend, das zu sehen und das Traurige ist, dass Europa nicht begreift, dass es hier so wunderbar diplomatisch, geopolitisch, gescheit arbeiten könnte. Denn was China jetzt ja gerade abliefert, ist einfach verrückt. Also wir haben das jetzt schon besprochen mit Corona. Dann spricht da Xi und wir müssen uns jetzt gerade vergegenwärtigen. China, die Volksrepublik, verklagt gerade Litauen, weil Litauen, nein, es ist andersrum. Litauen wird boykottiert von China. Litauen hat lauter Sanktionen bekommen, da die Länder, es wird nichts mehr exportiert nach China. Oder China nimmt nichts mehr an und will auch nicht mehr das andere mit Litauen zusammenarbeiten, weil Litauen diplomatische Kontakte zu Taiwan gepflegt hat und sich auch sonst nicht solidarisch mit China verhält. Litauen will jetzt zusammen mit der EU dagegen klagen. China sagt, ne, wir wollen das aber jetzt hier nicht, dass das auf die große Bühne kommt, das klären wir ja unter uns, was natürlich eine unglaubliche Hierarchie ist, wenn die Volksrepublik das mit dem kleinen Litauen klären soll und da soll sich die EU mal raushalten. Also man ist nur auf Konfrontation aus, sobald irgendetwas nicht in den Kram passt. Und sei es nur das Ende von Fight Club, dass man dann sagt, ne, also dass da alles in die Luft liegt, das geht nicht, wir müssen auch noch mal das Ende umbasteln. Wie im Buch. Und jetzt ist Xi da, jetzt ist Xi dort zugeschaltet in Davos. Und wofür spricht er sich aus? Für mehr Kooperation.
Ja.
The right way forward for humanity is peaceful development.
Ja, das kann man natürlich immer schön sagen, wenn man exakt das Gegenteil macht und eigentlich dann nur noch mal dort ist, um ein bisschen Werbung für die One Belt One Road Initiative zu machen. Weiter sagt uns sie noch.
Genau.
Different countries and civilizations may prosper together on the basis of respect for each other and seek common ground and win-win outcomes by setting aside differences. We should follow the trend of history, work for a stable international order, advocate common values of humanity and build a community with a shared future for mankind. We should choose dialogue over confrontation.
Ich krieg langsam so eine Chi-Fatigue, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Das ist ja diese Präampelprosa die ganze Zeit, das ist unglaublich.
Ja und es entspricht so gar nicht der Wirklichkeit. Also da kann man ja bei Trump wenigstens noch sagen, ja der wollte protektionistisch sein und hat das auch genau so formuliert und hat dann niemanden im Unklaren gelassen, aber hier zum einen laufend das Land abzuschotten wegen Lockdowns, dann auch Ausländer die in China arbeiten nicht mehr einreisen zu lassen oder nicht mehr ausreisen zu lassen und dann auch noch so weit zu sein, dass man sagt, wenn jetzt irgendwo in Ländern schlecht über China geredet wird, dann geht uns das sehr wohl was an und dann werden wir da auch mal mit Sanktionen usw. gleich anrücken und dann auf Kooperation auszugehen und eigentlich so eine Entpolitisierung der Wirtschaftspolitik einzufordern, wenngleich man sie eigentlich die ganze Zeit politisiert. Die Weltwirtschaft ist schon verrückt und dann noch von gemeinsamen Grundlagen, menschenrechtliche Art zu sprechen und wir denken an die Uiguren und es ist kaum noch auszuhalten, also wie gesagt, ich kann diese ganzen Davos Clips nicht empfehlen, sich anzusehen, außer Janet Yellen ist dort zu Gast. Die Finanzministerin der USA hat da Gelegenheit noch mal zu zeigen, wie eigentlich jetzt moderne Wirtschaftspolitik funktioniert und Finanzpolitik funktioniert. Sie setzt sich da mit dem Keynesianismus auseinander, sagt, ich will das jetzt gar nicht genau differenzieren, wie wir da in eine andere Richtung gehen oder weiter gehen als Keynes, aber sie macht ganz deutlich, wovon sie sich absetzt bei dieser modernen Angebotspolitik, wie sie das jetzt nennt. Bislang war es ja immer so gewesen, dass man sagte, Angebotspolitik heißt, wir brauchen mal Steuererleichterungen für die Unternehmen. Trump hat die ja dann noch mal so richtig groß mit der Gießkanne ausgegossen. Und dann wird sich ja das mit der Wirtschaft schon alles prima entwickeln.
Und ist auch die Linie von Friedrich Merz. Jetzt gerade, wo wir sprechen, äußert er sich zum Privalergebnis. Er ist ja jetzt der neue Mann.
Und da erteilt Jelland dem ganz klar noch mal eine Absagung sagt, nee, das hat nicht funktioniert und wir brauchen auch eine starke Erwerbsbevölkerung.
Potential GDP in the United States is constrained by a declining labor force.
Ja, wir kommen jetzt in die neue Phase. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie das bei euch dann in Wohlstand für alle auch so themblog wahrscheinlich mäßig abgehandelt wird, dass wir Vollbeschäftigung haben, also hundertprozentige Auslastung der Wirtschaft, dass wir hier nicht einfach mehr nur von Immobilien sprechen, wenn es um Limitierung geht, sondern wirklich auch um Beschäftigtenzahl, Bewerberzahl, Zulieferung, was so zugeliefert wird, Zulieferleistung und so weiter. Weil das wird ja alles limitiert jetzt.
Manche sagen schon, wir haben immer von Arbeitslosigkeit gesprochen. Inzwischen müssen wir von Arbeiterlosigkeit sprechen. Richtig. Also ist das jetzt ein neuer Begriff, den wir brauchen. Und wie gehen wir damit um? Wir haben ja schon mal oder nicht nur einmal über Zuwanderung gesprochen. Das ist das heikle Thema, das alle irgendwie umgehen wollen. Aber hier ist es nochmal ganz deutlich von Jellen gesagt, dass man investieren muss, nicht nur in Infrastruktur, sondern auch in die Möglichkeiten, die Menschen haben bei ihrer Berufswahl, denn sonst vergrößert sich die Ungleichheit immer weiter. Zwei Mal jetzt auch der Rückbezug auf die 70er Jahre. Also das ist jetzt ein Problem, dass wir seit 50 Jahren mit uns rumtragen und wir gehen das jetzt vielleicht mal an oder man hat das vor, das anzugehen. Es ist ja absurd, wenn man sich das vorstellt. Als letztes noch ein Clip, wo jetzt zu wenig investiert wurde.
Ich meine, die Amerikaner kommen mit unglaublichen Bildungskrediten aus ihrer Bildungslaufbahn raus. So viel Schulden, dass man quasi 30 Jahre braucht, um sie abzubezahlen und keine private Insolvenzverfügung oder irgendetwas an diesem Status ändert. Und gleichzeitig stellt man fest, es mangelt an allem. Wir haben keine frühkindliche Bildung, wir haben schlechte Schulen, alles schlecht. Die Unis haben einfach so ein bisschen da oben abgegriffen, also ein bisschen wahnsinnig viel. Alles andere liegt komplett da nieder, was auch wichtig ist für die Grundausbildung. Unglaubliche Zustände.
Ja, und ein sehr deprimierendes Wirtschaftsforum. Mal gespannt, wie es sein wird, wenn die sich treffen. Aber wenn man es so global sieht, was das Klima anbelangt, was auch die Ungleichheit anbelangt, dann ist das doch sehr dramatisch. Also Yellen und Xi waren die einzigen, die überhaupt mal das Wort Ungleichheit ausgesprochen haben, wenn ich das jetzt recht in Erinnerung habe. Es ist doch sehr traurig. Hast du noch was Lustiges, noch einen Clip, mit dem wir abschließen? Was ist das, ich sehe hier das, ich kann ja, um das jetzt allen zu sagen, die uns ja hier nicht sehen können, ich kann ja hier immer sehen, welche Clips alle aufgelistet sind. Und hier gibt es einen Clip, da heißt es, Olaf Scholz, schönen Dank für die Frage, Zusammenschnitt von Scholz Antworten. Was ist das?
Also, Olaf Scholz hat ja seine erste Befragung im Bundestag gemacht, die reguläre, quartalswesige Kanzlerinnen-Kanzler-Befragung. Ich habe sie weder im Original gehört, noch mir irgendwie, ich wollte es einfach nicht hören, es steckt ja nichts drin. Und im Ausklang des Deutschlandfunk Politikpodcast 238 haben sie noch mal einen Zusammenschnitt gemacht, von dem ich denke, ja, das passt, da kommt, glaube ich, der Olaf Scholz, wie er sich geben wollte, gut rüber.
Schönen Dank für Ihre Frage, auch für die Gelegenheit. Schönen Dank auch für diese Frage zu einem ganz konkreten Fall. Schönen Dank für Ihre Frage und auch für die, aber nicht für die Intention, die dahinter steckt. Schönen Dank für die Frage.
Ich danke Ihnen, Herr Bundeskanzler, ich beende die Befragung.
Schönen Dank, können wir auch sagen. Und wir möchten aber noch auf den Salon verweisen. Wir sprechen über das Buch Anfänge, eine andere Geschichte der Menschheit von David Graeber und David Bencroft, die es zusammen geschrieben haben. Und das ist Graebers Vermächtnis. Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf. Es wird ja schon heiß diskutiert und ich glaube auch, das wird eine ausführliche Besprechung dieses Werkes werden. Und hast du sonst schon was im Petto, was du nennen kannst?
Einiges, müsste ich jetzt noch mal raussuchen. Ich sehe allerdings gerade, dass meine gedruckte Version immer noch, und jetzt steht sie bei Amazon wieder mit, wird bis 22 Uhr geliefert. Was immer heißt, kommt am nächsten Tag, am Freitag stand schon mal, kommt bis 22 Uhr. Es ist also immer so ein bisschen Drama, was da auch drin steckt. Ich kann aber noch mal meine...
Ich kaufe ja die Bücher noch in der Buchhandlung und da ist es selbstverständlich...
Nein, so modern bin ich nicht. Die Querdenker Szene, von der immer alle meinen, sie sind hochgradig organisiert, da kennen sich alle. Nein, da treffen sich die radikal Einsamen. Noch nicht gelesen, aber ich bin sehr gespannt. Außerdem werden die Baseballschlägerjahre noch mal auch aus biografischer Sicht rückblickend in der FAZ unter dem Titel Blutige Landschaften beschrieben. Wir haben ja schon über Containerschifffahrt gesprochen. Klimawandelstudie zeigt, wie Schifffahrt nachhaltig werden kann. Da bin ich ein bisschen überrascht, dass das im Raume steht. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es geht. Wie beim Flugverkehr hätte ich gedacht, dafür brauchen wir noch ordentlich energiedichte Öl. Sachen, die wir da einfach verfeuern. In der Hinsicht exklusive Daten aus Langzeitstudie, die Wahrheit über das Homeoffice in fünf Grafiken. Solche Sachen habe ich in meiner Liste. Ich werde sie dann mal genau durchgehen, aber ich freue mich auch vor allem auf David Graeber. Vielleicht komme ich dann Mitte der Woche dazu, auch noch ein bisschen auf echtem Papier zu lesen.
Ich werde keine langen Texte oder nicht allzu lange Texte mitbringen, denn wir werden ja schon mit gebotener Ausführlichkeit über Graeber sprechen müssen und deshalb wird es einmal um die Frage gehen in einem Interview, haben wir eigentlich in Deutschland eine Klassenjustiz und wenn ja, wie schlägt sich das nieder? Und ich möchte auch etwas empfehlen zum Thema Kryptowährung, Web3, Metaverse, also diese Fragen der neuen Finanztechnologien und Währungen, da gibt es einen interessanten Lesestoff, da will ich auf etwas verweisen, was mich doch sehr beeindruckt hat. Und dann schaue ich mal, was ich noch so auswähle, es ist auf jeden Fall einiges im Angebot und dann sehen wir uns im Salon.
Sehr gut, haut rein, bis dahin.
Bis dann.